MORE LUCK PAN ROTH SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER BY KASKI.
AND THEY
WILL BE GETTING STARTED CENTERS
MITCHELL NIELSEN WELL CABALLERO
DOLLY HER DAUGHTER JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MY NAME MORE LOCK PAN
ROTH SKINNER STERN NUMBER BY
COSTING. THE GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THE SECRETARY.
TECHNOLOGY IS THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM HOWEVER IN THAT WE ARE
NOT TAKING VOTES TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED. AS A SUB COMMITTEE OF
THE FULL COMMITTEE ONCE WE-
HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL PAUSE AND
ESTABLISH IT. LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR IN THIS IS
JOINING US THIS MORNING FOR THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY WILL DISCUSS ISSUES
RELATED TO THE STATE'S PRISON
POPULATION. OVER THE LAST
DECADE LARGELY DRIVEN BY
FEDERAL COURT ORDERS CALIFORNIA
ADOPTED POLICIES THAT RESULTED
IN A DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE INCARCERATED IN STATE
PRISONS AND BEING SUPERVISED ON
PAROLE. AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED ITS
INTENTION TO DRIVE DOWN
CONTRACTED FACILITIES AND
EVENTUALLY CLOSE A STATE
FACILITY. GIVEN THIS PROPOSAL
IT'S IMPORTANT WE DISCUSSED THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE ITS
PRISON POPULATION. COVER THE
STATE'S FUTURE PLANS TO
ACCOMMODATE A DECLINE IN MAY
POPULATION. AND DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF RE ENTRY AND
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES FOR THE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED. WILL
BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING WITH SOME
CONTEXT HOW WE GOT HERE AND
WHAT THE CURRENT POPULATION IS
WITH THE PRESENTATION FROM THE
ALEJO AND FINANCE. NEXT
REPRESENTED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION LED BY SECRETARY
DHEAS WILL DISCUSS THE POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS. THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IN PLACE TO
FACILITATE POPULATION REDUCTION.
DR SCOTT WERE REESE AT THE CAL
BUT POLICY CENTER WILL THEN
DISCUSS THE CHALLENGES AND
REFORM TO CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
COGNIZANT OF AND COMMENT ON
LESSONS THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM
OTHER STATES. THE FINAL PANEL
WILL DISCUSS TRANSITIONAL AND
PULSE RELIEF SERVICES. KEITH
WHAT WE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ON COMMON LAW WE
JUST RECOGNIZE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR HIS- IRVINE
FOUNDATION RECOGNITION AND DOUG
BOND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
AMITY FOUNDATION WILL DISCUSS
BARRIERS THAT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FACE. UPON
RE ENTRY FROM THEIR OWN SERVICE
PROVIDER PERSPECTIVE. AND
FINALLY WILL HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF HEARING FROM ALL SELL
JOHNSON. WHO CURRENTLY WORKS AT
AMITY FOUNDATION AND WILL BE
OUR FINAL SPEAKER AND WILL GIVE
THE COMMITTEE THE FIRST PERSON
PERSPECTIVE AS A FORMAL
INCARCERATED PERSON AND NOW AS
A PROVIDER OF SERVICES TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. BEFORE AND UPON RE
ENTRY. ALEX THIS IS A- IN
DISCUSSION WE'VE THAT WOULD
AFFECT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR FRAMING IT- IN FROM A
VARIETY PERSPECTIVES TO GIVE US
A GREAT TEN THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL
PERSPECTIVE AS WE CONSIDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED STRATEGY IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET I'D LIKE TO
REMIND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
THIS IS TEN THOUSAND FOOT
PERSPECTIVE- WE ARE JOINED
TODAY BY- THE SUB COMMITTEE
CHAIRWOMAN. SENATOR SKINNER WHO
WILL HAVE THE PRIVILEGE AN
PPORTUNITY- AND IN HER
CAPACITY SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR TO-
DELVE MUCH MORE DEEPLY INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF- THE CORRECTIONS
BUDGET AND I'M SURE SENATOR
SKINNER WOULD INVITE ANY MEMBER
THE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
JOIN HER- AS THE COMMITTEE
AGENDAS BECOME PUBLIC IF THERE
ARE PARTICULAR ISSUES YOU WOULD
LIKE MORE INFORMATION ON. OF
ALL GOING TO SUGGEST MEMBER
BASED ON OUR- EXPERIENCE- IN
THE PAST AS WELL AS THE FACT
THAT I- BIG KNOWLEDGE IN
RESPECT THE FACT THAT OUR FINAL
PANEL ARE PEOPLE WHO'VE
TRAVELED- TO GET HERE THAT I'M
GOING TO ASK IF IT- IS OKAY
WITH OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
WE HOLD. ALL QUESTIONS AND TO
ALL THREE PANELS PRESENTED- I
DON'T WANT TO GET STUCK IN A
BOTTLE NECK WITH THE FIRST
COUPLE OF PANELS AND THE IN. A
PROLONGED THE WEIGHT OF OUR
THIRD PANEL BUT I ALSO WANT TO
LOSE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AND YOU
MISS THE OPPORTUNITY OF HEARING
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE THIRD
PANEL- IS THAT COMFORTABLE THE
ONE. WE HAD LONG TALK ABOUT.
YOU CERTAINLY CAN'T AND WHILE
YOU DO THAT I WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE COMMITTEE. IF I
APPRECIATE COMMITTEE MAY. YOUR
IN. WITH THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
INVITE THE FIRST PANEL TO JOIN
US FROM ELLIE AND FINANCE. WITH
THIS ONE OFTEN WILL YOU BE
LEADING OFF OR WILL- MISS
O'NEILL HOW ARE WE GOING TO
FRAME THIS. AT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU GOOD THANK YOU
GET MORE. CAITLYN O'NEILL AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW
OF RECENT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICY CHANGES AND THEIR EFFECT
ON THE STATE'S INMATE
POPULATION I'LL BE SPEAKING
FROM A HANDOUT THAT I BELIEVE
MAY HAVE BEEN IN YOUR BRIEFING
MATERIALS AND IF NOT THE
SERGEANTS HAVE EXTRA COPIES
GREAT- THAT'S I BELIEVE
FINANCES UP SORRY. SARS IS
CALLED IMPACT OF RECENT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICIES ON
THE STATE'S INMATE POPULATION
THAT'S RIGHT YES WE HAVE IT ARE
A GREAT AND THERE SHOULD BE
EXTRA COPIES FOR THE AUDIENCE
AS WELL. OKAY MEANING TO PAGE
ONE. IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
AND IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
FEDERAL COURTS RULED THAT THE
STATE'S PROVISION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND MEDICAL CARE
FOR INMATES WAS
CONSTITUTIONALLY AN ADEQUATE.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIX AB
PLAINTIFFS IN THOSE TWO
LAWSUITS FILED MOTIONS TO
CONVENE A FOR A FEDERAL THREE
JUDGE PANEL. TO ASSESS FIRST
WHETHER PRISON OVERCROWDING WAS
THE PRIMARY REASON FOR THE
STATE'S INABILITY TO DELIVER
ADEQUATE INMATE HEALTHCARE. AND
SECOND WHETHER PRISONER RLEASE
ORDER WAS THE ONLY WAY TO
REMEDY THOSE CONDITIONS. AND IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE PANEL
DECLARE THAT PERMIT PRISON
OVERCROWDING WAS INDEED THE RE
THE PRIMARY REASON BEHIND THE
STATE'S INABILITY TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE- IN MADE HEALTHCARE.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND TEN THE
PANEL ORDERED THE STATE TO
REDUCE THE CAPACITY OF THE
STATE OWNED PRISONS TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN POINT 5% OF THEIR
DESIGN CAPACITY. DESIGN
CAPACITY GENERALLY REFERS TO
THE NUMBER OF INMATES THAT
PRISONS COULD HOUSE IF THEY
HAD. ONE INMATE PURCELL AND
GENERALLY DID NOT DOUBLE BUNK
IN DORMITORIES. I AM SO BASED
ON THAT MEASURE CDC ARE- MUCH
CURRENTLY LIMIT THE POPULATION
OF ITS THIRTY FOUR STATE OWNED
PRISONS TWO HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
AT TO ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND INMATES.
BASED ON THEIR CURRENT CAPACITY.
AND THEN TURNING THE PAGE TO
PAGE TWO THE STATE TOOK VARIOUS
ACTIONS TO COMPLY WITH THE
COURT ORDER INCLUDING A
CONTRACTING FOR PRISON CAPACITY
AS WELL AS BUILDING ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY. IN ADDITION THE STATE
IMPLEMENTED VARIOUS POLICY
CHANGES THAT HAVE WRITTEN THAT
ALSO HELP THE STATE TO COMPLY
BY REDUCING THE OVERALL INMATE
POPULATION I'M GOING TO
DESCRIBE THE MAJOR POLICY
CHANGES ON THE NEXT PAGE.
STARTING WITH THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT. WHICH LIMITED WHO
WHO COULD BE SENT TO PRISON-
AND INSTEAD REQUIRED THAT LOWER
LEVEL FELONS GENERALLY A SERVE
THEIR TERM RENTAL AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. AND REQUIRE THAT
COUNTIES SUPERVISE LOWER LEVEL
PHONES GENERALLY WHEN THEY'RE
RELEASED FROM PRISON RATHER
THAN STATE PATROL AGENTS.
PROPOSITION THIRTY SIX WHICH IS
A PROVIDE THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
TWELVE. I CHANGE THE STATE'S
THREE STRIKES LAW- BUT
GENERALLY ELIMINATING A LIFE
SENTENCE FOR OFFENDERS WHO HAVE
TO PRIOR SERIES IN MYLAN
FELONIES ALSO KNOWN AS STRIKES-
AND THEN THEIR THIRD- FELONY IS
NON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT SO
ELIMINATED GENERALLY LIFE
SENTENCES FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS- AS WELL AS A LINE
RE SENTENCING FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY SERVING. TERMS FOR
SERVING THOSE SENTENCES.
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN WHICH
WAS APPROVED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. REDUCE PENALTIES FOR
CERTAIN ON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT
DRUG AND PROPERTY CRIMES AND
ALSO ALLOWED FOR RE SENTENCING.
AND PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
PASSED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN-
REDUCED THE ADULTIN THE OVER
AT REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT INMATES SPEND IN PRISON.
PRIMARILY THROUGH EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR PAROLE
CONSIDERATION AS WELL AS
EXPANDING CCAR'S AUTHORITY TO
REDUCE INMATES TERMS THE
CREDITS. THAT INMATES EARNED
THROUGH PART. IN THE ABILITY
XIN GRAMS AND MAINTAINING GOOD
BEHAVIOR WHILE INCARCERATED.
WHEN THERE'S BEEN VARIOUS OTHER
SENTENCING CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE PAST DECADE.
THAT HAVE IMPACTED THE IN-
INMATE POPULATION THESE ARE
JUST THE MAJOR ONES. IN ON THE
NEXT PAGE YOU'LL SEE A FIGURE
THAT SHOWS THE ON GOING DECLINE
IN THE STATE'S INMATE
POPULATION- BEGINNING IN. HERE
WE SHOW BEGINNING IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHEN THE EFFECTS OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN STARTED
TO TAKE HOLD- AND SPECIFICALLY
THE POPULATION DECLINED- BY
ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED INMATES
ARE 4% BETWEEN JUNE THIRTY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND- JUNE
THIRTY TWENTY NINETEEN. AND IS
PROJECTED TO DECLINE BY IAM
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED INMATES OR
7% OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS THAT
IS UNTIL JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. THIS TO CLIENTS PRIMARILY
THE RESULT OF PROPOSITION FIFTY
SEVEN- DRIVEN BY PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN- AND THEN I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT WE DID ADDRESS
THESE THE PROJECTIONS HERE
SPECIFICALLY TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE- ESTIMATED EFFECTS OF SB
ONE THIRTY SIX- CHOPPERED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH
ELIMINATES A ONE YEAR SENTENCE
FOR PRIOR OFFENSES IN CERTAIN
CASES. AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS LATER WHENEVER IS
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR THIS ONE OFTEN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO WANT
INTRODUCED MY COLLEAGUE GARETH
EDWARDS WHO'S HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL.
A WHAT I'LL BRIEFLY TOUCH ON
THE INVESTMENTS THAT MADE IN
THIS AREA IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AND THEN PROVIDE WITH
MISTER EDWARDS OUR PERSPECTIVE
ON SOME OF THE POPULATION
TRENDS THAT THE LA- DISCUSSED.
TO THE OVERALL CDC ARE BUDGET
THAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN
JANUARY IS THIRTEEN POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AND WITHIN THIS
WHEN IT COMES TO NEW
INVESTMENTS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS REALLY PUTTING AN EMPHASIS
ON REHABILITATION. AND RE ENTRY
THIS BUILDS ON THE INVESTMENT
SIDE OF THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
IN THE BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR-
RANGING FROM COMMUNITY REENTRY
FACILITIES TO INVESTMENTS IN
LITERACY PROGRAMS TO SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS. AS WELL
AS THE TRANSFORMATION OF THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
YOUTH IN COMMITTEE RESTORATION
THAT WILL BE FULLY IN EFFECT
LATER THIS YEAR. IN THE BUDGET
THIS. BUT AND THIS IS HOW TO BE
ABLE TATIAN A RE ENTRY. COMES
IN A NUMBER FORMS A COME IN
TERM OF INVEST IN AT. RANGING
FROM TECHNO INVESTMENTS FOR
VOCATIONAL AND ACADEMIC
TRAINING AS WELL AS INVESTMENTS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION AS IT
RELATES TO INMATES INCLUDING A
NEW PARTNERSHIP WITH.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
THERE'S ALSO A NEW FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL VISITATION DAYS TO
MAINTAIN CONTINUITY OF
RELATIONSHIPS WITH INMATES WITH
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT WILL
FACILITATE SUCCESSFUL REENTRY.
THERE IS TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STAFF
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT TO
INCREASE THE CAPABILITY OF
STAFF AS THEY DEAL WITH
INMATES. AND THEN FINALLY A NEW
PROBATION REFORM INITIATIVE AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION FOR COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. AS WELL
AS ENHANCE JAIL OVERSIGHT. SO
ALL THESE EFFORTS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE INMATES
THEMSELVES FOR FAMILIES AND FOR
COMMUNITIES. THEY'RE ALSO
IMPORTANT HE JUST LOOKING AT
THE STATE BUDGET WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE COSTS OF CDC OUR IN
THE MONEY THAT WE'RE PUTTING
INTO THESE PROGRAMS. AND
CERTAINLY SEE MINISTRATIONS
HOPE OVER TIME TO BE ABLE TO
BEND THE COST CURVE PROMOTE
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE
AND THEN EVENTUALLY AS WE SAVE
MONEY PROJECTED TO WHAT WE
MIGHT SPEND. REPURPOSE. THOSE
FUNDS FOR OTHER PURPOSES. AT
THE LA ALL NINETEEN CAL REMAINS.
TO THE COURT OR- CAP THE ONE
HUNDRED THIRD SEVEN POINT 5% OF
DESIGN. CAPACITY AND THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THE POPULATION AS
REPRESENTED IN THE LA- START
HAS TRENDED DOWNWARD AND IT'S
OUR PROJECTION AND WILL
CONTINUE TO TREND DOWNWARD. IN
FACT BETWEEN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND THE BUDGET YEAR OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE'RE
PROJECTING AN ADDITIONAL
APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND IN MAY
REDUCTION. IN TERMS OF THE
STATE PRISON POPULATION AND
WE'RE SEEING THIS AND SOME OF
THE ACTIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS ABLE TO TAKE
OVER THE LAST YEAR. AS YOU KNOW
LAST JUNE THE ADMINISTRATION-
CDC ARE TERMINATED THE FINAL
OUT OF STATE CONTRACTORS SOLELY
IN ARIZONA. SO THAT NOW ALL
STATE PRISON INMATES ARE HOUSED
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION FACED OUT ANOTHER
PRIVATE IN STATE CONTRACT
FACILITY LAST SEPTEMBER. AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS THREE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IS TO
CONTINUE TO PHASE OUT AND STATE
CONTRACT FACILITIES AND FINALLY
WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THE
GOVERNOR HAS ANNOUNCED AN
INTENTION TO CLOSE THE STATE
PRISON IF CURRENT POPULATION
TRENDS HOLD. AND SO THAT
CERTAINLY THE OBJECTIVE AT THE
SAME TIME I DO WANT TO STRESS
THAT IT'S NOT A GUARANTEE. IS
IF CURRENT POPULAR TRENDS HOLE
AND FURTHERMORE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO SAY RIGHT NOW WHICH PRISON
MIGHT BE SLATED FOR CLOSURE.
THAT'S A FACTOR IS. COME ON
RIGHT CLICK. EIGHT OKAY SO
NOTATION AND RE ENTRY IS TO
MONITOR CARE IS THE POPULATION
CONVENIENT DECLINE WHICH
SEPTEMBER WITH THAT POP OR WE
SEEING THE DECLINE AND THAT
WILL ENABLE TO MAKE THOSE JUDGE
AS THE YEARS GO ON SO- WHEN IT
COMES THAT SPECIFICS OF THOSE
POPULATION NUMBERS WHERE THEY
HAD BEEN IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND WHERE THEY'RE GOING
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER EDWARDS. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING. MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
ERIN EDWARDS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE MAIN
FOCUS OF MY PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING IS GOING TO BE ON
DESCRIBING WHAT WE EXPECT- IN
TERMS OF THE PRISON POPULATION
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
AND HOW WE PLAN TO ADJUST OUR
PRISON CAPACITY ACCORDINGLY-
INCLUDING BY. MEETING THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON PRIVATE CONTRACT
PADS HI AND CLOSING A STATE
PRISON WAS AND- FIVE YEARS. NOW
I THINK THE LA FOR OVER OF KIND
OF WHERE WE'VE FROM IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS BUT I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO. HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE OF KEY POINTS THAT I
THINK PROVIDE SOME IMPORTANT
CONTACTS OF JUST HOW FAR WE'VE
COME- IT WHEN WE WERE AT OUR
PEAK. AT IN TWO THOUSAND SIX OF
THE IN MAY PRISON POPULATION
WE'RE HOUSING HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND INMATES
AT THAT TIME. HI SOME AYE I
KNOW SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE HAVE BEEN AROUND
LONG ENOUGH TO PROBABLY HAVE
VISITED FIRST HAND AND
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT THAT.
LOOK LIKE AND WHAT THAT MEANT
FOR OUR PRISON OPERATIONS-
OTHERS ARE YOU HAVE PROBABLY
SEEN THE PICTURES OF INMATES
HOUSED IN TROUBLE BELONGS IN
AND GYMNASIUMS IN OUR- STATE
INSTITUTIONS- I THINK THAT'S A
RATHER DRAMATIC VISUAL
REPRESENTATION OF JUST HOW
OVERCROWDED. OUR INSTITUTIONS
WERE. WHAT'S MAYBE NOT CONVEYED
IN THOSE PICTURES IS WHAT THE
IMPACT WAS FOR THE APARTMENTS
OPERATIONS. I THINK MANAGING A
PRISON SYSTEM THAT THAT THAT IS
THAT THAT OVERCROWDED- IT
REQUIRES SO MUCH OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S ATTENTION JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- PRISONS ARE
SAFE AND SECURE FOR INMATES AND
STAFF. PRESENTS MAJOR CHEN. TO
PROVIDING- ADEQUATE
CONSTITUTIONAL LEVELS OF HEALTH
CARE HI AND FOCUSING ON IN MAY
REHABILITATION- SO NOW
CONTRACTING TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY- JUST AS OF THIS MORNING
WE ARE HOUSING JUST OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND AND MEN'S- IN OUR
STATE PRISONS. SO THAT'S A
DECLINE OF FIFTY THOUSAND
INMATES IN THE LAST. FOURTEEN
YEARS OR ALMOST 30% AND WHAT
THAT HAS DONE IS REALLY ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO REFOCUS ON
ITS CORE MISSION OF PROVIDING
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES TO- THE
INMATES IN ITS KEREN PREPARING
THEM FOR RE ENTRY INTO SOCIETY
WHEN THEY'VE COMPLETED THEIR
SENTENCES. IN A IN ADDITION
IT'S ALSO ALLOWED US TO REDUCE
OUR RELIANCE ON COSTS THE
CONTRACT CAPACITY. AT ITS PEAK
WE WERE RELYING ON FOURTEEN
THOUSAND CONTRACT BADS IN ORDER
TO MANAGE OUR PRISON
POPULATION. THAT INCLUDED TEN
THOUSAND INMATES AN OUT OF
STATE FACILITIES AND FOUR
THOUSAND AND MANSON IN STATE
CONTRACT FACILITIES I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT AS OF THIS
MORNING WE WERE- DOWN TO. JUST
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED INMATES IN
CONTRACT- IN CONTRACT BALLOTS.
WE WERE AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED
WE WERE ABLE TO BRING BACK THE
LAST OF OUR INMATES FROM OUT OF
STATE- IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SO WE WENT FROM TEN
THOUSAND WERE DOWN ZERO AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE ALSO NOTED WE'VE
ALREADY. BEEN ABLE TO PHASE OUT
ONE PRIVATE CONTRACT FACILITY
IN THE STATE- AS OF SEPTEMBER
TWENTY NINETEEN. SO THAT BRINGS
US KIND OF WHERE WE STAND TODAY
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SIX REMAINING
CONTRACTS FACILITIES THAT
INCLUDES THREE PRIVATE
FACILITIES TO FOR MAN AND ONE
FOR WOMEN- WE ALSO HAVE THREE
PUBLIC CONTRACT FACILITIES. IN
THE STATE WITH A WE HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH US CITIES AND
KERN COUNTY TO OPERATE THOSE
FACILITIES. AND AS I SAIDTHE
CURRENT POPULATION WITHIN ALL
OF THOSE- FACILITIES IS A TOTAL
OF JUST OVER TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED RIGHT NOW. TO NOW-
TURNING TO WHERE WE EXPECT TO
BE OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS
WHICH IS I THINK REALLY THE
MAIN FOCUS OF THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY- THAT PREPARED A- VISUAL
AID TO. TO HELP YOU FALL ALONG
WITH MY COMMENTS. IT LOOKS LIKE
THIS SHOULD BE IN FRONT OF YOU
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT HERE IS
REALLY- HIGH LEVEL PLANNING
DOCUMENT- THAT WE USE TO HELP
US MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH PRISON CAPACITY. TO
MANAGE ALL OF THE INMATES IN
OUR CARE. SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TOP LINE WHICH IS LABELED
PROJECTED INMATE POPULATION-
THAT IS SHOWING WHAT WE EXPECT
THE POPULATION TO BE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND AS YOU
CAN SEE WHERE PROJECT IN
DECLINE OF SEVERAL THOUSAND
INMATES OVER THIS FORECAST
PERIOD. THE NEXT LINE DOWN
SHOWS WHAT THE COURT ORDER
POPULATION CAP IS AT ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN POINT 5%
OF DESIGN CAPACITY. AS ELLIE-
NOTED THAT EQUATES TO JUST
UNDER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND INMATES THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO HOUSE IN OUR THIRTY
FOUR- STATE OPERATED PRISONS.
THE FOLLOWING IS. SERIES ROE IS
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE MAKE TO
THAT TOP WINE TO REFLECT
INMATES WERE HOUSE OUTSIDE OF
OUR THIRTY FOUR STATE PRISONS
BECAUSE THOSE INMATES DO NOT
COUNT TOWARDS THE STATE-
POPULATIONS POPULATION CAP. SO
ESSENTIALLY WE NEED TO SUBTRACT
THEM FROM THAT TOP LINE. SO
THIS INCLUDES INMATES HELD IN
THE PRIVATE- AND PUBLIC
CONTRACT FACILITIES. AS WELL AS
INMATES THAT WE HOUSE IN OUR
STATE FIRE CANS THAT ASSISTS
OUT CAL FIRE AND FIGHTING FIRES
ACROSS THE STATE- AS WELL. A AT
LEAST FACILITY THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA CITY WHICH IS-
ACTUALLY STAFFED BY CDC OUR
STAFF BUT- BUT LEASE FROM A
PRIVATE COMPANY. SO I TURN TO
AT THE BY LINE HERE BUT A- AND
LITERALLY- ON THIS CHART- THIS
SHOWS WHAT THE DIFFERENCE IS
BETWEEN THE- PROJECTED INMATE
POPULATION- HOUSE IN OUR THIRTY
FOUR PRISONS AND WHAT THE
POPULATION CAP IS- IT WE OFTEN
REFER TO THIS AS OUR BALL FOR.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK AT
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
WEEKS WE ARE TWENTY THREE
ALMOST TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
INMATES BELOW THE POPULATION
CAP- AND THAT MEANS TECHNICALLY
WE COULD ADD ANOTHER TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED INMATES TO OUR
EXCEEDING THAT THAT FEDERAL
COURT ORDER. IN THIS IS REALLY
THE KEY VARIABLE THAT WERE
MANAGING TO AS WE ADJUST PRISON
CAPACITY- FOR CHANGES IN THE
OVERALL PRISON POPULATION. SO
THE KEY HERE IS REALLY
MAINTAINING- THE RIGHT LEVEL OF
OFFER AND NOT HAVING IT BE TOO
HIGH OR TOO LOW- THE REASON WE
DON'T WANT IT TO BE TOO LOW IS
BECAUSE THAT WE COULD RISK
VIOLATING THE COURT ORDER-
THERE'S SOME LEVEL OF
UNCERTAINTY AND WHAT OUR PRISON
POPULATION WILL BE WE DO
PROJECTIONS IN THOSE- TEND TO
BE FAIRLY ACCURATE BUT- IT.
IT'S COMPLICATED BECAUSE WE
REALLY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER WHO
COMES IN THE FRONT DOOR OF THE
PRISONS THAT IS THAT- THAT THAT
IS BASICALLY DEPENDING ON WHO
THE COUNTY SEND US WE DON'T
HAVE A CHOICE TO TURN THEM AWAY
AT THE FRONT DOOR AND SO- EVEN
SMALL CHANGES IN COUNTY
SENTENCING PRACTICES- SLIDE
INTO A IN IT UP TAKEN CRIME
RATES OR- AND NOT. JUST POLICY
IS THE FROM WHAT D. A.'S COULD
RESULT IN IN MANSON WE EXPECT
COMING TO STATE PRISON IN THAT
WOULD POTENTIALLY JEOPARDIZE
OUR ABILITY TO MEET THE FEDERAL
COURT POPULATION CAP I'M WHICH
CASE THE FEDERAL COURTS WOULD
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO JUST
START RELEASING IN MEN'S FROM
OUR PRESENT. NOW OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S SOMETHING WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY FROM A PUBLIC SAFETY
STANDPOINT WILL DO EVERYTHING
IN OUR POWER TO AVOID THAT- AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO MAINTAIN
THAT BUMPER TO ACCOUNT FOR A
SORT OF. THE NEXT INCREASE. IN
SAN. TO STATE PRESS. ON THE
OTHER HAND WE DON'T WANT THAT
BY TO BE HIGH IN THE REASON
BECAUSE WHEN INCREASE THAT BALL
FOR THE WAY WE DO THAT IS BY
GENERALLY GOING OUT AND
PURCHASING MORE CONTRACT
BALANCE IN THOSE BEDS COME IN A
SIGNIFICANT COST OF THE STATE'S
ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER BAD AND SO FOR
EVERY AN INCREASE OF ONE HI.
DAD IN THE BUFFER WE'RE
ESSENTIALLY SPEND THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS- AND SO WE
WANT TO HONE IN ON A BOAT FOR A
LEVEL THAT'S NOT TOO LOW AS TO
RAISE OUR RISK OF EXCEEDING THE
FEDERAL COURT POPULATION HAPPEN
NOT TO HIGHEST SPEC FUNDING AND
SISTERLY. SO THERE'S NO MAGIC
NOW BUT WILL GENERAL SHOULD
FOR. IS ABOUT BUFFER TWO
THOUSAND IT'S BASED ON OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE- OF CDC OURS
POPULATION PROJECTIONS IN THE
PAST- IN OUR EXPERIENCE IN THAT
AREA- WE HAVE A COMFORT LEVEL
THAT THAT WOULD. THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO ACCOMMODATE ANY
UNEXPECTED INCREASES IN THE
POPULATION BUT BUT I ALSO- MAKE
SURE THAT WERE. EXPENDING STATE
FUNDS WISELY AND NOT SPENDING
MONEY UNNECESSARILY SO IF
YOU'LL TURN TO THE HAND OUT YOU
CAN SEE THAT OUR POPULATION
BUFFER- OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS. IS PRETTY CONSISTENTLY
RIGHT AROUND THAT TWO THOUSAND
FIVE MARCH THAT WE SHOOT FOR
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
POPULATION IS DECLINING. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE ARE PLANNING
TO REDUCE OUR USE OF CONTRACT
PADS IN SO THOSE TWO THINGS
SORT OF OFFSET EACH OTHER OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. WE ARE
PLANNING TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT MORE DETAIL THERE WE ARE
PLANNING TO- OF AND THE USE OF
BOTH OF OUR REMAINING PRIVATE
CONTRACT BUT FACILITIES FOR
MALE INMATES. ONE OF WHICH WE
EXPECT TO BE PHASED OUT BY THE
END OF THIS MONTH- THE SECOND
AND FINAL REMAINING BY PRIVATE
CONTRACT. FACILITY FOR MALES
WILL BE PHASED OUT BY THE END
OF APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY SO
JUST IN A COUPLE MONTHS FROM
NOW IN THEN LOOKING FOR. INTO
THE BUDGET. WE EXPECT TO BE
ABLE TO PHASE OUT THE USE OF
TWO OF OUR REMAINING PUBLIC
CONTRACT FACILITIES FOR MALES
WITHIN THE BUDGET YEAR. AND
THEN THE FINAL PUBLIC CONTRACT
FACILITY FROM MALES WE EXPECT
TO BE ABLE TO PHASE OUT. BY
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO
WE'RE ON PACE TO. VIRTUALLY
ELIMINATE OUR USE OF CONTRACT
PADS OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THE IF YOU LOOK AT THE OF
THE BALL FOR GOING OUT ON THE
ON A LONGER TIME HORIZON YOU
CAN SEE THAT IT STARTS TO GROW
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND BY THE END OF OUR
FORECAST PERIOD IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR I REACHES ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED- SO THAT'S
WHERE WE GET TO THE POINT HERE
WE CAN ACTUALLY CONSIDER-
CLOSING A STATE OPERATED
FACILITY- WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS
WE WOULD HAVE TO- WE WOULD LOSE
CAPACITY SO THE- THE- COURT
ORDER POPULATION CAP WOULD
DECLINE IT'S FOR THE AMOUNT OF
THAT DECLINE WOULD DEPEND ON
THE SIZE OF THE PRISON. WE
DECIDE TO CLUBS- AVERAGE
INSTITUTION SIZE IS ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED INMATES AND
OUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
POINT 5% OF DESIGN CAPACITY
THAT EQUATES TO ROUGHLY THIRTY
FIVE A LOT OF ROUGHLY THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED BEDS- TOWARDS OUR
POPULATION CAP SO. YOU DO THE
KIND BACK ON THE LOOKED OUT.
SUBTRACTING THAT THIRTY FIVE ON
FROM THE FIVE HUNDRED. WE WOULD
BASICALLY ABLE TO THIS PRISON
STILL MAY. THAT BUFFER OF TWO.
WHICH IS OUR COMFORT LEVEL THAT
WE WOULDN'T BE A- AND RISK OF
VIOLATING THAT- FEDERAL COURT
POPULATION CAP. THIS SO THINK
THAT HOPEFULLY GIVES YOU A PER
HIGH SUMMARY OF HOW WE APPROACH
ADJUSTING OUR PRISON
POPULATION- I DO WANT TO
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS WITH JUST
PROVIDING A- TO KIND OF
IMPORTANT COPY OUT STYLE OF
THIS DISCUSSION- THE FIRST
BEING THAT THESE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS ARE- AS MY
COLLEAGUE NOTED SUBJECT TO THAT
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY- IN THE
PAST WE FOUND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY DOES QUITE
A GOOD JOB OF PROJECTING THE
POPULATION- WHEN THERE ARE NO
MAJOR POLICY CHANGES IN OTHER
WORDS IF WE'RE JUST LOOK AT THE
STATUS QUO THE DEPARTMENT IS
QUITE ACCURATE ESTIMATE HOW
MANY. INMATES WILL HAVE IN THE
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS BUT THE-
OF COURSE DOESN'T HAVE A PER
BALL. IN IN WALL DOES NOT KNOW
WHAT POLICY MIGHT BE COMING
DOWN THE PIPELINE- FOR EXAMPLE
THERE WILL BE AN INITIATIVE ON
THE- AND THAT'S QUALIFIED FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY DOLLARS-
WHICH WOULD GENERALLY- INCREASE
THE PRISON POPULATION. AND IT.
IF THE VOTERS APPROVE THAT THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY. CAUSE US TO
REVISIT ALL OF THIS- PURGE ALL
OF THESE PROJECTIONS AND- OUR
ESTIMATES OF WHAT WE EXPECT TO
BE ABLE TO DO IN TERMS OF
ADJUSTING TO. PRISON POPULATION
CAPACITY- AND THEN THE FINAL
COPY OUT I WOULD. HI IS JUST
THIS IS FOR A SO HIGH ALLOWED
TEND TO FOOT SUMMARY OF HOW WE
MANAGE OUR PRISON POPULATION.
IN THERE REALLY MASKS A LOT OF
COMPLEXITY UNDERLYING ALL OF
THIS- I THINK. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY HAS TO MANAGE TO
DOZENS OF VARIABLES WHEN THEY
FIGURE OUT WHAT. WHAT TYPES OF
BEDS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IN
OUR SYSTEM WE HAVE A SPECIAL
TYPES OF BEDS FOR INMATES WITH
MEDICAL NEEDS. WE HAVE SPECIAL
BEDS FOR INMATES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS WE HAVE. BOB
THAT'S FOR FOUR DIFFERENT TYPES
OF SECURE FOR DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF SECURITY- WE CAN'T HOUSE
CERTAIN INMATES IN CERTAIN
PRISONS BECAUSE THE REST OF
VALLEY FEVER OR ADA
ACCESSIBILITY OR GANG CONCERNS-
THERE ARE IS THERE ARE JUST.
MANY MANY VARIABLES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO WAY AND
THAT'S REALLY A HERCULEAN TASK
THAT THEY HAVE TO DO. EVERY DAY
IT'S LIKE PUTTING TOGETHER A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND PIECE
JIGSAW PUZZLE AND SO I THINK AS
WE CONSIDER HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS DISCUSSION I HOPE IT'S-
NOT LOST ANY OF US JUST HOW
COMPLEX THIS. THIS REALLY IS AS
AN ISSUE ON. TO ADDRESS SO THAT
OFTEN PUT MY REMARKS TO TAKE
ANY QUESTION YOU HAVE THE- TIME.
POINT I'LL TAKE. WE ARE. THAT
OF FOR LOOKS AHEAD AND CALL
ROLE PLEASE AN ESTABLISH A CO.
MADAM SENATORS MITCHELL HERE
NIELSEN. WELL CARRIER. DOLLY
HER DAUGHTER. JOE LEYVA MCGUIRE
MONNING MORE LUCK. CAN BROAD. A
QUORUM COLLEAGUES IN OUR GOAL
QUEST TO BE BOTH EFFICIENT AND
THOROUGH I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU TAKE COPIOUS NOTES- WITH
REGARD TO QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIELD
QUESTIONS OF ALL THREE PANELS
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE THRD
PANEL. THANK YOU WITH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
FIRST PANEL WILL ASK YOU TO
PLEASE STAY BECAUSE YOUR
QUESTIONS WILL COME LATER ON OF
THE A SECOND PANEL JOIN US.
SECRETARY DAIS. AS WELL AS-
DOCTORS GOT GRAZED DIRECTOR
RESEARCH FROM CALIFORNIA BUDGET
AND POLICY CENTER. AGAIN THE
FOCUS OF THIS PANEL IS. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE STATE IS
ACHIEVING THE REQUIRED
POPULATION REDUCTIONS IN ORDER
TO MEET THE GOVERNORS AND
LEGISLATURES GOAL TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FACILITIES. AND WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH THE
SECRETARY GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
SIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
MORNING. SOME GOOD MORNING
CHAIR- WOMAN SENATORS THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TODAY. ALSO
THE CONVERSATION THIS MORNING
WITH NUMBERS YOU FOR A LOT OF
NUMBERS IN THE FIRST PANEL SO
BEGIN THERE AND I THINK YOU
HEARD POPULATION THIS MORNING.
OUR CURRENT POPULATION AS OF
THIS MORNING IS A HUNDRED AND
230-002-0080 THREE THIS FIGURE
REPRESENTS A DECREASE OF ABOUT
FORTY TWO THOUSAND AND MAY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN. OR
25% REDUCTION OVER TEN YEARS.
OF THE POPULATION QUESTION
ASKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
REDUCTIONS AND PROGRAMS- AND
ONE CAN LOOK AT THE STRICTLY
FROM THE NUMBERS QUESTION AND I
CAN TELL YOU A SECTOR SINCE
I'VE BEEN SIT IN THE SEAT I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO. MOVE BEYOND
THINKING ABOUT NUMBER
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WHAT I
KNOW WHAT I'VE KNOWN FOR NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS. AS A BEHIND EVERY
NUMBERS A PERSON. IT'S A PERSON
WITH NEEDS CONCERNS AND FEARS
REALLY NO DIFFERENT THAN
MYSELF- OTHER THAN I'M JUSTICE
INVOLVED BEFORE WITH A
DIFFERENT PURPOSE. REDUCE IN
OUR PRISON POPUATION IS THE
END RESULT OF PROVIDING THE
NECESSARY. REHABILITATE
REHABILITATE TOOLS AND SKILLS
INDIVIDUALS WHO LACK THEM AND
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THAT
LACK OF THOSE SKILLS AND
ABILITIES. WANT HIM UP IN THIS
PRISON SYSTEM THAT I'M
OVERSEEING. WHAT I DO WANT TO
SAY THIS CHANGE IN NUMBERS
THINKING NEEDS TO NEEDS TO
CHANGE WITHIN CITY C. R.
BECAUSE WHAT IT DOES IT HELPS
US AND HELPS ME AND THE
EMPLOYEES THE CDC ARE. THINK OF
INDIVIDUALS BE ON NUMBERS AND-
NEEDS. AND I THINK ONCE YOU
START THINKING OF INTO WOULD
NEED WHAT THAT DOES IT CHANGES
THE EMPLOYEES PURPOSE AND WHY
THEY CHOSE TO WORK IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
WORKING IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IS NOT AN EASY
TASK. IT'S CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS THE DEMANDS THE PRESSURES
NOT ONLY FOR THEM PERSONALLY
BUT THEIR FAMILIES. AND WHAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN THE LINES OF WORKING IN A
PRISON AND SERVING TIME IN THE
PRISONS THEY BLUR. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS- LIVES START BEGIN
TO SHAKE AND REHABILITATION IS
AN EFFECTIVE. BUT IF I DON'T
CHANGE THE PURPOSE AND FOCUS OF
THE REHABILITATION AND THE
REASON FOR OUR EMPLOYEES AND
WHAT THEY DO. WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS YOU WON'T HAVE
EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION YOU
WON'T HAVE POSITIVE OUTCOMES
YOU WON'T HAVE PRO SOCIAL
BEHAVIORS BY THE EMPLOYEES. SO
IT IS MY JOB. TO CHANGE THAT
ATMOSPHERE TO GIVE THE
EMPLOYEES PURPOSE. AND WHAT'S
BEING EXPLAINED EARLIER BY THE
LA ON OTHERS AND MYSELF TODAY I
THINK WHAT WE'RE DOINGAND WHAT
I AM DEMANDING OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT WE CHANGE. THE
REASON WHY WE EXIST AND THAT'S
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
THE REDUCTIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
POSSIBLE IN LARGE PART BY MANY
OF THE THINGS YOU JUST HEARD I
WON'T GO OVER THEM AGAIN BUT I
THINK ONE THING THAT WASN'T
DISCUSSED THAT. HAS BEEN ON.
THIS MAN AT THE DISPOSAL OF THE
SECRETARY PENAL CODE ELEVEN
SEVENTY D. WHICH WAS RARELY
USED IN PRIOR. BY PRIOR
SECRETARIES. BUT TO THE ELEVEN
SEVENTY PROCESS WHAT IT DOES IS
ALLOWS A SECRETARY. AND GIVES
VESTED AUTHORITY AND STATUTES.
TO REFER CASES TO SENTENCING
COURT'S. CONSIDERATION EITHER
BECAUSE OF DISCREPANCIES IN THE
SENTENCING CHANGES IN THE LAW
AND MORE POORLY EXCEPTIONAL
BEHAVIOR I HAVE- I HAVE GLADLY
SIGNED MANY OF THOSE ELEVEN
SEVENTY DIS AND WE HAVE SEEN
THOUSANDS OF YEARS TAKEN OFF
SENTENCES BECAUSE OF THAT. AND
WHAT THAT DOES FOR NOT ONLY ME
AS A SECRETARY BUT THE
INDIVIDUALS TO REFER THEM TO ME
THEY COME FROM THE PRISON. SO
THE PRISON LEADERSHIP THERE
FROM THE WHARTON AND THE STAFF
THEY RECOGNIZE. EITHER
DISCREPANCIES ARE EXCEPTIONAL
BEHAVIOR AND THE REFORM TO ME
FOR REVIEW. AND I REFER AMOUNTS
OF THE COURT BUT THAT DOES THAT
PROVIDES HOPE TO THE
POPULATION. AND ALSO FORCES
STAFF TO RECOGNIZE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING BY
SEEKING REHABILITATION. ALLOWS
ME T REFER THEM BACK I
RECEIVED NUMEROUS LETTERS FROM
INMATES. I CONTINUED RECEIVED
NUMEROUS LETTERS. OUT OF
PROCESS ASKING ME DIRECTLY SEND
MY CASE TO THE COURT BUT THAT'S
NOT THE PROCESS BUT- IT MAKES
ME FEEL GOOD THE IMAGE ARE
AWARE OF IT AND AS A TO THE
PRISONS I HEAR FROM THEM ABOUT
THAT. BE ON THE CRITICAL ITEMS
THAT I'VE LISTENED SPOKEN ABOUT
I'D BE REMISS IN MY TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE DEDICATED PEOPLE WHO
CHOOSE TO COME IN OUR PRISONS
ON A DAILY BASIS. AND GIVE BACK
TO OUR POPULATION BY
VOLUNTEERING AND FACILITATING.
THE PROGRAMS THAT REACH INMATES
IN WAY CDC ARE PROBABLY CANNOT.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCE. INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN IN THE CD OURS. AND NOW
CHANGED IN ONE TO COME BACK
GIVEN SHOW THAT HOPE IS POSH
AND CHAIN POTS. THESE
INDIVIDUALS COME IN ON A DAILY
BASIS I CALL THEM PARTNERS BUT
MORE OF ALL THE CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS OF I SAID EARLIER.
THESE ARE PEOPLE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
REENTRY PROVIDERS AND
VOLUNTEERS OR SOMETHING YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM TODAY.
THROUGH THIS POPULATION
REDUCTIONS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR USE OF CONTRACT
FACILITIES WHICH HAS BEEN
EXPLAINED EARLIER. AND I THINK
WE HAVE COME TO A POINT
CORRECTIONS WE REALIZE. THAT
THE DAYS OF OVERCROWDING WERE
NOT THE GOOD DAYS OF
CORRECTIONS- THERE WAS A DAY
WHEN I WAS A DAY TO DAY PRISON
OPERATOR AS A CAPTAIN ON THE
FACILITY. TRYING TO MANAGE
THESE TRIPLE BUNK FACILITIES
THAT THAT HAVE BEEN EXPLAINED.
OR THE LACK OF REHABILITATIVE
RESOURCES WERE NOT THERE AND
THEY WERE VERY BASIC. BASIC
EDUCATION AND A GOOD PROGRAMS
BUT THEY WERE VERY BASIC- THERE
WAS A HARD PLACE TO WORK- SO
NOW AS I SAID THE SECRETARY.
CRAFTING A DIFF NARRATIVE. A
DIFFERENT PURPOSE SEEKING
FUNDING- CHAMPIONING OUR
EFFORTS. THOSE PRISON OP NOW A-
WHAT THEY HAVE BECAUSE NOW THEY
HAVE A DIFFERENT PURPOSE AND A
DIFFERENT PLACE- TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. ALTHOUGH ALL OF
THESE- CONTRACTED FACILITIES
THAT I SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER-
THEY REPRESENT LOCATIONS THAT
ARE. YOU KNOW THE STAY ON MY
MIND I DO I DO RECOGNIZE THE
SOME OF THESE CLOSURES ARE
GONNA IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES.
AND WE WILL GO INTO IT WE WILL
BE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH MANY
PEOPLE I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THEM. AND AS THE TIME
COMES WE WILL BE COMMUNICATING
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ASSIST WITH
SOME OF THOSE CLOSURES AND
HELPING THE EMPLOYEES THAT MAY
BE DISPLACED. I KNOW THE
QUESTION THAT I WAS ASKED
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT FACILITATING
POPULATION REDUCTION BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT OUR
MAIN GOAL IS TO REDUCE OUR
POPULATION TO BE BILLETED OF
PROGRAMS. AND THAT PROMOTE
SUCCESSFUL COMMUTER INTEGRATION
WITHOUT THAT PIECE. WE WILL SEE
THE SAME OFFENDER OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. I WOULD- I WOULD HOPE
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
OUR CHANGE VISION AND MISSION
STATEMENT. YOU CAN GO TO I'LL I
WON'T BE LABOR BY READING IT
HERE. BUT GO TO THE CDC OUR WEB
PAGE IT'S RIGHT ON THE BALL THE
CLICKER ON IT AND CLICK IT
YOU'LL SEE THE NEW VISION AND
MISSION STATEMENT. THE SPEAKS
ABOUT MUCH OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEKING- IN THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THAT ESTABLISHES EDUCATION THAT
ESTABLISHES SERVICES FOR
SUCCESS FOR INTEGRATION. BUT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE VISION AND
MISSION. THAT DOES SPEAK OF
SAFETY. SAFETY IS STILL
PERMANENT A PRISON WITHOUT SAFE
ROUTE INSTITUTIONS OF
FACILITIES. AFFECT THE
REHABILITATION CANNOT HAPPEN SO
WE ARE STILL IN THE SAFETY
BUSINESS SO LET'S NOT. EVER
FORGET THAT I NEED TO REMIND-
MY CITIES YOUR STUFF FOR THAT
ALSO. THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT IN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LAST YEAR MADE CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS- AND SUPPORT THIS
VISION SUCH AS IMPROVING IN MAY
LITERACY EXPANDING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OR TREATMENT.
ESTABLISHING NEW COMMUNITY
REENTRY FACILITIES. THE BUDGET
WE PROPOSE FOR YOUR APPROVAL
THIS YEAR BUILT UPON THOSE
INVESTMENTS BY PROVIDING
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. WITH
EXPANDED A HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES MODELING NEW
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
REHABILITATIVE COMMUNITIES
WHICH I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT.
EXPANDING VISITATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO ESTABLISH A REESTABLISH
CRITICAL RELATIONSHIPS THAT
ARE. THAT ARE VERY VERY
CRITICAL TO REHABILITATION. AND
ALSO LASTLY IMPROVE IN OUR
STAFF CULTURE AND WELLNESS BY
TRAINING OUR EMPLOYEES TO
ENGAGE THE NEEDS OF THE
POPULATION IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
BY UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORTING
THE REHABILITATIVE NEEDS. IN
THE END. IN CD C. R. THIS IS
PUBLIC SAFETY IN A CORRECTIONAL
SETTING. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WITH GROWTH GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS SCOTT GRADES ON THE
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH AT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER WE ARE A NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO- I'VE BEEN ASKED
THIS MORNING TO SPEND A FEW
MINUTES ON PROVIDING SOME
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH PRISON CLOSURES IN OTHER
STATES- HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL FOR REFORMS THAT
CALIFORNIA MIGHT CONSIDER THAT
MAN THAT HAD BEEN INSPIRED
PERHAPS BY OTHER STATES- AND
ALSO TALK ABOUT A KEY CHALLENGE
ON THE HORIZON- WHICH ACTUALLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALREADY ALLUDED TO- SO TURNING
FIRST TO PRISON CLOSURES AND
OTHER STATES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES BASED ON REPORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RELEASED BY VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS. SUCH AS THE RAND
CORPORATION SENTENCING PROJECT
IT'S CLEAR THAT ON NET OTHER
STATES HAVE BEEN REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF CORRECTIONAL BAD BY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OVER THE LAST
DECADE- A NUMBER OF FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN CLOSE WHILE WE ALL
TALK ABOUT PRISON CLOSURES IN
FACT IT REALLY RARE THAT A
LARGE- IS STATE OWNED FACILITY
WOULD BE CLOSED WITH OFTEN
BEING CLOSED ARE SMALLER
MINIMUM MEDIUM TERM FACILITY.
ISN'T A LOT OF OTHER STATES ARE
PHASING OUT CONTRACTS WITH
PRIDE IN PRINT PRIVATE PRISON
OPERATORS WORK REALLY CENTERS
ARE BEING CLOSE CAMPS ARE BEING
CLOSED SO A LOT OF WHAT WE HEAR
WHEN WE HEAR PRISON CLOSURES
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
BIG FACILITIES WERE HOPING TO
EVENTUALLY GET TO HEARING WELL
FOR ME A LOT OF STATES HAVE
BEEN DOWNSIZING THE TYPES OF
FACILITIES ON THE CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN UNDERTAKING FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS- SO DOWNSIZING.
FOR A MIX OF REASONS A LOT OF
STATES HAVE HAD BUDGET PROBLEMS
THEY LOOK FOR SAY LOOK TO THE
CA BY IN NAY FIVE THEY CAN
SQUEEZE SOME THERE ARE BE THE
FALL CRIME RATES THE CAR ARE
TRACK HE SAID STAY OF A DAY.
THEY HAVE TO. MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE TWENTIETH
OR THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- SO
THERE IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW YOU
MAY GET RID OF THE FACILITY
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO INCREASE
OPERATIONAL FACIL EFFICIENCIES
AND OF COURSE THERE'S ALSO BEEN
A BIG MOVING ACROSS THE NATION
TO CUT TIES- WITH PRIVATE
PRISON CONTRACTORS OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S BEEN AN APPROACH THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
AND GOVERNOR BROWN AS WELL HAVE
FAVORED WE ARE ON THAT PATH- I
DO PROVIDE YOU WITH A HAND OUT
THAT I MAY SPEAK TO FROM TIME
TO TIME IT'S A TABLE COMPARING
US TO STATES THAT EVERYBODY
LIKES TO COMPARE. CALIFORNIA TO
NEW YORK AND ACCESS I'M JUST TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING INCARCERATIONS OF
ANDY KERR SUBMISSION ARE IN
THOSE STATES NEW ACT EVER RE
BEEN THE ISN'T BASED SO THEY CO
THE TEEN SO. ACTIONAL SAID TO A
SIX FIVE HAD BET THAT'S A TABLE
SAYS IS CLOSE TO THE STATE RUN
PRISON AND PRIVATE PRISON SAN
THOUSAND A LOT SO IS JUST A ONE
IF THERE'S A LOT OF THE WAY OF
GOING ABOUT THANK IS NOT ALL BY
BECAUSE HAVEN'T MAY TO CLOSE
ONE UR BIG FACILITY WERE ALL
TRYING. TO BEEN FOCUSING FIRST
ON PRIVATE OUT A STATE THIS. ME
IN STATE PRIVATE FACILITIES
THEN EVENT HOPE IS WE GET TO
THE BIGELOW AS HAS BEEN ALLUDED
TO DOWNSIZE CAN BE CON OFFER A
CUP REASON ONE THERE'S ALWAYS A
CONCERN PUBLIC SECTOR LAW SO IN.
WHO IN PRISON FOR SALE ARE OF
COURSE GOING TO CONCERN THAT
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THEIR JOB SO
ON MY BEST READING OF THE
LITERATURE OUT WHAT'S BEEN PUT
OUT ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING
IN OTHER STATES TYPICALLY
STATES TRY TO AVOID MASS
LAYOFFS SO WHAT HAPPENS IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE MAY DECIDE- IT'S
TIME TO RETIRE- AND THEN THE
STATE DOES WHAT IT CAN TO FIND
SPOTS FOR FOLKS WHO WANT TO
STAY ON IN THE CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEM. IN OTHER FACILITIES
THAT REMAIN AFTER ONE TWO OR
THREE FACILITIES HAVE BEEN
CLOSED SO THERE WILL ALWAYS BE
A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE CONCERN ABOUT
JOB LOSS THE STATE NEEDS TO
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT BUT I
IMAGINE CALIFORNIA AND CD WE
ARE- IT WOULDN'T BE WHAT IT
COULD. DO OR THAT PEOPLE WORK
IS THEIR JOB AS A- SINGLE. I'M
THERE'S ALL IN A GAME ON
IMMEDIATE AS HAS BEEN A TO A
LOT THESE PRINT OFF. ARE IN IS
THE HAVE A LOT OF A CAN AND I A
COPPER TO THE THEIR ROLE A LOT
OF THEIR JOB OUT THERE THESE
GREAT JOB. HIGH SCHOOL. THANKS
INTO THE PAST I'M AS GOV CUOMO
AT NEW YORK IS SAID ON SICK IN
CAR OF IS NOW AND PROGRAM AND
I'M NOT GOING TO RATIONALIZE
LOCKING UP PEOPLE AS AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TOOL HE
SAID HAS SAID THAT IN RESPONSE
TO A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT HIS DESIRE TO
KEEP SHRINKING NEW YORK'S
PRISON SYSTEM STILL I'VE
CALIFORNIA MOVES CLOSER TO
CLOSING A STATE RUN PRISON AND
ALSO CONTEMPLATES CLOSING THE
REMAINING PREFER PRIVATE
FACILITIES. YOU DO WANT TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS FOR
THE THAT FOR THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE GOING TO SEE A SOURCE
OF GOOD PAYING JOBS LOST THAT'S
NOT A REASON TO KEEP THE
FACILITY OPENED BUT IT IS A
REASON TO THINK ABOUT IS THERE
A WAY TO REPURPOSE THE FACILITY
CAN YOU FIND WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT- SO THAT
THE TAX LOSSES AND THE JOB
LOSSES CAN BE MITIGATED TO SOME
EXTENT. OKAY LET ME SWITCH TO
ADDITIONAL REFORMS TO HELP
FURTHER REDUCE INCARCERATION-
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE FIRST
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN
SOME HUGE STEPS THIS
LEGISLATURE. PRIOR GOVERNOR IS
THE VOTERS WE'VE DONE A LOT TO
ADVANCE THE CAR'S RATIONING
CALIFORNIA SO- KUDOS TO THE
GOLDEN STATE- WE'RE ONE OF THE
LEADERS BUT THERE'S MORE THAT
CAN BE DONE AND I HAVE A COUPLE
OF THOUGHTS SO MINUTE THROW OUT
THERE THAT KIND OF FIT INTO
THAT. GO BIG OR GO HOME
CATEGORY ONE IS INSPIRED BY NEW
YORK THE OTHERS INSPIRED BY
TEXAS- SO THE FIRST THOUGHT
SORT OF INSPIRED BY NEW YORK
WHICH RECENTLY REPEAL THE
ROCKEFELLER DRUG LAWS SO THESE
GO BACK TO THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES MANDATORY MINIMUM.
SENTENCES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND DROVE UP
THE PIT THE PRISON POPULATION
WITH NO GAINS IN PUBLIC SAFETY
RECENTLY THE LEGISLATURE SAID
WELL. LET'S GO LET'S BACK LET'S
JUST GT RID OF IT THIS DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE ANYMORE WE CAN'T
LIVE UNDER LAWS THAT WERE
PASSED. UNDER BY A PRIOR
GENERATIONS SO THIS MAY BE THE
TIME FOR ALL YOU HAVE TO GO TO
THE VOTERS FOR FOLKS TO START
THINKING IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
FURTHER MODIFYING THE THREE
STRIKES LAW WE TOOK ON THE
THIRD STRIKE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WITH PROP THIRTY SIX.
FOR SECOND STRIKERS- FOR
EVERYONE WHO GETS A SECOND
STRIKE ON FOR A FELONY EUROPE
SENTENCES AUTOMATICALLY DOUBLE
THE RESEARCH DOES NOT SUPPORT
THE CONTENTION LONGER. IS IT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. THIS ATTACK
WOULD BE A- SEC. WHAT'S IN IT
FOR THE SO CONVICTED OF A
VIOLENT ZERO FELONY IF WANT TO
CUT IT WITH HE GOT MANY NOT IN
THAT CAT LET'S JUST GIVE ME THE
SAN THAT'S ON THE SINCE OF
DOUBLE YOUR SET KEEP YOU IN
PRESENT FOR MUCH OF THAN IN TO
BE RE GOING VERY WOULD BE
CALLING FOR A FULL SCALE REPEAL
OF THREE STRIKES WHO KNOWS IF
THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE READY
FOR THAT OR IF THIS LEGISLATURE
IS READY FOR THAT BUT THAT
WOULD BE ONE OF THOSE
GENERATIONAL SHIFT THAT YOU
COULD IMAGINE PROBABLY
HAPPENING WITHIN A FEW YEARS-
SECONDLY- WE NEED TO
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE WITH MENTAL IT LESS.
IT IS SHOCKING WE HAVE OVER THE
SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE ALMOST TEN
STATE PRISONERS ARE RECIEVING
MENTAL HEALTH THREE AT A CALL
AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND THROUGH THE
CDC ARE THAT'S FOR ONE FIFTH OF
HEALTH RELATED SPENDING THROUGH
THE CD THE ARE FOR STATE
PRISONERS WORST THING OVER WITH
WHEN. HELPED OUT MENTAL SERVICE
FOR PEOPLE IN STATE PRISON
STATE PRISONS ARE SPECTACULARLY
INAPPROPRIATE PLACES FOR PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS TO BE OURS
SO WE'VE MADE SOME GAINS IN
CALIFORNIA THE GOVERNOR
OBVIOUSLY DEVOTED HIS STATE OF
THE STATE SPEECH YESTERDAY TOO
CONCERNED ABOUT HOMELESSNESS IN
THE LINKS TO MENTAL ILLNESS
THOSE LINKS ARE ALSO PRESENT A
PRESENT IN OUR IN THE WAY THAT
WE INCARCERATING CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO START ASKING OURSELVES
HARD QUESTIONS IS THIS THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO BE
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS CAN WE DO
OR IN. MORE RE THAT THE END I
PREVENT THE KEY PEOPLE WITH
ALMOST GET IN BOB IN THE THIS
IS THE FIRST PART THIS IN. IS
BECAUSE PUBLIC I'D LIKE BUT
YOU'RE AND REPUBLICAN GO IN
THAT SEVEN TO. THE WAS GOING TO
THE FOR PLACE THEY LOOKED FOR
REFORM O STOP CYCLING PEOPLE
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES
THROUGH THEIR PRISON SYSTEM
THAT IS ONE OF THE FIRST PLACES
THEY LOOKED FOR SOLUTIONS TO
THEIR- BALDING. PRISONS THEY
HAVEN'T MADE IT AS FAR AS
CALIFORNIA THEY HAVEN'T ADOPTED
AS MANY REFORMS AS WE HAVE SO
THEIR PRISON POPULATION HASN'T
COME DOWN MUCH BUT IT'S COME
DOWN BY ABOUT. TEN PERCENT. SO
FOR. THIS THAT. FINAL THOUGHT
HERE CHALLENGES ON THE HORIZON
AS THOMAS JEFFERSON SAID IN THE
SMASH HIT HAMILTON EVERY ACTION
HAS ITS EQUAL OPPOSITE
REACTION- WE'RE GOING TO BE
SEEING THIS ON THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT. I'M GOING
TO BE IT'S SORT OF A TEST OF
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIANS
COMMITMENT TO THE CONCEPT OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
WHETHER WE AS A STATE ARE
WILLING TO STAY THE COURSE OR
IF WE'RE GONNA START NIBBLING
AWAY AT THE GAINS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE BY THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND THE VOTERS THEMSELVES
RECENT YEARS THERE'S OPERA
PROPOSAL TO REPEAL BAIL REFORM
THAT GUY THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SIGNED A LAW BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
THERE'S ALSO GOING TO BE A
PROPOSAL TO CHIP AWAY AT PROP
FORTY SEVEN AND PROP FIFTY
SEVEN IN A WAY THAT WOULD DRIVE
UP STATE AND LOCAL CORRECTIONAL
SPENDING. AND ALSO SLOW THE
STATE'S MOMENT COME IN REDUCING
THE PRISON POPULATION THE
NUMBER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST SHOWED YOU FOR
THEIR PROJECTIONS OF THE PRISON
POPULATION FIVE YEARS FROM NOW
ASSUME CURRENT LAW THE STATUS
QUO. OKAY THAT'S GREAT BUT WHAT
IF THE STATUS QUO CHANGES THAT
MEANS YOU HAVE- PROBABLY
ELIMINATED YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE THE STATE PRISON IN FIVE
YEARS SO IT'S REALLY SOMETHING.
TO KEEP IN MIND- AS WE DEBATE
THIS IT HASN'T GONE ON THE
BALLOT YET BUT THIS MEASURE HAS
QUALIFIED AND I WOULD ASSUME
IT'S VERY LIKELY TO BE PLACED
ON THE BALLOT BY THIS I THINK
IT'S A JUNE DEADLINE. SO THAT'S
REALLY SOMETHING TO KEEP IN
MIND NOT NECESSARILY ANYTHING
THIS LEGISLATURE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT- BUT IT IT'S
GOING TO BE A TEST OF
CALIFORNIA COMMIT. TO WE'RE
WILLING TO STAY THE COURSE ON
THAT CRIMINAL. CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM CHOICES WE'VE BEEN
MAKING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE THANK THE
SET TERRY AND DOCTOR GRAY FORD.
CONTEST AND WE'RE GONNA. ASK
THE FINAL PANEL TO COME FORWARD
FAST YOU TWO GENTLEMEN TO
PLEASE STICK AROUND BECAUSE I'M
SURE MY COLLEAGUES WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. THE THIRD
PALATABLE TRANSITIONAL IMPULSE
RELIEF SERVICES PANEL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM- ABOUT
WHAT'S NEEDED FOR SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY AND HOW THE STATE CAN
PLAY A ROLE IN ENSURING ITS
SUCCESS. ONE WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING FROM MR WORTLEY FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ON
COMMON LAW FOLLOWED BY THE BOND
AND- SALE JOHNSON BOTH WITH THE
AMITY FOUNDATION WELCOMES TO
OUTLAY CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
AWARD FROM IRVINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATE MITCHELL- GOOD
MORNING SENATOR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- JUST ADAM KEEP
WIDELY FROM ON COMMON LAW WHAT
WE DO IS WE PROVIDE. TRAUMA
INFORMED COUNSELING AND LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE SERVING LIFE SENTENCES AND-
I THINK THE NUMBER MAY BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER BUT- I. HAS
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES. THE
NUMBER NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
KNOW- I WELCOME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY BECAUSE- I
THINK THAT WE AS A SOCIETY WE
WE'VE INVENTED INVENTED MANY
WAYS TO- DEHUMANIZE PEOPLE AS
WE- PROSECUTE AND CONVICT AND
SENTENCE THEM TO PRISON. WE
SENT THEM TO LONGER TERMS AT
YOUNGER AGES AT THINK IT'S WELL
PAST TIME WE FIND SOME SAFE
PATHWAYS TO BRING THEM BACK
HOME. THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS TO
CLOSE A PRISON AND IN THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS OR SO AND I THINK
THAT'S AN ATTAINABLE. GOAL IN A
REASONABLE- STEP BUT- I ALSO
THINK THAT. WE GET THERE BY BY
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
PEOPLE IN PRISON AND MORE
RESPONSIVE TO SURVIVORS OF
CRIME OPTICALLY VIOLENT CRIME
BUT CRIMES IN GENERAL I THINK
WE GET THERE BY TRANSFORMING
THE VERY CULTURE INSIDE OF
INSTITUTIONS I APPRECIATE
SECRETARY D. AS IS- COMMITMENT
IN HIS HIS VISION- AND WHAT
THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE I THINK WE
AGREE ON A LOT OF THINGS. BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT AS THIS
COMMITTEE IS AWARE THE COST OF
PRISON. ISN'T IN IS- REALLY
CONTINUES TO SOAR EVEN THOUGH.
THE POPULATION. IS REDUCE COSTS
SERVE OUR CREDIT WE HIGH AND I
THINK. THAT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE ARE. OLDER SICKER. AND THEY
HAVE A GREATER NEED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THEN CAN
ACTUALLY BE MET IN A PRISON
SETTING. MY OBSERVATIONS ARE
GOING TO FALL INTO THE REALLY
THREE BROAD CATEGORIES TODAY-
ONE IS ABOUT. OF THE NEED FOR
MORE RESPONSIVE PROGRAMMING
INSIDE THE PRISONS- ANOTHER
CATEGORIES IT IS THE NEED FOR
CULTURAL CULTURAL CHANGE WITHIN
THE PRISONS. AND BLAST
CATEGORIES ABOUT THE MEANING
THE NEED FOR MEANING FULL OF
SUPPORT UPON RE ENTRY PANEL
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THIS PANEL
BUT- YOU CAN'T REALLY TAKE ONE
PIECE AND NOT NOT TIED TO THE
REST BECAUSE IT'S ALL PART OF
THE SAME. PROCESS AND SYSTEM-
AND AS- AS A GOOD IDEAS NOTED
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE NOT
NUMBERS. AND PEOPLE LIVE IN
EVERY EVERY PHASE OF THIS
PROCESS AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO FOCUS ON WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE. AS FOR MORE RESPONSIVE
PROGRAMMING. OF THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
IN OUR PRISONS ARE SURVIVORS OF
PHYSICAL OR EMOTIONAL TRAUMA.
ESTIMATES RANGE FROM 6270% OF.
THOSE WHO IDENTIFY AS MALE AND
95% FOR THOSE BY DEVICE FEMALE
AND EVEN HIGHER RATES AMONG
TRANSGENDER POPULATION- ARE
SURVIVORS OF PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL
TRAUMA. AND RESPONDING TO
TRAUMA WITH PUNISHMENT IS
PROVEN ITSELF TO BE ONE OF THE
LEAST EFFECTIVE- MOST HARMFUL
AND EXPENSE OF THINGS WE CAN DO
TO OTHER HUMAN BEINGS. AND SO-
IT'S NOT JUST THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN PRISON IT'S THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
SO- WE URGE A HEALING APPROACH.
INSTEAD I THINK THIS STARTS
WITH SCREENING PEOPLE WHEN THEY
FIRST COME INTO PRISON- TO
IDENTIFY WHAT TYPES OF ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES. AND
TRAUMA THEY'VE HAD IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE DO RIGHT NOW- AND
THEN WE CAN ACTUALLY. SUPPORT
THE PROGRAMS THAT THAT HELP
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. CURRENTLY
THE COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
APPROACH TO PRISON PROGRAMMING
FALL FAILS TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES- WHICH CAN USUALLY BE
TRACED BACK TO AN ORIGINAL
TRAUMA BURIED BENEATH. DECADES
OF PROTECTIVE LAYERS THAT
PEOPLE CREATE TO KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE. I THINK THE
PROBOARDS IS BY RECOGNIZING THE
BENEFITS OF HAVING PEOPLE DO
THIS DEEP INTROSPECTIVE WORK.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T AGREE THAT THE
FAILURE TO DO THIS WORK
CORRELATES TO RISK OF VIOLENCE.
NEVERTHELESS I THINK THE
PROBLEM REALLY IS THAT WHILE.
PROBOARDS GRANTING PAROLE TO
PEOPLE WHO'VE DONE THIS WORK
THERE TOO FEW PROGRAMS AND TOO
FEW SAFE SPACES WITHIN THE
PRESENCE ACTUALLY DO THE WORK.
AS FOR THE CULTURE CHANGE
WITHIN THE PRISONS I- AS I SAID
I DO COMMEND SECRETARY D. AS
FOR HIS VISION OF A NEW CULTURE
INSIDE AND IT ESPECIALLY IS
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANT
ROLE. OF FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AND REALLY TRANSFORMING-
WHAT AND WHAT SAFETY LOOKS LIKE
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
PRESIDING THE COMMUNITY IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY- I THINK WE HAVE
TO REJECT THE CONCEPT OF US
VERSUS THEM. WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY. BECAUSE
WE'RE BOTH WERE US IN THEM. AND
THAT'S TRUE WITHIN THE PRISONS
AND WITHIN THE LARGER SOCIETY
AT THING THAT WE CREATE A US A
SAFER AND MORE PRODUCTIVE
SOCIETY WHEN WE COME CLOSER
TOGETHER RATHER THAN MORE
DISTANT AND ISOLATED FROM EACH
OTHER AND I THINK PRISON
OFFICIALS. ALSO REALIZE JUST
HOW DAMAGING PRISON IS FOR
THOSE WHO WORK THERE. ASIDE
FROM VIOLENCE AND SOME OF THE
INSTITUTIONS OF THEIR STAFF OF
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RATES OF
DEPRESSION SUICIDE POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES OF ANY PROFESSION. A
PRISON IS SIMPLY A BAD PLACE
FOR EVERYBODY. BUT PEOPLE WHO
WHO DO FIND A COMMUNITY INSIDE
PRISON WHERE THEY CAN PROCESS
TRAUMA ARE MUCH MORE SUCCESSFUL
WHEN THEY APPEARED BEFORE THE
PAROLE BOARD. AND THOSE WERE
RELEASED THROUGH THE PRO WAR TO
MUCH MORE SUCCESSFUL AFTER THE
RELEASE. AND THE COST SAVINGS
ARE HUGE- IN IN OUR
ORGANIZATION WE'VE NOW SEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR OF OUR-
LICENSE CLIENTS RELEASED. AND
EVERY YEAR THEY STAY OUT OF
PRISON SAVE THE STATE NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS. JUST THOSE TWO
AND FORTY FOUR. IF WE JUST
THINK THIS DEMONSTRATED
INVESTING AND COUNSELING AND-
IN THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
THAT THE PEOPLE NEED TRANSLATES
INTO GREATER SAFETY WITHIN THE
PRISONS AND OUTSIDE IN THE
COMMUNITY- THE CATEGORY OF THIS
MEANINGFUL SUPPORT UPON RE
ENTRY. IS A HUGE ONE AND YOU'RE
GONNA HEAR SOME EXPERTS ON THAT
IN A MINUTE. I'M A TALK FROM
ABOUT TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
SPECIFICALLY- TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING SOMETIMES REFERRED TO
AS HALFWAY HOUSES- THEY CAN BE
HELPFUL FOR PEOPLE RETURNING
FROM PRISON ESPECIALLY
FOLLOWING LONG LONG TERMS IN
PRISON CLING LICENSES- HOWEVER
THE FACILITIES THAT ARE
OPERATED BY FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES. TO FOCUS ON ON
RESTRICTION AND PUNISHMENT TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON MEASURING
RECIDIVISM WE ACTUALLY THEY
SHOULD FOCUS ON- COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT WE THINK
RECIDIVISM ITSELF IS REALLY A
POOR MEASURE OF- OF SUCCESS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
TELL YOU MUCH ABOUT WHAT
SOMEONE'S LIFE LOOKS LIKE ON
THE OUTSIDE. MOST OF US ARE WE
ON OUR WAY BACK TO PRISON.
DOESN'T TELL YOU MUCH ABOUT
WHAT OUR LIVES LIKE. THAT'S
TRUE EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANNA- REFERENCE I'D I SHARED A
LETTER- WITH THE COMMITTEE
EARLIER THIS WEEK THAT THAT-
SUMMARIZE SOME FINDINGS FROM A
REPORT THAT WE COMMISSION LAST
YEAR- FROM THE GOLDMAN SCHOOL
OF PUBLIC POLICY AT UC
BERKELEY- WE WERE WE WERE
CONCERNED BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM
A LOT OF OUR CLIENTS ABOUT.
CHALLENGES THEY HAD AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OF A LOT
OF DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES MANY
OF THEM REALLY BAD AND
DISTURBING CONCERNING WHO
WANTED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT IT SO
WE ASK THE FOLKS AT THE AT THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL THERE- SOME
SOME GREAT STUDENTS
PARTICIPATED IN THIS PROGRAM-
THIS PROJECT INTO THE LETTER
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THOSE THINGS
AND SOME OF THOSE KEY FINDINGS
FROM THE REPORT. INCLUDE THAT.
WHAT HAPPENS A WHAT ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS IS THAT THERE'S THIS
CONTINUED- OFFICES ON
RECIDIVISM AS THE KEY INDICATOR
OF RE ENTRY AND PAROLE SUCCESS.
AND THAT CONTRIBUTES TO PROGRAM
ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE BASICALLY
LIKE PRISONS MMHM- THEY'RE
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL A LOT OF A
LOT OF WAS FURTHER ISOLATING
PEOPLE FROM THE VERY SOCIAL
STRUCTURES THAT THE THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO THEIR FULL
REINTEGRATION. THIS INCLUDES
BEING REGULARLY CALLED BY THE
CDC NUMBERS INSTEAD OF THE
NAMES INCLUDES IN DURING PRISON
LIKE DRILLS SUCH AS SURPRISE
COUNT TIME AT THREE O'CLOCK IN
THE MORNING. I HAVE TO GO
OUTSIDE SOMETIMES THEY'RE GOING.
BEING FORCED TO SIT THROUGH
HOURS OF IRRELEVANT PROGRAMMING.
IT INTERFERES WITH MORE
MEANINGFUL AND PRODUCTIVE-
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS AN
EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES BUT ALSO INCLUDES
A PATRONIZING AND PATERNALISTIC
WAY OF CONTROLLING RESIDENTS
MONEY. WITHOUT TEACHING THEM
ANY KIND OF FINANCIAL LITERACY
SKILLS OR IMPOSING A REASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE TRAVEL AND
THE TIME WITH THE FAMILY ALL
THESE THINGS OF BARRIERS TO
SOMEONE FULLY REINTEGRATE AND
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY ANOTHER FINDING WAS
THAT- WHILE THEY'RE THERE
CONSIDERABLE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
STATE HAVING CONTRACT WITH
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT COMPANIES.
LIKE THE GEO GROUP. OTHER
TRANSITIONAL FACILITIES. THAT
DON'T RECEIVE STATE FUNDING.
HAVE VIRTUALLY NO OVERSIGHT. NO
REGULATION WE DON'T ATUALLY
KNOW WHAT THEY DO- AND THEIR
PRACTICES ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE. AND THAT THAT REPRESENTS
A OF A LOT OF THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING THERE THE FUNDED BY. I
WOULD FOUNDATIONS OR JUST OF-
THEY FOUND FIND OF INDIVIDUAL
DONORS TO SUPPORT THEIR WORK.
AND THEY JUST SORT OF CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT THEY ONCE WE HAVE
BEEN A NONPROFIT I SUPPORT-
BEING CREATIVE IN FINDING WAYS
TO SUPPORT PEOPLE. BUT WHEN
PEOPLE RUN THEM LIKE PRISONS I
DON'T SUPPORT THAT. AND I THINK
IT'S CONTRARY TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IN THESE
THESE PROGRAMS. SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
REPORT. A FOCUS ON TRANSITIONAL
PROGRAMS. THEY INCLUDE HEY
FOCUSING AS MUCH OR MORE ON THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THE-
AS COMPARED TO SIMPLY HOUSING
PEOPLE AND ALSO. CREATING SOME
CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY IN THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT SUCCESS EVEN
MEANS AFTER PRESIDENT- IT CAN'T
JUST BE WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE
ACTORS RIGHT- IT CAN'T JUST BE
THAT- WE THINK THAT THAT WE
SHOULD BE MEASURED IN TERMS OF
BETTER DESCRIBE THE QUALITY OF
SOMEONE'S LIFE AND THEIR
ABILITY TO FULLY PARTICIPATE AS
FULL CITIZENS IN SOCIETY-
REMOVING BARRIERS TO HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION THAT THE
THAT ALSO INTERFERE WITH. FULL
INTEGRATION. I HAVE THE TO SAY
WITH THE MISFITS IT'S REALLY
MEANINGFUL TO BE SITTING HERE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE- OF THE HOTEL
JOHNSON WHO YOU HEAR FROM IN A
MINUTE WAS A CLIENT OF MINE
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO. AT THE
TIME HE HAD BEEN GRANTED PAROLE
BY THE PAROLE BOARD. AND THE
GOVERNOR REVERSED. AND WE HAD
TO GO TO COURT. TO FIGHT THAT
DECISION. AND WE LOST. AND THIS
IS A PART OF A WHOLE SERIES OF
PETITIONS THAT WE FILED TO
CONVINCE THE STATE TO LET HIM
GO AT THE TIME THE- THE
GOVERNOR WAS NOT INTERESTED AND
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO SHOW TO
SHOW. WHO THEY WERE THEY'VE
THERE'S A LOT OF FOCUS ON THE
CRIME ITSELF AND NOT A LOT OF
APPRECIATION FOR THE CAPACITY
TO CHANGE- SO IT'S A PRIVILEGE
REALLY AN HONOR TO BE SITTING
WITH THOSE OUT NOW. NOT ONLY
BECAUSE HE'S HOME WHERE HE
NEEDS TO BE. UP BUT BECAUSE- IF
HE'S RUNNING A PROGRAM IN WHICH
TWO OF MY OTHER CLIENTS NOW.
RESIDE TALK ABOUT FULL CIRCLE.
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW THE MAN IT
DID YOU YOU'LL HEAR FROM TODAY.
HE WAS THAT GUY TEN YEARS AGO.
AND WE AS A STATE DIDN'T
RECOGNIZE HIS CAPACITY TO
CHANGE AND WHO WE WAS FOR THE
PEOPLE IN IN PRISON AND IN THE
COMMUNITY- I'M I'M REALLY GLAD
THAT THAT'S CHANGED WITH THEIR
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. BEHIND HIM
WHO WERE IN THE SAME SITUATION
AND SO I APPRECIATE THIS THIS
INTEREST IN FINDING MORE
PATHWAYS FOR THESE FOLKS COME
HOME BECAUSE OF THE
CONTRIBUTION THEY MAKE WHEN
THEY GET HERE- I THINK THAT THE-
ALL ALL THIS REALLY IS TO SAY
THAT. I THINK COMPREHENSIVE- A
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. DURING AND
AFTER KERR SERRATION ARE KEY TO
FINDING WAYS TO REDUCE THE
PRISON POPULATION I THINK WE
HAVE SOME MODELS THAT THAT-
WORK I THINK THEY RELY ON
CONTINUING THE SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE START INSIDE ONCE THEY
COME HOME DON'T JUST LEAVE THEM
HANGING- YEP YEP TO START
PROGRAMS EARLY ENOUGH WHILE
PEOPLE INSIDE CONTINUE TO THEM
LONG ENOUGH AFTER OUTSIDE THAT
INCLUDES THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THEY NEED COUNTING WHEN
THEY COME HOME- CAUSES A TRAUMA
THAT THE EXPERT. CHAPLAIN AT
LESSONS THE TRAUMA OF BEING
IMPRISONED THE TRAUMA OF COMING
OUT. WE DON'T RECOVERY THAT AND
SO I THINK THERE'S A GREAT NEED
AND PEOPLE LIKE THOSE LA LIKE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEST SUITED
INVEST KILL TO HELP THAT
TRANSITION IT'S WHO IS WHAT HE
WHAT HE DOES SO I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
PERSPECTIVE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- COMMITMENT TO AFFECT
MEANINGFUL CHANGE THE SYSTEM
THAT IS. NEGATIVELY IMPACT
IMPACTED THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO
LIVE AND WORK INSIDE PRISONS
AND YOU KNOW I'LL JUST CALL THE
MEASURE EARLIER. SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE IN A RECENT. STUDIES
INDICATE THAT MOST SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE MOST SURVIVORS OF
CRIME PER FOR AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION WHEN GIVEN THE
OPTION. ESPECIALLY THAT OPTION
LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING LIKE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE- PROBLEM IS
THE NOT GIVEN AN OPTION. IT'S
PRISON OR NOTHING- AND MOST
PEOPLE WOULDN'T USE THAT
SEPARATE SHOULD THIS
OPPORTUNITY I GET REALLY NOT A
TO BE HERE WITH THE MISTER BOND
MISTER JOHNSON THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITH WHAT WE
PROTECT YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM- DOUG BOND
FOLLOWED BY MISTER JOHNSON
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO BOND
WITH THE AMITY FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY AGAIN-
DOUG BONHAM CO FOR AMITY
FOUNDATION- TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MD DATE FOUNDATION LONG
BEFORE I WAS CO FAMILY
FOUNDATION. I WAS A FOSTER
CHILD TO INCARCERATED PARENTS-
THE FOUNDERS OF THIS
ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY GOT ME
OUT OF FOSTER CARE AFTER BEING
IN OVER A DOZEN FOSTER HOMES
THAT INTERVENTION HELPED CHANGE
MY LIFE IN THIS KIND OF THE
PASSION FOR WHY DO THIS TODAY.
I HAD A NOT BELIEVED IN A
SINGLE FATHER COMING OUT OF
PRISON THE COULDN'T READ OR
WRITE AND HAD BEEN IMPRISONED
SUMMERTIME'S GETTING CUSTODY OF
HIS CHILD MYSELF FROM MY SISTER
WOULDN'T BE. REUNITED WITH HER
FAMILY MY MOTHER THEN GOT OUT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX HELP
START THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY
WITH- THOSE ALL. AT OUR DONOVAN
IN NINETEEN NINETY AND HELPED A
LOT OF PEOPLE THROUGH THAT
PATHWAY FAMILY FOUNDATION AND
AMITY FOUNDATION- WHEN I CAME
WAS SERVING UNDER PEOPLE WERE
SMALL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WERE NOW IN OVER
TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE AND HAVE
SIX HUNDRED EMPLOYEES MANY OF
WHOM HAVE. PACKED BY THE SYSTEM.
MEMOS ON EXPANDING PROGRAMS
LIKE SPECIALIZED TREATMENT
OPTIMIZE PROGRAMMING WHICH IS
CALLED STOP THE CDC ARE FUNDED
PROGRAM- THE MEN'S COMMUNITY
RANGER PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO COME HOME THE LAST
YEAR BEFORE THEIR SENS WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF VERY GOOD
SUCCESS WITH THAT. AND THEN
ALSO TOOL FOR NONPROFITS LIKE
AMITY FOUNDATION A REVOLVING
FUND THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
HELP OBTAIN PROPERTIES- AND
WERE REALLY BOLD INTO A LOT OF
PRIVATE PROPERTY HUNTERS RIGHT
NOW POLICE IN THOSE PROPERTIES
DOESN'T REALLY HELP TO.
NONPROFITS IN TERMS OF STRENGTH
IN BEING ABLE TO PAY OUR STAFF
AND HAVE ASSETS AS AN
ORGANIZATION- BUT THE REPAIR
WORK IS WHERE- CELLS THAT AND
OTHER STUDENTS SO I JUST WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT- COLLABORATION IS RALPH
MENTIONED THIS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT CDC ARE VISITED NINE
PRESENCE OVER THE LAST WEEK AND
A HALF- WE OPERATE IN EIGHTEEN
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SIX COUNTY JAILS. ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT BEDS AND TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND IT TRULY
DOES HAVE TO BE A COLLABORATION
WITH CITIES HERE ARE TEN YEARS
AGO I WOULD HAVE BEEN WELCOME
THEN THE WAY WERE BEING WELCOME
TODAY TO THE INSTITUTIONS
EGGMAN CORRECTION FOR THEIR-
THEIR CHANGE THE- FOR THE
DIRECT THAT WE'RE GOING ON WE-
HAVE A LOT OF GROUND STILL A
LOT TO BE DONE. AND THIS IS A
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE THIS ISN'T
SIMPLY JUST DOING ONE SERVICE
AND THAT ONE SERVICE IT'S GOING
TO HELP. EVERYTHING THERE IS A
LOT. MINISH SEE NO OF HOUSE
ISSUE. AND THERE'S MANY THINGS
THAT WE WERE ON WE CLASS ORGAN
AND WE THE WITHOUT MANY GROUP
LIKE HE SAID OTHERS WE COULDN'T
DO WHAT WE DO AND SO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THAT ONE
INTERVENTION IS GONNA CHANGE
EVERYTHING IS VERY FULL AND
QUITE FRANKLY- WE COORDINATE
WITH SO MANY AMAZING
ORGANIZATIONS SO MANY COMMUNITY
BASED GROUPS THAT REALLY HELP
COLLECTIVELY HELP BRING PEOPLE
HOME SO. JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT YOU TO TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE IMPORTANT ROLES A
COLLABORATION AND HOW THAT'S
DONE IN THE COMMUNITY AND HOW
THAT ACTUALLY GET A RE. LIKE
HE'S GROUP- AND OTHERS REALLY-
ESSENTIAL FOR WHAT WE DO REALLY
GIVING HOPE TO INDIVIDUALS
THAT. DON'T HAVE A LOT OF HOPE
IN THE INSTITUTION MAKING SURE
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT.
THAT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND INMATES HAVE- FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE COMMUNITY IN THE
IMPACT ON THEM WHEN THEY COME
HOME. SOME OF THE BARRIERS FOR
US WITH HOUSING IN IS A LOT A
LOT OF PERMANENT HOUSING. SITES
REALLY ALLOW OUR PLACEMENT FOR
MEN AND WOMEN TO GO INTO
APARTMENTS THAT DEFINITION
HOMELESSNESS. IS WORKING
AGAINST US IN TERMS OF SOMEBODY
COMING HOME I'M NOT GOING TO
PUT SOMEBODY ON THE STREETS TO
THAT FOR THEM TO SAY THEY'RE
HOMELESS. JUST TO GET INTO
HOUSING AND RISKS THAT- SO WHAT
THE STATE IS DONE WITH THE
BBC'S GRANT. TO A LOT I'LL PAY
SUBSIDIES A RENTAL SUBSIDIES IS
DEFINITELY IMPORTANT EXPANDING
ON PROGRAMS LIKE THAT. IS
ESSENTIAL- REALLY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT CAN
REDUCES BARRIERS. I THINK IS
VERY ESSENTIAL FOR US- MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE AFTER CARE IF
WE TALK ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN A
PRISON WE HAVE TO HAVE
ALTERNATIVES YOU CAN SIMPLY
JUST. SHUT DOWN IMPRISONING
PEOPLE TO COME OFF ON A BUS AND
GREYHOUND AND LAND IN LA- AND
IT UP IN SKID ROW SO WE HAVE TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
DEVELOPING. CAPACITY IT TAKES
ANYWHERE FROM A YEAR TO TWO
YEARS TO GET IT THIS CAN GO ON.
OUR RESIDENTS SO THERE LAW HOLD
TIMES CON. BUT HERE'S A AND
OTHER BARRIERS THAT WE HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH BEFORE WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET ONTO CAMPUS. I GO.
YEAH SIR THINGS THAT CAN. DID
YOU YES AND WITH THE
CORRECTIONS. TO STRING THAT
PROCESS IF YOU. HELPERS TO HIGH
FORMALLY IN CAR. MEN WOMEN THAT
HAVE BEEN IN. YOU WILL SEE A-
WHEN YOU ASK FOR THAT VETERAN
YOU SEE RESPONSE. AND SO WE
WOULD HAVE TO ENCOURAGE THOSE
KIND OF- REQUIREMENTS OR
INCENTIVES. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WERE BUILDING FIVE HUNDRED
UNITS PERMANENT SPORT OF
HOUSING BECAUSE IF WE DEVELOP
IT THEY CAN'T SAY NO. QUITE
FRANKLY TO THE MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN THAT ARE COMING OUT
THAT ARE IN OUR PROGRAMS. SO
HAVING THOSE INCENTIVES IN
PLACE- IS CERTAINLY HELPFUL AND
HAVING DEVELOPERS ACTUALLY WILL
TRY TO SKIP A ROOF. SS PEOPLE
AND NOT ASSESS PEOPLE OUT
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT GOING ON
IN THE COMMUNITY. BETTER
LEVERAGING A PROGRAMS IS
CERTAINLY SO STATE FUNDS
CERTAIN PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TRANSITION NATURE. MAKE THE-
LEVER WITH RESOURCE FROM THE-
FROM THE COUNTY. AND THE
PROVIDERS LIKE. ACCOUNTABLE TO
THAT- WHAT LEVERAGE RESOURCES
ARE WE LOOK UTILIZING. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR WITH
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARDS-
THOSE ARE ALL VERY ESSENTIAL
FOR US SOME OF THE POLICIES
RECENTLY. ARE TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT AGAIN ONE SIZE FITS ALL SO
WE'RE HOUSING FOR PROVIDERS
WELL- WE DO. A SERVICES FOR
VIGILS THERE SIR MENTAL ILL
CYCLING NOW TO QUE JAIL. THOSE
PROGRAMS LOOK VERY DIFFERENT
THAN ON LAW FOR PROGRAM. AND
PEOPLE COME IN HOW AFTER THE
YEARS THE CARS SOME OF THE
HOUSING FIRST CHALLENGES FOR
EVERYTHING THAT STATE FUNDED
NOW WHILE WE SUPPORT THAT.
WOULD PUT BARRIERS IN FRONT OF
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ONE THAT DOES
WENT THROUGH AND LIKE THE ONES
THAT PEOPLE COMING OUT FOR LIFE
SENTENCES OR SO JUST BE MINDFUL
THAT IT'S AND WELL INTENTIONED-
BUT ON THE GROUND AND GET.
THESE FACILITIES UP AN
OPERATING CREATE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS. SO I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S TIME TO LISTEN TO
THIS APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
AND THANK YOU. VERY MUCH-
MISTER JOHNSON WE'RE LOOKING TO
BRING IT HOME. HE MY NAME IS
THOUGH JOHNSON AND THANK YOU
MISTER WHY AND MISTER MOM. THEY
NOW CONSUMERS MIGHT. I'VE BEEN
WITH WHILE NINE NOW. THE TWENTY
OR TO A CAMPAIGN IN THE PRISON.
IN GOT INDUCED. ANY FOR MARK.
IN NOT FOR CAME TO PRISON NINE
EIGHTY. I WANT TO GUY TO DO IN
EIGHTY. I GOT TO IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IT WAS A DAY MANY
PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE THE TWO IS
PAID IN AND I WAS THERE FLOWS
AND YOU HAD TO WAIT ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IS CAN IN A- IN
A LOT OF. I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU
GUYS ARE LOOKING TO DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW MOVED TO HAVE MORE
PROGRAM TO PRISON BECAUSE IT IS
BENEFICIAL FOR THE PEOPLE IT IS
A FIFTY FIFTY THING YOU KNOW
YOU GUYS GIVEN THE PERSON GOT
TO GIVE. IN I TOOK FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
IT WHEN PEOPLE PUT ME IN A
PLACE TO BE A PART OF A
PROGRAM. OR OR- YOU NEED TO
PULL UP ENERGY SOMEONE TO
CHANGE MY LIFE WHEN I WANT TO
PROVE MY DAUGHTERS ONE YEAR OLD
WHEN I GOT OUT TO WAS. TO HOME.
THE MORE. HOME I MARRIED A
THIRTY SAID. GRAND NINE GREAT%
GRAND. I'M IN THE PROCESS OF
BUYING NO. IN A YOU KNOW. IS
BECAUSE I TOOK A- OF. UP TO
LEARN ABOUT WE'RE MISTER WHAT
HE WAS TALKING. ABOUT ACCOUNT.
SAVING ACCOUNTS. HOW DO YOU
WANT. YOU MY OUT OF YOUR- BEEN
FREE TO A- IN A- ENEMY. FORT
MEADE BUT- STATE IT THEY
TRANSITION HOUSE A TEN MINUTE
NEW GAVE ME OPPORTUNE TO LOOK
AT LIFE FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
COSTA RATE YOU SEE THINGS ONE
WAY WHEN YOU GET OUT REALITY
SIT SEEN. IN THINGS IT CHANGES
I KNOW WHAT I WANT TO MAKE
DONALD FIRST TIME IN ORDER THE
SODA. IN THE LADY GAVE ME A CUP
AND ASK WILL WITH MY SOUL.
MISSION WITH OVER THERE. SOME
STUFF THAT KNOW WHEN I MY LOOK
CORD TO GIVE YOU YOU GOT TO GO.
IN AND WE A CARD IN YOU WAIT
FOR YOU MONEY. I FORGOT TO PUT
NUMBER IN THERE BECAUSE THEY
TIM AT TO PUT PHONE NUMBERS IS
STUFF. THAT WE- LEARNED MOM IS.
AND HELPED ME WHEN YOU GET A-
OF WOULDN'T BE ANY COST. FOR
TIME BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
TECHNOLOGY A CHANGE LIKE WITH
THE PHONE LIKE IT EMINI WE A-
HAVE SOME STUDENTS WHO WILL. WE
TECHNOLOGY WE DO CLASSES LIKE
THAT WE DO A LOT OF SOCIAL
TEAMS BECAUSE- WHEN YOU'RE
PRISON IS NOT THAT MUCH SOCIAL
ACTIVITY DID YOU CAN
PARTICIPATING. SO WE HAVE A LOT
OF SOCIAL VISIT WE TAKE THE MAN
OUT TO LIKE THE AVIATORS NOW
AND WHEN I. I WOULD LIKE.
ALMOST SIXTY YEARS OLD THE
FIRST TIME EVER GOING TO. WATCH
IN THE PLAY. SELECT HONEST IS
NEW FOR ME AND IN THE SAME THE
SPECTER ABOUT LIFE BECAUSE
BLOOD THING TO HAVE. BEEN DOING
LIKE I HAVE FIVE MILLION TO DO.
TOMORROW NIGHT ON TO A GAME THE
FIRST TIME THEY CAN BE GOING TO
THE STATE WAS IN. EVEN BLOOM
WHEN I MEAN IT WOULDN'T MADE
WHEN THEY WERE. WENT TO PRISON.
SO IT A LOT OF STONE ARE YOU
KNOW BECAUSE LIKE. WHAT IS LOT
OF THE- AND KNOWLEDGE. WE WENT
TO. IN EUROPE. OWN IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD STEP LIKE THAT
WHEN I GREW UP MARCH A
COMMUNITY. IT WAS TAUGHT THE
YOU WOULD A MAN AND THAT SHE
WOULD. IN THAT WAS BEING STORED
IN COMMUNITY IN WHEN I WAS
TWELVE. ABOUT FIFTY YEARS A LOT
OF MY FREE TO MAKE FORTY.
BECAUSE ALL OF. BUT IS TO MAKE.
WAS TO LIKE. SO LIKE WHEN I
WENT TO PRE. I MAY A CONSCIOUS
DECISION I WANTED. SOME AND I
WANT TO GET SOME BACK TO MIKE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M DON'T. YEAH
BELIEVE. BECAUSE OF. COUNT IT
BE CAN NOW. WELL I'LL SHOULD
FIVE MILLION. KERN NEEDED GET
NOT A- INMATE ADJUSTMENTS TO
CSUS. IN ONE OF THE- THING WE
ARE. DO IT I CAN. WE BRING TO
FOR. IN HAVE THE END WITH THE
FOR. AND IS SEVEN OF THEM. TO
NAY. IN FOR THEM. LAW OF GUYS.
YOU KNOW. OUR FAMILY IS NOT
HILL. FOR BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
LIVING RIGHT SO WE HAD TO LIKE
YOU KNOW TO IF WITH BECAUSE THE
MINIMUM THEM MY OWN THAT WAS A
OUT ALSO WITH AND HAVE SOME OF
THE REAL ON TO LET BECAUSE IN I
LIVE IN. UNION DON'T GET OUT TO
MY DAD WITH MY WALL MIGHT IN A
CURVED IS A BETTER WAY TO YOU
GOT TO THE CORD YOU'D GONE TO
YOU BACK TO PREVIOUS. INVEST IN
YOUR HOUSE ONLY NEW BE SOME YOU
THEM MAY NOT GO FOR YOU IN YOU
HAD TO BE USED ENOUGH SAY LOOK
I LOVE YOU BUT I LOVE FROM A DO
IN A MIKE NONE MY FOR FROM
DISTANT BECAUSE I DON'T. YOU
KNOW CITY UP WE GO BACK TO
PRISON FOR OF THIS TO THEY DO
SO KNOW IN THIS WOULD MARTIN
AYE AFTER TO DO MISS. WHAT IT.
IT MERELY GIVE ME A DAY IN THE
YOU KNOW LIKE AND I WANT HIM TO
HAVE MORE THAN I HAVE YOU KNOW
ANYWAY I COULD DO IT'S CHAU
WARM DID YOU AWAY. YOU HAD TO
PUT JUST THE TO WANT TO DO HAVE
TO DRESS TO DO TICK YOU TO
PRISON. YOU KNOW OU HAD TO
ADDRESS THE THING THAT YOU HAVE
TO MAKE BETTER DECISIONS IN
YOUR LIFE BECAUSE WE HAVE MADE
A LOT ON HIS DECISION TO HIM
BECAUSE WE HEARD. IT ONCE YOU
FIND OUT WHAT HER COOPER FROM
YOU STARTED DRESSING NET BEING
DESTROYED HEALING YOURSELF. TOO
YOU KNOW. WE WILL TO HELP WITH
THE COMMUNITY IN OTHER PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE CORRELATE OUT STUFF
WITH OTHER PEOPLE WE HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE COME AND TEACH IT RIGHT
NOW I HAVE A LETTER CONTAINS
COMING TO SIT FOR THE LAST SIX
BUT HELP ME IS HOW TO HAVE
RELATIONS TO WE. BECAUSE OUR-
PERSPECTIVE HAVEN'T REALLY.
WOMEN TOTALLY. FROM THE WOMEN
LOOK AT IT. IN IT DIDN'T REALLY
HELP. FOR THE WAY. TO SHARE
WITH ME LAWLER. THE NUMBER ONE
THING TO LIVE IS GO BACK TO
PRISON FOR IS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OR RELATIONSHIPS. IS THAT WE
TRY TO DO THIRD EFFORT MY
COMMUNITY WE WON'T MEN AND
LEARNED THAT HAVE HELPED
RELATIONS. I BRING MY WIFE
BROWN SHOE ON MY NECK WITH MY
WIFE IS TO LIKE THAT I LET ME
COMES. WITH HER EIGHT G. THE
YOU DON'T LIKE ABOUT ME YOU
KNOW I. TO DATE SOME THINGS TO
YOU BECAUSE I DON'T WANT THEM
TO SEE. YOU KNOW LIFE IS GOOD
ON THE OTHER SIDE AND NOT AND
YOU MAY I SAID AGAIN I'M TO
HAVE A- IN BEEN USED IN WITHIN
AND- BECAUSE- I'M- TO. GOD IS
GOOD ME WITH A- MAKE DIFFERENT
MARK OF FULL. OF. THANK YOU
VERY FOR COMING TODAY IN YOUR
WILL. TO SHOW YOUR PURSE. WHAT
THE FACT THANK YOU. THANK PANEL
WHILE I HAVE YOU THE WE ARE IN
A FIVE COULD I THINK WE ENOUGH.
THANK YOU WE WOULD INVITE. DEUS
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE FIRST TO
PAY TO THIS. ON BECAUSE I WANT
EVERY TO BE A TO BE OF A AS I
OPENED. TO QUESTIONS FROM OF
THE- AGAIN LIKE TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR TO. A RECOVERY
LEARN WITH THE CUBS. THE TO SEE
BUT THE- IF YOU WOULD LIKE I
APPRECIATE THAT THE SO. WILL ON
THAT FROM YOU MESSAGE. AND WILL
MAKE SURE BECOME MEMBER. IT
THANK YOU. YEAH BUT THANK YOU.
AB I'VE GOT ONE QUESTION AND
THEN GOING TO PAY THE TWO
COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR THROUGH
THE NIELS AND THEN I SOME SKIN.
SENATOR MORE LAW. SENATOR. THAT
TEN THIRTY BILL THANK YOU. A AS
A FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE WE HAD
A COMMITTEE HEARING JUST THIS
WEEK ON CLIMATE CHANGE WHERE WE
WERE IT HEARD A VARIETY
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS ALL OF
US ATTENDED THE STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS YESTERDAY WHERE
THE GOVERNOR FOCUSED ON ANOTHER
INQUIRES- INVESTMENTS AND SO
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE VERY
TOUGH DECISIONS AROUND
INVESTMENTS ON BEHALF OF.
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. AND I
THOUGHT OF THAT AS I LIST
TODAY'S. IT'S ONE QUESTION I
HAVE BECAUSE I DO SHARE IN-
SECRETARY DHEAS IS COM AT AS
WELL AS I THINK A COMMENT MADE
ALSO BY MISTER WHAT LEE AND
THAT IS A GOOD KNOWLEDGE IN THE
HEALTH WELL BEING AND SAFETY.
OF ALL THOSE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IMPRISONED BEAT IN
MAJOR PERSONNEL. WE HAVE CLOSE
STATE FACILITIES ARE IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE BUDGET OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS WE HAVE
OVERSEEING THE CLOSURE OF-
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
FACILITIES IN NAPA AND SEVEN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE KNOW WHAT
THAT. EXPERIENCE CAN BE LIKE IT-LOOKS LIKE. I ALSO CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE LIFE EXPERIENCE OF
THOSE EVEN THOUGH THE FOCUS
THANKS TO THE COURT ORDER IS
REDUCING THE POPULATION WE ALSO
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS
OF THE HEALTH WELL BEING AND
SAFETY OF THOSE WHO ARE STILL
INCARCERATED. AND THESE MANY
THESE INSTITUTIONS ARE QUITE
OLD- BECAUSE OF THE GREAT
RECESSION IN OUR WAYS OF
SURVIVING- WHEN BUDGETS WERE
WERE LESS THAN HALF WHAT
TODAY'S PROPOSED BUDGET IS WAS
A REDUCTION IN FUNDING AROUND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
SPECIAL REPAIRS. I REMEMBER
HEARING THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE HAD
TO MAKE A DECISION ABOUT. A
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR BOILER. IN
A FIFTH THAT WAS FOR CLOSE. BUT
AGAIN WE HAVE A RISK. FOR
MAINTAINING THEM TODAY. SO IF
YOU COULD TALK TO US VERY
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE ACCUMULATED.
BACK LOG OF SPECIAL REPAIRS AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
BECAUSE- AS WE TALK ABOUT ALL
OF THESE FUNDING
RESPONSIBILITIES- I WANT TO GET
A SENSE OF WHAT YOU THINK THE
OVERALL PRICE TAG IS. BOMB FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THE FACILITIES
WHILE THEY'RE OPEN AND PEOPLE
ARE THERE. OUR HUMANE FOR LACK
OF A BETTER WORD. BUT NO
SECRETARY DAIS AT THAT'S BEST
COMING FROM YOU FINANCE WHOEVER.
CAN REPLY AT APPRECIATED FOR MY-
SURE MY FRIENDS AND FINANCE BY
MISS STATE OR NOT EXPOUNDING
LIKE I SHOULD THEY'LL JUMP IN
AND I KNOW I HAVE SOME REAL
SMART PEOPLE FROM OUR
FACILITIES DIVISION OUT THERE
BUT- TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
ENDEAVOR TO TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
TWELVE OLDEST PRESENCE AND-
THAT'S WHAT TROUBLE THIS
PRISONS RANGING FROM YEARS BILL
FROM. EIGHTEEN FIFTY TWO TO
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE LONG TIME
AGO. THANK AND- A TO THE LASSEN
BILL TO NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
AND WE HAVE GOTTEN SOME-
VOLUMES BACK ON THAT REPORT AND
JUST TAKING A LOOK AT THOSE
ELEVEN SOME OF THE- SOME OF THE
INITIAL NUMBERS TO BRING THOSE
UP TO. A CURRENT INDUSTRY
STANDARDS IS ABOUT OVER ELEVEN
BILLION THAT'S JUST FOR THOSE.
BEYOND THAT- WE HAVE ROOF
REPAIRS WE HAVE- REPAIRS AND
WE'RE DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE BRINGING OUR FACILITIES
UP TO HEALTHCARE STANDARDS. ONE
OF THE ITEMS ON THE BUDGET IT'S
A REQUEST FOR- OUR FACILITY IN
NORCO CRC. AND THAT IS TO
IMPROVE OUR HEALTH CARE
FACILITY TO BRING UP- THE
FLOORING IN THE COUNTER SPACE
UP TO MEDICAL STANDARDS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH TITLE TWENTY
TWO BECAUSE LIKE YOU SAID
SENATOR. THESE ARE PEOPLE
PROVIDED SERVICES FORM. WE DO
HAVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE HOWEVER WE
HAVE ONGOING FUNDING FROM PRIOR
BUDGETS TO INCLUDE THIS YEAR
WE'RE FOCUSING ON ROOFS-
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO HAVE. HUMANE
LIVING CONDITIONS SLEEPING
CONDITIONS AND EVEN AT THAT- I
KNOW THE EFFECTS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WHEN HOUSING UNITS
CLASSROOMS PROGRAM AREAS. THEY
NOT ONLY FOR THE INNOCENT THE
EFFECTIVE STAFF LIVE THERE WITH
MOLD WITH THERE IS I'M SENDING
MY- TO DO SEARCHES AND JUST BE
THERE FOR EIGHT TO SIXTEEN
HOURS A DAY THEY NEED TO BE UP
TO PAR- SO. IT'S INTO THE
BILLIONS BUT WHAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR IN THIS JUSTIN THIS BUDGET
CYCLE IS YOU KNOW IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE HEALTH CARE SIDE FOR
SECRECY. AND THEN- AT SOME
POINT ONGOING FUNDING TO
CONTINUE OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FROM YEARS PAST
WITH THE FOCUS ON ROOFS. NOT TO
MENTION WE ALSO HAVE- FUNDING
SECURED FOR INFILL FOR MEDICAL
SPACES TO EXPAND THEN FOR OUR
INMATE POPULATION SO WE CAN BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH OUR- WITH A
PLOT OF COURT ORDERS A MEDICAL
LAWSUITS THAT WERE IN- SO IT'S
QUITE SUBSTANTIAL- I. HAVE
PEOPLE SAID NOT THAT THEY CAN
GIVE YOU THE EXACT DOLLAR BUT
WAS. IN ON THE TWELVE PRISON.
STUDY PIECE. THAT VERY HELP
HELLO TWO AND A- I DO HAVE THAT
NUMBER FOR THE OTHER 20% OF
OUR- HELPFUL. I'M SORRY AS-
DHEA SAID THE ELEVEN THERE
THERE WAS VERY IN DEPTH STUDY
THAT WAS JUST ISN'T WRAPPED UP
ON THE TWELVE ALL. PRAISE THAT
RECORD A LOT OF OVERLAY BILLION
DOLLARS IN REPAIRS- CITIES HERE
IS ESTIMATED AND- WITH. THAT
SORT OF A DIFFERENT A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENTMETHODOLOGIES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY APPLES TO APPLES TO
THOSE NUMBERS BUT HAS
ESTIMATED. THAT THE NUMBER THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF MAINTENANCE
REQUIRED AT THE OTHER TWENTY
TWO PRISONS BETWEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR WOULD
BE AROUND. EIGHT BILLION. HI I
APPRECIATE THAT I BECAUSE
BECAUSE WHILE THE THREAT OF OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY IS FOCUSED
ON THE CURRENT BUDGET AND THE-
ANTICIPATION AND EXCITEMENT
AROUND YOU KNOW POTENTIAL
CLOSURE AND BRING PEOPLE BACK
OUT OF STATE ALL OF WHICH I
FULLY SUPPORT YOU KNOW WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE MINDFUL. OF OUR YOU
KNOW LESS EXCITING MORE ARCANE
RESPONSIBILITY AS LANDLORDS AND
EMPLOYERS AND MAKING SURE SO I
WANT TO JUST ALL OF US TO HAVE
A- GENERAL IDEA OF WHAT THOSE
OVERALL COSTS ARE IN TERMS OF
MAINTENANCE ONE FINAL QUESTION
FOR ME THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MR NIELSEN- BECAUSE- THAT
DOLLAR FIGURE ALSO LEADS TO BE.
CONSIDERED WHEN WE THINK ABOUT-
WANT TO DRAW AN IMMEDIATE
CORRELATION TO THE REDUCTION
POPULATION AND YET WHY IS NOT
THE CITY SEE OUR BUDGET YOU
KNOW DECLINE IN THAT IT'S AN
EQUAL RIGHT THIS IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY. BUT IF THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE LA- WHOEVER
CHOOSES TO RESPOND COULD GIVE
US A HIGH LEVEL SINCE OF WHAT
SOME OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
COST DRIVERS ARE. TO THE BUDGET
DESPITE THE POPULATION DECLINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR PUTTING
IN CONTEXT THE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT DEBT REDUCTION ALL BIDS
ON THE SAYING. FIVE PRE SHEET
THAT BUT IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE
US A HIGH LEVEL. UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT SOME OF THOSE COSTS
DRIVERS ARE TO HELP EDUCATE THE
COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE AND OUR
MEMBERSHIP AT THE DID SENATE AS
A WHOLE SO WE STOP. WITH THAT
RATHER YOU KNOW KIND OF SOFT
MORE ARITHMETIC GAME IF WE'RE
DOWN BY FIVE PEOPLE THEN WE
SHOULD BE DOWN BY 5% IT IS NOT
THAT SIMPLE SO TALK TO US ABOUT
SOME OF THE COST DRIVERS PLEASE
I THINK- I'LL SPEAK I'LL TAKE A
STAB AT AND I THINK THE THINGS
THAT I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH. IS
THE FIRST ONE IS THE HEALTH
CARE MENTAL HEALTH COSTS AND
HAVE RISEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT HAVE BEEN AS A RESULT OF-
COURT ORDERS BUT EVEN BEYOND
THE COURT OR JUST DOING THE
RIGHT THING FOR THE POPULATION.
SO THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE MAIN
DRIVERS- ONE OF THE SECOND
PIECE IS EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
AND BENEFITS- THEY HAVE GONE
UP- AND I DO GET QUESTIONED I
WAS QUESTION IN THE LA TIMES
ARTICLE LAST YEAR WHEN A
PARTICULAR BY UNIT GOT A RAISE
IN THE **** DO YOU SECRETARY
BELIEVE THAT THEY DESERVED A
RAISE AND THAT'S KIND OF A
LOADED QUESTION. NO WAY
RESPONDED WAS AT I DEMAND OF MY
EMPLOYEES AND THEY DO A JOB
THAT MANY STONE MANY PEOPLE
CAN'T OR WON'T DO. SO I DO
DEMAND A LOT SO THAT'S A
RELATIVE QUESTION. SO I DO
BELIEVE THEY DESERVE THE
COMPENSATION THEY'RE GETTING.
SO THAT THAT'S BEEN ANOTHER
DRIVER AND- THE THIRD DRIVER-
REALLY HAS COME FROM- YOU KNOW
THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS THAT WE HAVE
INVESTED IN. AND THESE ARE
INVESTMENT DOLLARS US WAY LOOK
AT THEM. AS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
FROM PRIOR PANELS IN THE LAST
PANEL. THESE ARE INVESTMENT
DOLLARS AT AS WE HAVE GROWN A
REHABILITATIVE CATALOG AND
PORTFOLIO. WE LEARNED ALONG THE
WAY. AND WE WERE TRYING TO BE A
DYNAMIC. REHABILITATIVE AGENCY
NOT JUST GOING BY THE OLD WAYS
OF DOING BUSINESS IS SOMETHING
WORK FIVE YEARS AGO THAT MEANS
IT'S GOING TO WORK THE NEXT
FIFTEEN YEARS THAT'S NOT THE
CASE. BECAUSE WE HAVE NEW
POPULATIONS IN NEW AGES AND
DEMOGRAPHICS COME IN
INSTITUTIONS WITH NEW NEEDS AND
WE HAVE TO. MEET THE MORE THE
RAT WITH THE CURRENT NEEDS SO
EVERYTHING FROM THE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR- ADVANCEMENTS TO- WHAT
I CALL SOME MORE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT AT
TIMES WE GET. I GET ASKED YOU
KNOW THE EVIDENCE BASE WHICH IS
A VERY VALID QUESTION BUT I
ALWAYS LOOK AT THOSE AS THESE
ARE PROGRAMS THAT COME IN THEIR
PRIMERS. FOR INDIVIDUALS. WITH
AND STOP AND- TOWARDS A MORE
EVIDENCE BASED. PROGRAM WHERE
THEY HAVE TO ACHIEVE MILESTONES
IN THAT THEY HAVE TO TAKE
EXAMINATIONS AND THAT THE
PROOF. THAT THEY HAVE LEARNED
CONCEPTS AND THAT THE HOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO THE LIFE TO LIVES.
SO ARE WE- PORTFOLIO CATALOG IS
TO HAVE TO EXPAND YEARS. WE
HAVE A MORE SERIOUS INVITE. POP
THAT WE HAD IN YOUR- BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT SENT US. AS WE WERE
YOUNGER PA. COME TO US ONE OF
THE BUDGET I JUST FOR A- IF.
FOR EXT. AT VALLEY STAY PRISON
AND THAT'S FOR INDIVIDUAL
CENTERS FROM NINE. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWO YEARS AND
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A LITTLE
SEVEN. OF THOSE INTO. THE RIGHT
NOW IN A PRISON SYSTEM IN MADE
AGE AGES FOR EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
THERE'S OVER TEN THOUSAND.
THAT'S A OF YOUNG PEOPLE OUR
ANSWER. HAVE SEE THE IN MY THE
YEARS I STARTED A ONE OF AGE. I
SEEN IN MAYES COMING AT TWO ONE
TWO NOW THERE YEARS OLD LIKE ME.
AND I JUST THINK IF WE WERE
ABLE TO REACH SOMEONE I BEGAN
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A DIFFERENT
OUTCOME. THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO
HAVE GONE THROUGH. SOME OF THE
VIOLENT INCIDENTS THAT OCCUR IN
THE DAYS OF OLD IN PRISON WE DO
HAVE ISLAND INCIDENT STILL. BUT
I THINK IF WE REACH THEM- WITH-
WITH THE MORE- INFORMED AND A
MORE. COGNIZANT WAY OF REACHING
THEM IN WHATEVER THEIR NEEDS
ARE SO I THINK THE THIRD ONE IS
A REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS. THANK
YOU ELIA AT WE ACTUALLY DID
JUST RELEASE A BRIEF FOR READ A
ADDRESS THIS QUESTION OF WHY.
THE A BUDGET FOR CITIES HERE IS
INCREASED BY OVER THREE BILLION
WHEN THE INMATE POPULATION
DECLINE SIGNIFICANTLY AS WELL
AS A POORLY POPULATION SO. I'D
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW NOW IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
WE IDENTIFIED THREE MAJOR
DRIVERS OF CDC ARE EXPENDITURES
OVER THE LAST DECADE OR SO- THE
FIRST ONE IS THE COURT ORDERS
THAT I SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER IN
MISTER DE IDEA REFERENCED- THE
ORDER TO REDUCE PRISON
OVERCROWDING. MEANT THAT THE
STATE HAD TO. HAD TO NOT ONLY
REDUCE THE PRISON POPULATION
BUT ALSO EXPAND CAPACITY BY
BUILDING AND ACTIVATING NEW-
INFILL AND WHAT A NEW PRISON
AND NEW INFILL CAPACITY ON
PRISON GROUNDS- AS WELL AS-
CONTRACTING FOR ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY SO- AND LEASING
FACILITIES SO WE'RE ACTUALLY.
DESPITE THE POPULATION DECLINE
OPERATING MORE FACILITIES THAN
WE WERE BEFORE SAYS OVERHEAD
COSTS OF HAVE. AN INCREASED AND
STAFFING COSTS- IT WE'VE ALSO
HAD TO COMPLY- WITH OR COURT
ORDERS RELATED TO EXPANDING IN
MADE HEALTH CARE WHICH HAS BEEN
QUITE COSTLY- AND SO. WHILE THE
STAFFING LEVELS DID DECLINE
OVERALL STAFF DID TO SOMEONE. A
REALIGN YOU KNOW FOR PERHAPS
FROM THINGS LIKE NOT HAVING TO
OPERATE- GYMNASIUMS AS HOUSING
UNITS AND- THE PRO POPULATION
DECLINE ALSO WOULD HAVE COSTS
AND STAFFING INCLINED- THESE
FACTORS SUCH AS- A- ACTIVATING
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY AND
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDING HEALTH
CARE STAFF IN PARTICULAR HAVE.
BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF STAFF TO
RETURN TO ROUGHLY PRE LINE
REALIGNMENT LEVELS- THE SECOND
ISSUE A SECOND MAJOR DRIVER AND
IS EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION SO
EVEN. THOUGH THAT WERE AT THE
SAME ROUGHLY SAME- STAFFING
LEVEL AS WE WERE PRE ALIGN
REALIGNMENT- WE'RE SPENDING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE. THE COST
PER EMPLOYEE HAS INCREASED BY
43% SINCE THREE PRE
REALIGNMENT- THAT'S DOUBLE THE
RATE OF INFLATION- THAT'S-
MAINLY BEAT FOR TWO REASONS-
THAT WE IDENTIFIED. AND THAT IS
THAT AG PENSION CONTRIBUTION
RATES INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
THOSE ARE SET BY THE CALPERS
BOARD AND WE'RE INCREASED-
RELATED TO- IN ORDER TO PAY FOR
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES THAT GREW
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. AND
THEN ALSO SALARY GROWTH OF-
CITIES ARE STAFF GREW. AS
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND THEN THE THIRD
FACTORY IDENTIFIED WAS- AS YOU
ALLUDED TO EARLIER HAT WE DID
THE STATE DID- AS A WAY TO- GET
THROUGH TO THE GREAT. RISK IN
THE FISCAL CRISIS THE STATE
DID- SHIFT COSTS FROM THOSE
EARLY YEARS AROUND THE ERROR OF
THE TIME A REALIGNMENT TO LATER
YEARS SO- A BIG EXAMPLE OF THAT
IS FOR ALLOWING OF CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS SO- WHEN WE- ASK FOR
FURLOUGHS WHEN WE FOR LOW
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS WE STILL
HAVE TO. GUARD THE PRISONS SO-
ESSENTIALLY WE GIVE OFFICERS
INCREASE LEAVE TIME IN EXCHANGE
FOR REDUCED PAY AND SO THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE OFFICERS
LEAVE BALANCES DURING THE- THE
FISCAL CRISIS- WHICH
ARTIFICIALLY THIS ARTIFICIALLY
REDUCED CITY SIR EXPENDITURES
IN THE EARLY YEARS. AND NOW
IT'S THOSE OFFICERS ARE
RETIRING WERE CATCHING THAT OUT
WE'RE PAYING FOR OVERTIME TO
BACKFILL WHEN THEY TAKE
VACATION SO THAT ARTIFICIALLY
INCREASING EXPENDITURES IN
LATER YEARS SO IT'S REALLY ALSO
IN SOME WAYS NOT AN APPLES TO
APPLES TO LOOK AT WHEN THE
STATE WAS IN RECESS THE
RECESSION VERSES. LATER SO AND
THEN FINALLY I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT- HAD THE INMATE POPULATION
NOT DECLINE IN THE IT SING BY
THE SIGNIFICAN MOUNT THAT WE
HAVE SEEN OVER THE LAST DECADE-
THE STATE WOULD HAVE NOT ONLY
WILL HAVE LESS LIKELY VERY LOW
WOULD HAVE HAD TO IN ORDER TO
COMPLY ITH THAT. OVERCROWDING
ORDER WOULD HAVE HAD TO
CONTRACT FOR SAY A
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE CAPACITY AND
OR BUILD POTENTIALLY SOME
PRISONS WOULD HAVE HAD. MAKE
YOU KNOW ENSURE HELL CARE FOR
EVEN IN MADE WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN E. MORE CA. AND WE COULD
BE SPENDING- BILLIONS OF
POTENTIALLY OF DOLLARS MORE NOW
THAN WE ARE. TODAY SO WE'RE
STILL SAVING IN THAT SENSE.
THANK YOU THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS BEFORE WE
ARE A TURN OVER DECISION
NIELSEN THANK YOU FOR THAT SIR
TO NIELSEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND BEFORE I. GO UNDER
THE DIGITAL QUESTIONS I'D LIKE
TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE. ON THE
DRIVING FACTORS WHICH RELATED
TO THE INMATE LAWSUITS. AND
I'M- IMPLICATING PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN AND LEGISLATURE'S
RATING WAY BACK. THAT THE
ORIGINAL LAWSUIT. WE'RE NOT
NEARLY AS ONEROUS. AND HAD THE
STATE ACTED PRO ACTIVELY THOSE
AND GOES BACK TO THE- LATE
EIGHTIES THE PARTICULAR THROUGH
NIGHT. THE LAWSUITS WOULD NEVER
BE WHAT THEY ARE TODAY. BUT THE
STATE DID NOT ACT PRO ACTIVELY.
AND SO THE FINAL TWELVE SWOOP
WITH THE FEDERAL COURTS GETTING
FRUSTRATED SAYING LOOK YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO DO IT WE WILL TAKE
OVER. SO THE PREMIUM IS ON
BEING MORE PROACTIVE. HERE THE
CHALLENGE OF OUR TIMES. WHEN I
BECAME CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
PRISON TERMS MANY YEARS AGO.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I
LEARNED IS IT. REHABILITATION
IN THE INSTITUTION WITHIN AN
ADEQUATE. AND I COULDN'T REALLY
COUNT ON THAT B. AND A HUGE
FACTOR IN THE REHABILITATION OF
ANY PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL.
BECAUSE IT WAS INADEQUATE IN
PART BECAUSE- NOBODY EVER PAID
ANY ATTENTION TO TRACK TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON WITHIN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND I THINK THE
SECRETARY REFERRED TO A LITTLE
BIT AGO. IT ISN'T JUST THAT YOU
WENT TO A OR IN A OR BREAKING
BARRIERS OR WHATEVER. DID YOU
INTERNALIZE IT COULD YOU TAKE
THAT ON YOURSELF. AND APPLY IT.
IN I HAD WANTED YOU TO FROM THE
MOMENT JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO I
RAN INTO A MAN AND A CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THINGS IN STORE
SACRAMENTO THE CAME UP TO ME
SAID YOU KNOW YOU CHANGE MY
WHOLE LIFE THE CENTER I'M SORRY
I DON'T KNOW HOW. YOU CHAIRED
MY PAROLE HEARING. THEN YOU DID
NOT FIND THE SUITABLE. BUT YOU
TOLD ME WHAT I NEEDED TO DO. TO
BE FOUND SUITABLE. THEN I GOT A
COPY OF DECISION. IN A CAPITA.
AND A LEARN BY. IN ANY EXTOLLED
THE VIRTUES AND WHAT NEW NOW
DEL ARE TELLING US HERE TODAY
YOU WANT TO PAY ATTENTION TO
BUSINESS AND YOU DID ANY CHANGE.
I MY POINT IS THAT WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTIONS WE NEED TO DO A
LOT BETTER JOB OF FOLLOWING THE
INDIVIDUAL THROUGH THEIR
TREATMENT REGIMENS. TO SEE IF
THEY DO THEIR JOB. I WANNA
THANK SECTOR DS AS WELL IT'S
BEEN MY PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
HIM SOME SINCE HIS. TENURE
BEGAN ON THE- ON THAT AS A
SECRETARY THERE. AND IT'S
TOUGHEST JOB IN GOVERNMENT. FOR
THE AGENCY PEOPLE. THE PORTAL
IN THE INSTITUTION. AND IT'S
PRETTY TOUGH JOB FOR THE
INMATES TO. WHEN I'VE HAD
PEOPLE TELL ME OVER THE YEARS-
THEY HAVE THAT'S A COUNTRY CLUB
ALL THEY DO IS WATCH TV AND GET
THEIR THREE SQUARES. WELL I
SAID THAT'S NOT A CUT CLUB YOU
WILL TO GO TO. IF YOU ARRANGE
TO GET IN THERE FOR A WHILE ACT
ARRANGE IT FOR YOU. I DON'T
DIFFERENCE TO YOU THOUGH YOU'LL
KNOW THERE'S A GAVE GUNDRY AND
YOU LEAVE. PRESS ARE NOT
COUNTRY CLUB. AND THE ISSUE OF
PERSONNEL WHO WORK THERE IN.
WHAT MY GREATEST CONCERNS. WITH
THE PEOPLE IN MY EMPLOY. WASN'T
TAKEN AT HOME. THEN I LEARNED
HOW TO SEE WHEN THEY WERE TAKEN
AT HOME. AND I BRING HIM IN THE
OFFICE ALONE SEC TAKEN OUT.
WHAT I MEAN AFTER ALL. I MEAN.
AND TRY TO WORK THEM SO THAT
THEY COULD CALL. THAT IS A VERY
DIFFICULT AND IT IS CALLED BY
CORRECTING PIECE OFF TO THE
TOUGHEST BEAT FOLKS IT IS THE
TOUGHEST BEAT. THEY GET
CRITICIZED AN AWFUL LOT. IT IS
THE TOUGHEST BEAT. AND WE NEED
TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN. TO MAKE
THE INSTITUTIONS BETTER FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL DARIAN AND TO ENSURE
THE REHABILITATIVE. PURPOSE AND
MISSION. IS EFFECTIVE BUT LET
US NOT FORGET AS WELL THOUGH
INSTITUTIONS ARE ALL FOR
PUNISHMENT AS WELL. BUT THE
BIGGEST ELEMENT OF THE SYSTEM.
THIS JUSTICE. JUSTICE FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED AND ARE
YOU IN THEIR TIME. AND JUSTICE
FOR CRIME VICTIMS. NOW OF LATE
EVEN IN THIS BUILDING CRIME
VICTIMS ARE PRETTY WELL
IGNORED. FACTORY BEEN REDEFINED
WHO THEY ARE. THAT DOES CONCERN
ME. AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU LOOK AT IN A THE- IS THERE
IN REMORSE. ARE THEY CAPABLE OF
FOR THEM SO IN THE SHOES. OF
THE PEOPLE THE BASED OF WHAT
THE DEBT. MANY CAN. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT MUST REALLY
EMPHASIZE IS EARLY INTERVENTION
BROKEN WINDOW THEORY. I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW IN HOW MANY
PAROLEES TO DEATH ROW INMATES.
THAT I'M QUITE IT WITH THEIR
LIFE HISTORIES. AND A WHIP IN
MY HEART FOR THE CHILD THEY
WERE. DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE. BUT
I HAVE TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
CONSEQUENCES THINGS HE DID
LATER ON. BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON A SOCIETY
IS OUR FAMILY. THE
STRENGTHENING OF FAMILIES. IN
THE ROLE THE PARENTS IN THOSE
FAMILIES. AND I KNOW THAT MAKES
A DIFFERENCE. THERE WAS ALWAYS
A DELIGHT WHEN YOU WOULD SEE
THE BLACK GOAL OFTEN SOMEBODY'S
EYES AND THEY THEY GOT IT. WELL
ENOUGH OF THAT PROTECTED THE AS
I WANT TO ALSO YOU FOR
COOPERATING WITH SOMETHING THAT
I THINK IS INSTRUCTED MAYBE TO
THE- BOARD HERE'S- THE
COMMITTEE. YOUR AGENCY HAS
COOPERATED WITH ME FOR SOME
TWENTY YEARS CONDUCTING A
SEMINAR ON THE DEATH PENALTY AT
SAN QUENTIN EVERYYEAR FOR THE
EGG LEADERSHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
A FELLOWSHIP FOR ABOUT THIRTY
FARMERS. MY EXPERIENCE IN
DEALING WITH THE DEATH PENALTY
IS I HAD TO DIRECTLY TO TEN
TIMES. IS THIS IS A VERY GRAVE
AND HEAVY ISSUE ALWAYS A PUBLIC
POLICY ISSUE IT EBBS AND FLOWS
IT'LL ALWAYS BE THERE. BUT I
HAVE DECIDED TO CONDUCT THIS AS
THE SEMINAR FOR THESE FELLOWS.
AND WE BEGIN I TELL IN THIS IS
NOT ABOUT THE DEATH PENALTY
IT'S LIKE YOU COMING HERE TO
HEAR ABOUT THE DEATH PENALTY
THEY WE HAVE PEOPLE SPEAK FOR
AGAINST. HIM HAD A DEATH ROW
INMATE FROM. OKLAHOMA WAS
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED. CAME AND
SPOKE SEVERAL YEARS TO US. GREG
WILL HEART. I SAID THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THE DEATH PENALTY IT'S
ABOUT YOU HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
A VERY GRAVE ISSUE. OR NO
LONGER IS IT GOING TO BE AS
ABSTRACT AS IT HAS BEEN BEFORE.
NOT MY POINT TO THAT IS JUST AS
FAR SOCIETY LOOKS AT THIS
SYSTEM AND MAYBE SOMETIMES SAYS
FLIP AND THINGS ABOUT THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND ABOUT THE
PRISON SYSTEM. WE CAN DO BETTER
MISSED WHAT WAY I COMMEND YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THEIR TO NEW DOING IT
SUCCESSFULLY. YOU'RE PUTTING
YOURSELF IN THOSE SHOES. AND
YOUR SHOWING THE APATHY. AND
YOUR GIVEN INDIVIDUALS SOME
HELP THAT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. THAT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I HAVE THEN WAS. AN
AUDIT LAST YEAR THAT SHOWED.
NOT A VERY BIG IMPACT ON
RECIDIVISM. BY OUR CUSTODY
PROGRAMS. NOW THAT SADLY
VALIDATES THE FUNCTIONS THAT I
HAD LIVING AS I DID FOR A WHOLE
LOT OF YEARS. ANYBODY PIPE UP
AND GIVE ME SOME THOUGHTS HOW
WE CAN DO BETTER ON THAT
KEEPING TRACK. MAYBE SECTOR
DIAZ I'LL I'LL TAKE A STAB AT
IT SO IN A RECIDIVISM IS A
NUMBER THAT CORRECTIONS
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN GAUGED ON
SOMEONE OF OUR REPORT CARD AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S AN
ACCURATE- YOU KNOW AN ACTOR
REPORTER AND I THINK I THINK MR
WILEY SPOKE TO ABOUT HOW
RECIDIVISM I LOOK AT RECIDIVISM
AS A- AS A CALIFORNIA NUMBER
NOT A CDC OUR NUMBER. IS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN OUR
SYSTEM A ONE DAY RELEASED BACK
TO COMMUNITIES I THINK THE
REPORT YOU SAW IS- RECIDIVISM
THE LAST NUMBER THAT WE PUT OUT
ITS RELATIVELY STAGNANT IT DID
MOVE VERY MUCH. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S IT ISN'T
WORKING BECAUSE ONE THERE IS A
SLIGHT SLIGHT DOWNTURN IS NOT A
FULL POINT BUT PERCENTAGE
POINTS DOWN ON CRIMES AGAINST
PERSONS. WHAT HAS KEPT THAT
RELATIVELY STAGNANT IS THE
PROPERTY CRIMES PIECE YEAH SO I
WAS I'M HAPPY TO- AND I
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING WE
RECEIVED AS WE'RE GOING TO BE
ADDRESS IN SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS. ROLE IN THAT PROGRAM
OUT- AND ADDRESSING THE SUCH AS
BUSA SOARING NEEDS OF INMATES
AND THEN I WAS VERY HAPPY HERE
YESTERDAY STATE OF THE STATE ON
HOW YOU'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND
THE MEDICARE SERVICES SO THERE
WILL WE WILL HAVE THAT
CONTINUITY OF CARE. OF THAT
SERVICE FROM PRISON INTO THE
COMMUNITIES- BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS ALL SUCH AS ABUSE
DISORDER NEEDS- WE'RE JUST SET
PEOPLE UP FOR A RETURN. AND A
THREE YEAR OLD COHORTS THAT WE
USE FOR COUNTY RECIDIVISM IS
ARREST CONVICTION AND RETURN TO
STATE PRISON. SO IT'S A PRETTY
HIGH BAR ON HOW WE CAN
RECIDIVISM BY THOSE THREE
POINTS SO- I'M I'M HOPEFUL I
WAS GLAD I'D LOVE TO SEE THAT-
YOU KNOW RECIDIVISM. GO DOWN
WHICH IS A GOOD MARKER BUT IT'S
LIKE I SAID EARLIER IT'S REALLY
A CALIFORNIA EFFORT AS WE BUILD
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND COMMUNICATING THE
SHERIFFS AND CHIEFS OF POLICE-
AND ALL TO EMPLOYERS OUT THERE
THAT INDIVIDUALS LIVE IN OUR
PRISONS. THE THEY ARE RECEIVING.
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED BOB SKILLS
LIKE BE YOU. IN THAT ALL IN IS
THAT. THIRD CHANCE SOME. AND
THE TO DO THAT. AND WE JUST
CAN'T COUNT THE- THINGS READ IN
THE PAPER OF THESE HORRIFIC
ACTS OF A READ SOMETIME. THAT
THAT'S ALL OF THEM THAT'S ALL
OF THEM. THAT'S A SMALLER
SMALLER PERCENTAGE AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW EVERY VIOLENT ACT
BY PEOPLE LIVE IN PRISON IS A-
THIS IS A IS A TRAGIC ACT AND
IT. REFLECTS POORLY ON THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE REALLY TRYING.
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND HOW
SOME PEOPLE PAY IN A BAD LIGHT
ON. THE MAJORITY PEOPLE WHO
JUST WANTED TO WRITE AND JUST
GET THE SECOND AND THIRD
CHANCE. SO I THINK THE ARM AND
FOR MY PART I THINK MORE
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITIES.
BUILDING BETTER PARTNERSHIPS
WITH- PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT. WE
DO HAVE A DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONS PRESENT EMPLOYMENT
WE HAVE A POINT PERSON WHO'S
OUT THERE BUILDING TIES WITH-
WITH UNIONS WITH- WORKFORCE
ARE GETTING PEOPLE JOBS WHEN
THEY GET OUT. SO I THINK. YOU
KNOW I HOPE I SHOULD LIVE BLOOD
ON YOUR OF THE- THANK YOU AND
GOOD KEEP MIND TO. IT BECAUSE I
THINK. STATURE SOME SKEWED A
BIT BECAUSE THE CORRECT IF YOU
AGO. RE DEFINED. TO LET THE
ABOUT THIS. THAT DOES INDEED
HAVE ITS IMPACT- SO THE SOME
SOME COLLECTION. THERE THE LAST
WEEK. JAILS I WHEN REAL PASS
THAT THE LAWSUIT WERE GOING TO
RIGHT TO THE CAR JAILS DID
PRESIDENT WAS A ONE WITHIN
MONTHS OF THE PASSAGE OF
REALIGNMENT. IN THE AND HOW.
ARE GOING TO BE FORCED THE- TO
PROVIDE A COMEDY. TO SELL
CAPITAL COST A GREAT MY REBUILT.
A SECURE FACE OF CONCERN A
NEVER EVER HAD TO BEFORE. THE
TICKET IS AT HAS THE- MORE
MAYBE ANALYST FOR THE SEVEN OF
YOU SOME KIND. OF HOW GOING TO
BE REALLY ABLE TO THOSE
COUNTIES WITH THIS. LET'S LET'S
GIVE ANALYST AT IT. A I THINK
YOU'RE- AWARE OF GOVERNOR DID
HAVE A MENTION OF A PROPOSAL
TANK THE STATE OVERSIGHT OF
JAIL IN THE- OVER OF THE
GOVERNORS BUT OVER IS. THE IT'S
FICTION WE COUNTS GOOD
OVERSIGHT IS JUST MEAN PUT MORE
ON THE COUNTY THAT'S NOT AN
ANSWER SO IT IS A WAS GET A
STATUS BECAUSE OF THAT WE ARE.
AT THIS ISSUE WORSE IN THE
PROCESS OF ANALYZING IT AND- WE
ARE THINKING HOLISTICALLY ABOUT
THE ISSUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TREES THAT WERE WHAT IS LOW
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD ON TO THAT IT
IS IT THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE STATE OVER THE
YEARS HAVE HAS AUTHORIZED I
BELIEVE OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
IN LEASE REVENUE FUNDS TO HELP
COUNTIES- STRUCTURE REDUCE
THEIR JAIL SYSTEMS IN ORDER TO
BE BETTER FOCUSED ON-
REHABILITATION AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND IN MANY
CASES A LOT OF THOSE PROJECTS
ARE STILL IN PROCESS EVEN
THOUGH THE AT THIS POINT THE
FUNDING HAS BEEN- AUTHORIZED
QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO. SO IT
WILL BE IMPORTANT TO ASSESS
WHAT THE IMPACT OF PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED FUNDING IS ON-
COUNTY NEEDS GOING FORWARD SO
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT THERE'S
A LOT NOT APPROPRIATED. BUT
STILL AROUND WHERE'S THE MONEY.
NOT THAT IT'S NOT A- IT'S GOING
OUT TO THE COUNTIES THE COUNTY
IS A JUST IN PROCESS OF CAN.
AND A LOT OF THE FACILITIES
HAVE YET TO BE ACTIVATED AND
MAKE A DENT INTO THE NEEDS-
KEEP IN MIND THAT'S A LONG TERM
INSPECTOR DSW HAVING ON THAT
POINT ABOUT THE JAILS I DO SIT
ON THE- BE A CC. THEN I KNOW
YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
OVERSIGHT BUT- WE JUST HAD A
MEETING WE DID DISCUSS THAT
OVERSIGHT BUT I THINK MORE
IMPORTANTLY. LIKE I TALKED
ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS I DO HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. AND I KNOW THEY DO
SEEK FROM TIME TO TIME LITTLE
INSIGHT ON THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE GONE THROUGH WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH A LOT. AND I'M
AVAILABLE AND OPEN FOR ANY YOU
KNOW ADVICE FOR INSIDE OR SOME
OF OUR SUCCESSES AND I THINK WE
LEARN MORE. FROM OUR FAILURE
SOMETIMES AND TELLING THINGS
TRIUMPH. ON THE- CHINA BUY THEM
THAT ROW THAT THE- SHOULD GO.
WELL THE MONEY HI MY OB. MR
ACTORS SIDE AND OF THE-
NECESSARY. BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE LEAD. AND. THE
DIMINISH. REGULARLY THEY DON'T
THINGS ON ALL. GO AND THE
STAYED. YOURSELF WE HAVE GOT TO
SEE. OUR SUPPORT. LOW
GOVERNMENT AS A- GO THROUGH
THIS OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS SO
I'M CERTAINLY. TO WITH YOU SIR.
BUT YOU HAVE SOME YES THEY YOU
WANTED TO A COUPLE OF NOTES THE
ON THE IMPACT ON JAIL I THINK
THE FIRST I WOULD POINT OUT IS
THAT IT. WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
THAT RELY ON PUT THE DISH
ASPECT. ON JAIL THESE MANY OF
THE LAWSUITS THAT THAT YOU'RE
AFTER PROVED RELY ON THERE ARE
LET THERE'S ON GO TO GET FOR
TAX NOW LOCAL. SO WHICH IS NOT
SUGGEST THAT THAT. ON A DIDN'T
PUT A DISH PRESSURE JUST WANTED
TO THAT AS CON I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT. DESERVES SUBSTANTIAL
OPERATE RISK HAVE PROVIDED TO
THE WALL TO FOR THE POP THAT
HAS BEEN. OVER THE YEARS AND OF
COURSE ALWAYS HAVE TO ABOUT
WHETHER THAT THE APPROACH
AMOUNT NOT BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT WE ARE-
ESTIMATING ABOUT A BILLION AND
A HALF DOLLARS- INTO THE TWENTY
ONE. BUT COUNTY. FOR DELAY WITH
THE- THAT WOULD REAL. AS PART
OF A ONE ON THE- HI INCLUDING.
THAT WILL GO TO LOCAL TO AND
THEN JUST ADD A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO WHAT MISTER SO TO BE. NOTED
THE FUN FOR. THE ACT INFER FOR
LOCAL WE APPROVED ABOUT ONE
SEVEN. DOLLARS IN AND BY THE
FLOOR TO. TAKE FACILITY AT THE
WALL LEVEL THEN AS MR SO. NOTE
MALES PROJECTS ARE IN PROCESS
SO THINK WE HAVE THE TO SEE AN-
WHAT. IMPACT ON BEHALF. THANK
YOU AND AGAIN A DEAL THANK YOU
YOUR DEBT. THAT IS A JOB HAVE
SIR. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH US INTO NIELSEN THING
FOR THE CALL FOR. SO I KNOW.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS WE
FOR OVER THE ROLLED BSE SEE IS
IN A PRE TO THE- BID PROCESS.
WHERE A SHERIFF'S APPLY FOR THE
DOLLARS TO FOR BRAND NEW CAN
AND AS I RECALL THAT WAS
LARGELY. PULSE TO REALIGN.
CENTER MORE LAW CARE TO TAKE
LEAVE BUT I HAVE A FINANCE OR
OR MAYBE. BY COMMITTEE STAFF HE
QUEST IS WHAT. REGARDING THE
OVER CAUGHT OF THE- AND THEY
GET. ON THE TIME FRAME.
COMPLETE IT. THE RECEIVER TO
COMPLETE WORK AND ALL HEALTH
RESPONSIBILITY TO SEE ARE SO
SOMEONE COULD THAT IN TO SET A
MORE IT IS I THAT WOULD BE A
PRE TO DO IT BUT IF WE GET TO
SENATOR LOTS OF THAT WILL BE A
FOR SENT TO SKINNER IS NOW
FOLLOWED DOCTOR PAY AND SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND A-
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS AS THE OF
THE THAT GO INTO THE ISSUES IN
GREAT DETAIL OF COURSE THERE'S
MANY THINGS I WOULD LIKE TO
DELVE INTO BUT WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY EVERY THURSDAY FOR
THE NEXT X. NUMBER OF WEEKS TO
DO THAT- AND JUST SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT. WE OF COURSE WILL
DEAL WITH ARE THINGS LIKE- AS
WAS RAISED BY ELIO DI THESE TWO
COURT CASES THE COLEMAN AND THE
PLOTTER HAVE IN THE COST IN AS
A WEIGHT BACK. AS OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE WHAT WE ARE WHAT
WE ARE BOTH CHARGED WITH AND- I
THINK LOOKING THROUGH THE LENS
OF IS JUST AS BUDGET OVERSIGHT.
HOW TO OF MAKES THAT WE ARE
USING OUR DOLLARS MOST
EFFECTIVELY AND DUE TO THE- IN
FACT IT'S GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
THE INCREASE. IN TERMS OF THIS
PRESSURE AND GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WHICH OBVIOUSLY
EVERYONE LEGISLATURE HAS LOTS
OF THINGS I'D LIKE TO USE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS FOR SO
WE'RE TRYING TO. MIND THE STORE
VERY CAREFULLY THAT WE'RE USING
A MOST EFFECTIVELY IN KEEPING
COSTS DOWN. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE ARE VERY COGNIZANT OF
CONDITIONS FOR THE STAFF AND
FOR OUR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. AND PUBLIC SAFETY
SO THOSE OF THE LANDS THAT WE
ARE LOOKING THROUGH ALL OF THE
TIME- AND SO WE WILL GET INTO
DETAIL IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
AROUND THE COLEMAN IN THE PLOT
TO CASES AND WHETHER AT WHAT
POINT WE WILL GET OUT OF THESE
RECEIVERS SHIPS- AND WE WILL
ALSO BE- WANTING THAT WASN'T TO
TALK ABOUT BUT HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE. IN ACTED
LAST YEAR WAS THIS. TO MOVE.
THE DJ. TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND RATHER THAN US
GETTING INTO IT TODAY ALL STEVE
IT FOR MYSELF EIGHTY SO WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ON RIGHT
NOW IN TERMS OF MY QUESTIONS
IS. THAT AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
BY MOST EVERYONE THAT THE WE IS
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HAVE STATED GOAL TO
REDUCE FACILITIES WE KNOW THAT
THE ONLY WAY TO ACHIEVE THAT.
IS WITH APPROPRIATE POPULATION
REDUCTIONS- AND SO RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON EITHER HOW DO WE
CHOOSE WHICH FACILITY OR THAT
SORT OF THING I'D RATHER SORT
OF TALK ABOUT WHAT. WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO TO. GET THOSE
POPULATION REDUCTIONS IN-
THIRTY SO FAR CORRECTLY
RIGHTFULLY TALKED NUMBERS. BUT
AS A MISTER FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE POINTED OUT OBVIOUSLY
THERE THIS IS MORE. THAN THAT.
THE NUMBERS REPRESENT PEOPLE.
AND WE BE DOING IN A WAY. THAT
INTEREST PUBLIC SAFE AND THAT.
HAS FAR FOLKS WERE RELEASED IN
KIND OF SIR THAT MISSED JOHNSON
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE AS WE RICH
PEOPLE TO WE WANT TO BE A TO
SUCCESS RANCH AND BE IN OUR CAN.
AND TO MISTER AGREED OF THAT SO
IS IT THAT WE DESIGNED THE
APPROPRIATE POPULATION
REDUCTIONS ACHIEVED THE
REDUCTIONS WITH THAT SAME TIME
THAT WE ACHIEVE THIS TYPE OF
REAL REHABILITATION. SO LET ADD
SPECIFIC THE QUESTION FIRST.
AND WITH MY FIRST QUESTION OUR
POPULATION REDUCTION IS AS
YOU'VE DESCRIBED WE HAVE A VERY
AGING POPULATION IN OUR PRISON.
AND THAT IS JUST LIKE
HEALTHCARE COSTS IN THE OVERALL
SOCIETY'S GENDER IN GENERAL
THERE'S A SMALL PERCENT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE BIGGEST COSTS OF THE
HEALTHCARE MANY OF THEM ARE
WITHIN THAT AGING POPULATION
WE'VE PASSED MANY STRATEGIES
RELATED TO THAT AS FAR AS I CAN
TELL FROM REPORTS I'VE SEEN
THEY'VE NOT REALLY AN IMPACTING
MUCH REDUCTION POPULATION SO
COULD WHOEVER ON THE PANELS-
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. I
WHICH OF THOSE ARE WORK ON WINE
IN WHAT OTHER STE. SHOULD WE
PERHAPS BE CONSIDERING. I CAN
GO AHEAD AND- GIVE AN ADDRESS
THAT. YOU REFERENCE I THINK ARE
THE ELDERLY POPULATION AND OUT-
AN AGING POPULATION AND IT
PEARL PROCESS FOR A INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE- GENERALLY CONSIDER IT
CONSIDER FOR REAL RELEASE IF
THEY SERVE MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS IN PRISON AND REACH
SIXTY YEARS OLD- AS YOU NOTED
THAT PROCESS HASN'T BEEN ANY
CITY HUGELY SIGNIFICANT IN
TERMS OF LARGE NUMBERS OF
POPULATION REDUCTIONS- THAT
COULD PERHAPS BE CHANGED IF THE
THRESHOLDS WERE. SIGNIFICANTLY
ALTERED BY FOR EXAMPLE AND
REDUCING NEED- TIME SERVE
REQUIREMENT BENEATH TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OR REDUCING THE AGE
REQUIREMENT BELOW SIXTY YEARS-
THERE'S A OTHER POPULATION
MANAGEMENT OPTIONS THAT THE
STATE HAS- WHICH I CAN GIVE YOU
SOME EXAMPLES OF- SO TO FURTHER
REDUCE THE OVERALL INMATE
POPULATION- AND- THERE ISN'T
THERE'S VARIOUS OPTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE THE STE AND THE STATE
COULD REQUIRE THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS TO RELEASE TO
INITIATE RELEASE CONSIDERATION
FOR NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS. UNDER
THE PROP FIFTIES. ACCESS TO
DAYS THAN NOW TO EXIT RELEASE
AT SOME WE FREE READ IT COULD
ALSO X. OUR TO MAKE COST PLACE.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW IN UNDER CC I
EXIT. CREDIT EARNING POLICIES
TO- SIMPLY BY CHANGING OF THEIR
HOUSING STATUS TO EARN CREDITS
AT A FASTER RATE PUT IN- IN
TURN- REDUCE THE INMATE
POPULATION- OR- A COULD THE
STATE COULD ENACT FURTHER
SENSING CHANGES THE ELDERLY PRO
PROCESS BEING ONE OF THEM BUT
YOU KNOW. MANY MANY OTHER
OPTIONS A CDC ARE ALSO HAS
SIGNIFICANT HAS CONTROL OVER IN
MAY CREDIT EARNING SO IT COULD
IT COULD CHANGE THOSE POLICIES
WHICH WOULD. IN A WAY THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE INMATE
POPULATION- OTHER POPULATION
MANAGEMENT OPTIONS- TO THE
EXTENT AND THE STATE WANTS TO.
REMOVE AND MAKE- REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INMATES HOUSED IN
STATE OPERATED STATE OWN
PRISONS THAT IS THE THIRTY FOUR
PERSONS THAT THE COURT ORDER.
UP IS TO- FOR EXAMPLE THAT IT
COULD CLOSE ONE OF THOSE
PRISONS FASTER THAN OTHERWISE-
THE STATE COULD INCREASE THE
CONSERVATION CAMP POPULATION
BIKE PAN NATO SUCH BY LAW
INMATES WITH MY FOR. DETAINER
AS INTO CAN AS WE READ IT CAN.
THAT IS ONE. OF RECOMMENDED
THIS COULD ALSO GET IN
EXPANDING FOR INMATES TO CAN
LIKE X. PAY COULD ALSO ALLOWING
EXPANDING ALLAH FOR PROGRAMS
LIKE THE ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM BY
ADMITTING FOR EXAMPLE INMATES
WITH MORE THAN TWELVE MONTHS
LEFT TO SERVE AND BY JUST TO
KIND OF DRAW THAT POINT HOME
THOSE THOSE ACTIONS WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY REDUCE THE OVERALL
AMOUNT MAY POPULATION BUT THEY
WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
INMATES REQUIRED THAT THE STATE
MUST HOUSE IN ITS- THIRTY FOR.
I STATE OWNED PRISON. IN ORDER
FOR ANYONE ELSE IN THE. I WOULD
ADD THE ON THE ELDER PAROLE SO
ELDERLY. TERRIBLE NAME. OF BUT
IT IS IT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT THE
MEASURES THAT WERE- ENACTED IN
ORDER TO DEAL WITH THE
OVERCROWDING SITUATION
RESPONSES TO THE THREE JUDGE
PANEL ONE OF THE EARLIER ONES
WAS OF STARTING TO RECOGNIZE
WHICH GAVE RISE TO THE SENATE
BILL TWO SIXTY INTO SIXTY ONE
BUT TO RECOGNIZE PEOPLE WHO
WERE YOUNG AT THE TIME OF THEIR
CRIMES AND GOT LONG SENTENCES
SHOULD GET SPECIALIZED
CONSIDERATION PROCESS AN
OPPORTUNE IN THE SHOW THAT
THEY'VE CHANGED IN CAN SAFELY
HOME. UP ONE OF THE BIG
CONCERNS I HAD WAS THAT. THAT
THE LANGUAGE AND THOSE BILLS
ALLOW THE BOARD TOO MUCH
DISCRETION FRANKLY. AND WHAT
WILD THERE'S A THERE'S GREAT
PROMISE THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO WERE SENTENCED UNDER AGE
EIGHTEEN THOUSANDS MORE UNDER
AGED TWENTY SIX WHICH IS THE
NEW STANDARD. WHO QUALIFY FOR.
FOR USE PAROLE HEARINGS- IN
PRACTICE. THEIR PROGRAM RATES
ARE WORSE. THEN EVERYBODY ELSE
WORST THE AVERAGE THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO BE DENIED PAROLE.
CLEARLY NOT THE WHAT WE
INTENDED WITH THAT RIGHT- IN
THIS IS A THIS IS ALSO WHY YOU
SEE THAT THE THERE HASN'T BEEN
A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN AMONG
THE IN IN THE AGING POPULATION
ELDERLY PAROLE PROCESS BECAUSE
OF THE PAROLE BOARD. STILL IS
RELYING ON FACTORS THAT DON'T
ALWAYS CORRELATE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY. THEY ARE REACTING TO-
VARIATIONS IN SOMEONE'S
ARTICULATION OF INSIGHT REMORSE
THAT DON'T ALWAYS MATCH WHAT
THE BOARD THINKS IT SHOULD LOOK
LIKE AND THEY'RE RELYING ON-
ANCIENT RULE VIOLATIONS OR EVEN
ALLEGATIONS ARE UNPROVEN WHICH
IS REALLY A REALLY HUGE ISSUE.
WHERE YOU HAVE BROKEN
MISSIONERS WHO ARE QUESTIONING
SOMEONE ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
APPEARS IN A CONFIDENTIAL
FOLDER TWENTY YEARS AGO. UP IN
OUR THEY WERE NO A PERSON'S
NEVER CHARGE WITH THE WAS HERE
TO REFER GUILTY. THE
COMMISSIONERS ARE INTERPRETING
THIS ONE LINE ALLEGATION AS A
STATEMENT OF FACT AND THEN WHEN
THE PERSON DENIES IT TODAY.
THEN YOU LACK CREDIBILITY LACK
INSIGHT- UNSUITABLE FOR PAROLE
THEY DENY THAT THIS IS A
PRACTICE THAT HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR MANY MANY YEARS IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY REALLY. BUT IT DOES HAVE
TO DO WITH THE HOW COMFORTABLE
COMMISSIONS ARE WITH THE PERSON
APPEAR BEFORE THEM HOW THEY
PRESENT ALL THOSE THINGS- SO AS
LONG AS THERE IS THAT LEVEL OF
DISCRETION. THAT CAN EASILY BE
ABUSED UNFORTUNATELY. THEN I'LL
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT. IN
OUTCOMES THROUGH THE
DISCRETIONARY PROPUESTAS WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY HAS BECOME. OF
THE MAIN WAY THAT WE PROVIDE
ACCESS FOR PEOPLE TO COME HOME
FROM PRISON AS IT IS WITH ALL
THE REFORMS LAST YEAR'S ABOUT
HALF THE PRISON POPULATION WILL
GO TO THE PAROLE BOARD. BUT THE
OUTCOMES ARE TERRIBLE FRANKLY
LAST YEAR THE REPORTED I THINK
NINETEEN AND A HALF PERCENT.
PROGRAM RATE WHICH IS ABOUT
WITH MAYBE A LITTLE LOWER THAN
WAS THE YEAR BEFORE THAT AND
I'M TOLD IT'S GOING TO BE A
LITTLE LOWER THIS YEAR- SO WE
NEED TO FIND WAYS TO SWITCH
SWITCH THOSE NUMBERS OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SO THE BEST
SUITED AND IN A MORE MORE ALSO
JOHNSON'S GET A CHANCE TO COME
ALL. YES WHAT. THAT CLEARLY
THIS YOU KNOW THE INTENT OF THE
QUESTIONS FOR THE ELDERLY
ELDERLY POPULATION WELL
ACTUALLY. YES THAT WAS ONE. M.
BUT GIVEN THAT WERE A KIND OF
EXPANDING THAT IT'S OKAY I MEAN
WHAT I'M MOST INTERESTED IN IS.
WE NEED POPULATION REDUCTION
BUT WE WANTED TO BE EFFECTIVE.
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY AND AS-
MISTER WATLEY'S POINTED OUT WE
HAVE. YOU KNOW PUT IN VARIETY
OF BOTH VOTERS AND LEGISLATURE
PUT IN A VARIETY OF. MEASURES
TO IN EFFECT IMPACT THAT. AND
SOME ARE WORKING SOME AREN'T
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT STRATEGIES DO
HAVE TO RECOMMEND TO US THAT
WOULD BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
STILL PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY ON
ON ON THE BOARD QUESTION ABOUT-
GRANTING OR THE NILES OR HOW
THE REVIEW OF WHAT THE REVIEWER
WHAT THEY CONSIDER- I KNOW THEY
HAVE EXPANDED AND I KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE THEY THEY HAVE CHANGED
ON HOW THEY LOOK AT THEM AND I
KNOW THIS IS REALLY A QUESTION
FOR THE COMMISSIONER BPH
MISSION. TRYING TO GET FROM
YOUR COME AT ALL BUT. I WILL
SAY THEY HAVE REALLY RE. AND IS
A DESIRE CHANGE. THAT THE YOU
KNOW THE BOARD IS LOOKING A END
OF. THAT ARE READY FOR RELEASE
IN THE DON'T POSE A- OR
UNREASONABLE WRIST. SAFETY ON
THEY DO GO OUT AND I THINK.
EVERYONE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE RATES. YOU KNOW HAVE
EXPANDED FROM THE YEARS PASSED
TO WERE. YOU KNOW THEY WERE
INTO THE HUNDREDS NOW FROM THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION THIS
ADMINISTRATION TOTALLY WENT TO
THE THOUSANDS. SO I THINK IT'S
MORE OF A QUESTION OF BPH AND I
KNOW THEY ARE RAMPING UP WITH
MORE STAFFING I KNOW THEY'RE
LOOKING AT NON VIOLENT. STAFF
ENOUGH FOR THE NOT VIOLENT
OFFENDER- BUT I THINK IT'S MORE
OF A QUESTION FOR. BPH ON THE
PAROLE PIECE- WHEN IT COMES TO
LOOKING AT CRAP EXPANDING AT
ITS HOUSING PLACEMENT IT'S A
GREAT MORE CREDITS. WE DO ASK
OURSELVES QUESTIONS QUITE A BIT
WE ARE SEVERAL YEARS IN. DC
FROM THE TO IT WAS. SIMPLY ONE
THING EVER CALL. OF A SET. IS I
TO BE MIND. THAT IT ANY
EXPANSION OF CREDITS TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON I HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING IT
FOR THE PURPOSES. OF
REHABILITATION NUMBER ONE.
HANDING OUT CREDIT JUST TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT'S GOOD FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY. BUT I. DO BELIEVE THAT
MEASURE NET WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT WHAT'S MORE
EFFECTIVE THAT NEEDS TO BE ON
GOING- THAT WE DO LOOK AT THESE
NUMBERS AND INTERNALLY WITHIN
CDC ARE I AM MASS WHAT. CAN WE
INCREASE THIS SECTION OF PEOPLE
THAT. THE PEOPLE. I'M ALL FOR
IT BUT I ALSO RECONCILE. IS
THERE A PROPER REHABILITATIVE
DOSAGE RECEIVED BY THE CIVIC.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT THEM OUT
LACKING NOR DO I WANT THEM UP A
PREPARED FOR RE ENTRY SIR. SO
FIELD FIFTY SEVEN CREDITS THAT
THEY'RE STILL IN MY MIND WE
STILL ARE. IN THE BUSINESS OF
SEEKING WHAT IS BEST. ARE CAL
POPULATION IS LOW OUR MINIMUM
SUPPORT FACILITIES ARE MORE
FULL BUT A CAP POPULATIONS AND
LOGOS WHAT WE DID FIND. IS
THAT- INMATES WOULD BE FIRST
THING IN THE MINIMUM SUPPORT
FACILITIES RATHER THAN GOING
OUT TO FIRE CAMP. BECAUSE THEY
SAY WE CAN LEARN THE SAME
CREDIT I DON'T HAVE TO WORK AS
HARD. THAT'S A MOTIVATION
ISSUE. SO MAYBE I DO NEED TO
DO. A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
PRESENTATION OF THAT GROUP
MAYBE- AMPLIFIER MAGNIFY SO FAR
POST RELEASE. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GETTING JOBS IN THE
FIREFIGHTERS SERVER. SHOW THAT
THERE IS JOB. FOR THEM THE- AND
WE HAVEN'T VENTURA OTHERS ARE
THERE. BUT NOW. I THINK. YOU
KNOW IT'S- BREAST EXPAND JUST
SICK OF NUMBERS. OF IT IT WE
NERVOUS TO DO THAT WITH.
SHOWING THAT- THAT THERE'S A
TRUE PUBLIC SAFETY CONNECTION
WITH THAT. THANK YOU TO A
QUESTIONS SO. THE OTHER FOR AND
ASK WE ARE. ARE BY SHERRY THE
ISSUE THE COW. NAME COUNTY IN
THIS WAS POINTED OUT WE ARE
ACTUALLY. AND HAVE BEEN FOR
YEARS ACTING SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO THE
COUNTIES BOTH FOR. A FACILITY
UPGRADES AND FOR- OPERATIONS.
AND THE IN SOME CASES THE
COUNTIES HAVE NOT YET SPENT THE
MONEY THAT THEY WERE GRANTED.
AND IN OTHER CASES YOU KNOW
HAVEN'T YET APPLY. BUT LET SAID
THAT ASIDE FOR A MINUTE. WHAT
BEEN BROUGHT UP THE- CAN BE AND
WE DON'T KNOW THAT DETAIL YET
BUT WE CAN WHEN WE HAVE OUR ME
WILL A CHART ON THIS THERE'S A
TO. BETWEEN THE OUR PROPORTION
OF POPULATION THAT INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES ARE SENDING TO STATE
PRISON IN OTHER WORDS THERE ARE
SOME OF OUR SMALLER COUNTIES
ARE SENDING A MUCH LARGER
PERCENT OF THEIR POPULATION TO
STATE PRISON. THEN IN THEN
REALIGNMENT EITHER BY HOW
THEY'RE CHARGING OR SO IN OTHER
WORDS NOT HOLDING THEM IN THEIR
COUNTY JAILS WHICH OF COURSE IS
A POPULATION PRESSURE FOR OUR
STATE PRISONS SO WHAT-
STRATEGIES MIGHT WE USE TO YOU
KNOW HELP A DISINCENTIVE VICE.
THE ALLOWING OF THE PRISON
POPULATION TO POTENTIALLY BE
TERM DETERMINED BY LOCAL
DECISIONS. CHOOSE A WORD WITH
AND OFF ARM ARE OFFICE RECENT
RELEASED A REPORT AND- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROBATION PROPOSALS.
THAT REPRESENTS THE SORT OF-
SOME STRATEGIES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS EMPLOYING TO
TRY TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH A HISTORY OF
MISDEMEANOR CONVICTION. FROM
COMING TO PRISON AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE THINK WOULD BE
A- STRONG ALTERNATIVE TO THE
ONES PRESENTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. IS ADJUSTING V.
SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT FORMULA TO
REWARD COUNTIES FOR PREVENTING
MISDEMEANOR PROBATIONERS FROM
COMING TO PRISON SO IS YOUR
CALL SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT IT
SHARES A PORTION OF THE STATE
SAVINGS THAT'S CREATED WHEN
COUNTIES REDUCE THE RATE AT
WHICH FALLON'S ON. EIGHTY
SUPERVISION ARE SO PRISON AND
SO FROM HARPER. ONE OPTION THAT
THE STATE SHOULD CONSIDER IS
MODIFYING THAT FOR A FORMULA TO
REWARD THEM FOR REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF- FOLKS ON MISDEMEANOR
PROBATION THAT COME TO PRISON
SO REALLY FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
TRAINING INCENTIVES RIGHT FOR
THE COUNTIES IS A- CRITICAL
STEP TOWARDS ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- ISSUES. THANK I'M BY AT MY
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL GIVE INTO
THIS IN MAYBE THERE'S A ELSE
THE PAN ONCE TO ON THE GUY
WANTS TO ASK BUT- GIVEN THAT
HEALTH CARE COSTS ARE ONE.
RISING PORSCHE OF THE CDC
BUDGET. ONE QUESTION OF OUR-
CUSTINE TONY OF ME NOW I'M JUST.
YOUR IT'S SOMETHING WE'LL GET
INTO DETAIL WHETHER WE'RE BEING
ABLE. TO ACCESS CAL FOR THOSE
POPULATIONS WE CAN'T ACCESS
MEDI CAL. WHEN A PERSON IS
INCARCERATED IN THE STATE
FACILITY BUT- AND- WE OBVIOUSLY
KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR- OF THOSE
FOLKS. IF THEY WERE UNDER MEDI
CAL TREATMENT IT WOULD REDUCE
OUR COSTS A GREAT DEAL BUT SO
MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE WANTS TO GET
INTO THAT I JUST RAISING IT
BECAUSE IT IS A GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING. ISSUE BUT MY FINAL
QUESTION IS. SO WE'VE A LOT
ABOUT POPULATION REDUCTION
WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT- HOW
PARTY FOR PURPOSE OF POPULATION.
SO BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
EVENTUALLY ALMOST EVERYBODY IN
PRISON NOT ALL BUT ALMOST IS
GOING TO GO HOME. AND SO. WE IN
IN REDUCING THE POPULATION BUT
ALSO PREPARING PEOPLE TO GO
HOME WE WANT TO DO THE BEST JOB
POSSIBLE WE WANT GOOD PUBLIC
SAFETY. IT SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
REALLY HAVE ONE. TO HAVE SOME
OF OUR PANELISTS FROM LAST
PANEL SHEER BUT ANYONE. CAN IS
WHAT. WHAT ARE WHAT WOULD BE
THE KEY ADVICE. IN A MISTER
JOHNSON IF YOU HAVE A THAT
WOULD BE GREAT IN TERMS OF OUR
ABILITY TO SUCCESSFULLY HELP
PEOPLE REENTER FROM PRISON. AND
BEFORE YOU ANSWER. WE HEARD
YESTERDAY IN THE STATE OF THE
STATE THE GOVERNOR TALK ABOUT
ARE HOMELESS POPULATION IN OUR
FOLKS THAT ARE HOUSING AND
SECURE. AND NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING IN MORE DETAIL AT THE
POINT OF COUNT WE ARE SEEING
THAT A LARGE PERCENT ARE PEOPLE
WITH RECORDS PEOPLE THAT WERE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED. AND IN
THE REPORT THAT WE HAVE FROM
THE BUDGET STAFF THE DETAIL.
ALL HOW CALIFORNIA. HAS SOME OF
THE HARDEST HIT SOME OF THE
MOST ELABORATE EITHER LICENSING
PROCEDURES ARE COSTS FOR
LICENSE HERE ALL THESE THINGS
AROUND EMPLOYMENT. THAT BEYOND
THE FACT THAT WE LIMIT ALL
KINDS OF PEOPLE WITH A FORMER
PHONY CONVICTION FROM ALL THESE
CATEGORIES EMPLOYMENT WE ALSO
MAKE THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY FOR
EMPLOYMENT. ARE REALLY HIGH
AND- SO ANYWAY THAT THAT'S A
KIND OF COMPLICATED BUT- WHAT.
WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING TO.
BETTER PREPARE AND EIGHT WHAT
ADVICE DO YOU HAVE FOR US. FOR
ME- WAS SAID LIKE DEFENDER
MENTOR PROGRAM NAY WITH GUYS BE
LIKE WORK IN TRYING TO GET A
CERT WHAT INCARCERATED- ONE
THING I WANTED. TO WOULD USE AN
EARLY IS COST EFFECTIVE PEOPLE
WE HAVE THE BILL AT TO TAKE
MEDICATION I'M JUST TELLING YOU
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. I
BECAME A VEGAN TO TWO YEARS
AGO- WITH A DIABETIC AND HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE I HAD THOSE WHO
HAD OPENED JUST ABOUT WE
INSTEAD OF THE- MARK THE
RIDER'S. TAKE MEDICATION BUT
THE WRITERS ANYTHING BECAUSE
WAITED HE DO LOW EXERCISE AND I
DRINK PLENTY OF WATER YOU KNOW
TO BE COST EFFECTIVE WE STORE
TO YOU PEOPLE ARE HEALTHY
BEFORE YOU GET OUT STUFF LIKE
THAT BECAUSE- OF THEM WHEN I
FIRST CAME HOME I WENT TO HAS
GET UP NAY THE DON'T NEED. IT
AND I WAS LIKE BECAUSE HEART
ATTACK IN I'M HAD ANOTHER
HEARTED BECAUSE WITH THE IS
LIKE THAT FOR OF MY LIFE WE
NEED EACH ALIVE AND WITH TO
BECAUSE MAKE THIS HELP THE MAKE
BETTER TO. LIKE THAT WOULD. SET
UP A PRO. REALLY WANT TO WORK
IT. NO IS NO HUNDRED. DANGER
GOING TO WORK IN. GOT IT IN IN
THIS. PEOPLE TOLD ME TWENTY YOU
AGO MORE SEVERE BETWEEN YEARS
AGO AND AM. LAST YEAR REMEMBER.
HOST OF TO ONCE. IF WE GET
PEOPLE TO LIKE TO SOME KIND FOR
SO DIFFERENT WAY BELIEVE.
CHANGES IN THE CITY PEOPLE DID
KNOW WHAT TO YOUR ME COME BACK
IN A SEE I A LITTLE OUT HE-
KURT. BECAUSE ENCOURAGE WE'RE
GO A LONG WAY MISTER YOU SEE
LIKE I WAS DEEP. TWO EIGHT.
FOUR THIRTY TWO YEARS NOW
PEOPLE COME OWES A MISTER. YOU
KNOW IN. MAKES WHEN YOU GET.
WHEN YOU START. YOURSELF OTHER
P. RISK YOU BECAUSE OF PEOPLE
RESPECT THE SET UP THEY'VE BEEN
BE DEBT BEFORE YOU CAME TO
PRISON. THE REAL THE WOUNDED
DUCK BE WHEN WE GOT. TO PUT UP
A MASSIVE STAY STRONG OF LATE
IT'S A SHE'S DEFACING. OF BEING
DID YOU DURING YOUR LIFE CHECK
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW AS WOODS FOR
TWO OF THE- BELIEVE IN COLOGNE
PEOPLE. FOR LEAVE A MESSAGE. TO
WE TWENTY IS GO YOU BE WHEN A
SUIT. ABOUT TODAY AND I CAN SEE
IF WE HEREI AM TODAY. IT'S SO
IF WE WILL. IN CURSE. TO
BECAUSE BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO DIS NIGHT ONE. REMAINING BE
MP. IN EVERY COULD LOOK AT. FOR
ME I'LL FOR TO GO PEOPLE TODAY.
YOU KNOW AND WAS YOU KNOW YOU
SEE. WE'RE TO GO A LONG WAY FOR
DATING. YOU KNOW WE PEOPLE
STILL HEARD. WITH CAN STILL
OCCUR BE AND BILLY IN THE AND
IN A- IN THE- OF NEW TO GO TO
THE NECK PERSON. THEN YOU KNOW.
I BE. MAKE TWENTY TWO YEARS A I
WOULDN'T WANT ME TO LIVE NEXT
TO US. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
BUT I. WOULD TODAY I I'M- YOU
KNOW. YOU KNOW. I'M JUST SAYING
BECAUSE BELIEVE YOU MAKE. ME
AND MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO
BE SENATOR BECAUSE OF NOT
PERSON IS EVERY. IS FOR. WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN SOME LIKE.
YOU KNOW FROM WHICH SAID TODAY
IN HIS CARE ON OUT HIS ROOM IN
SOME OTHER GOING TO SOMETHING
TO BE A- MAY IT POSSIBLE. IN
HIS GO INNER TUBE. YOU KNOW OUR-
APPRECIATE. BUT AS OF MAR FOR
AND YOU KNOW OCCURRED GOING TO
PRESENT IT TO DO ALL. PRO IN
THIS WHERE SAID. WHEN YOU HAVE
CREDIBLE WILL MODELS TO PRISON.
IF PEOPLE GOING TO FOR THE
RIGHT THING. GIVEN THE ARE THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE. P. NAY BY
ENDED A NEW NAY. THE BECAUSE
THEY BEGIN. AT HOLD. IT IS WITH
HIS MOM LIKE A SAID HOPE TO
KEEP. FAT ME WE GET BE. CHANGE
BECAUSE- IN THIS WICKER. CATCH
THAT AS WELL KNOWN THANK YOU
WAS I THINK HAVE AN CAPACITY IN
pQUESTION WE TO PEOPLE HOME IF
RELEASE PEOPLE IT THERE MAY
WILL. MENTALLY ILL ELDERLY WHY
POPULAR WASN'T UP THAT INCREASE
IN IN CAR WHEN AND THE WIND AND
CHILDREN TO WOMEN SO I THINK
THE AND DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS
TO BE HAD AS WELL BUT THE
COMMUNITY PASS CITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE ABLE TO
COORDINATE THOSE SERVICES WHEN
TIME THE OFFENDER MENTOR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM IS GREAT
WE HIRE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE FORMALLY INCARCERATED THAT
ARE NOW CERTIFIED TO PROVIDE
THOSE TREATMENTS SERVICES IN
THE COMMUNITY TO EXPAND IN ON
MANSION WITH HOUSING BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION WE ADDRESS THE
HOUSING ISSUE BY ALLOWING MEN
AND WOMEN THAT ARE FALLING. DOT
BUILD UP MISS OF HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITYSO WE'RE OF INTO A AT
ONE SOMETHING MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE LIKE FOR PER FOR. MEN
AND WOMEN LIKE OZIL TO COME
HOME TO FOR THE MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PLAYED IN A COUNTY PARTNER
LEVERAGE CHARACTERISES AND
OTHER SERVER FOR IN TO GET INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR NATO YOU
LOVE BECAUSE THEY ARE ALWAYS
GONNA BE. AND BECAUSE THEY'RE
GONNA BE COUNTY. OR IN THE US
LONG OUT THEIR OWN. THIRTY TO
BE CLEVER. I WOULD AT THE-
UNTIL WE- PRETTY DRASTICALLY TO
OUR PER SYSTEM. THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A BETTER SUPPORT
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
DOING A LOT OF THE WORK- AND
DOING KIND OF THE DEEPER WORK
FOR PEOPLE IN PRISON WE NEEDTO
MAKE SURE THERE'S CONTINUITY OF
CARE. SO THAT THE WORK DOING
INSIDE THEY GET TO CONTINUE
WHEN FOLKS COME INTO THE
COMMUNITY- BECAUSE THAT
TRANSITION HOME. IS ONE THAT
TAKES AN EMOTIONAL TOLL
REQUIRES A LOT OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT AND THERE'S THIS ALMOST
NONE OF THAT CERTAINLY NINE
COMING FROM THE DIVISION OF
ADULT ROLE OPERATIONS- THERE'S
NOT A COUNSELOR SOMEONE CAN GO
TO TALK TO ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY BROKE DOWN CRYING A LITTLE
TRAFFIC NOT SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTAND THAT. CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT- BUT THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE STARTED BUILDING
THESE RELATIONSHIPS WITH PEOPLE
WATER INSIDE- TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE SUPPORTED AND CONTINUE
THAT WORK. ON THE OUTSIDE AGAIN
THIS IS. GREEN BAY'S
ORGANIZATION SHOULDN'T BE BE
FOR EVER SOLUTION. BUT AS I
SAID UNTIL THE PRISON
POPULATION AND COMMUNITY AND
SYSTEM IS DRAMATICALLY
TRANSFORMED. WE PLAY A PRETTY
VITAL ROLE- AND HELPING PEOPLE
MAKE THAT TRANSITION. SO A
COUPLE YEARS AGO OUR OFFICE
RELEASED A PORT ON THE LOOKING
AT WAYS THE STATE COULD IMPROVE
IN PRISON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS I THINK THIS WILL BOTH
BOTH TOUCH ON YOUR QUESTION IN
SOME OF YOUR EARLIER QUESTIONS
ARE SENATOR NIELSEN- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE THINK IS REALLY
CRITICAL IS. THAT WE THAT WE
REQUIRE THAT PROGRAMS BE
EVIDENCE BASED NATURALLY A TWO
STEP PROCESS FIRST AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CDC ARE HAS AN
ODD DEFINITELY IMPROVED IN
RECENT YEARS TO CHOOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE
ELSEWHERE. BUT THE SECOND AND
GOAL STEP IN THAT PROCESS IS
ENSURING THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE CHOOSE OUR ACTUALLY BE
OPERATED IN A WAY THAT SIMILAR
TO THE WAY THEY WERE. AMENDED
OUT WHERE THIS CALLED A
FIDELITY ASSESS AND CITIES HERE
IS IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO
BEGAN. THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING FIDELITY
ASSESSMENTS. WE ALSO THINK
THOUGH THAT BEYOND THAT IT'S
CALLED ACTUALLY LOOK AT IN THE
WAY THAT THE ORDER DID WITH
RESPECT TO SOME CDC OUR
PROGRAMS. THE ACTUAL
STATISTICAL FACT ON INMATES
THAT ARE IN THE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE JUST BECAUSE A PROGRAM
WORK SOMEWHERE ELSE WE NEED THE
ISSUE BUT IT ALSO IN HERE SO
THAT FITS NOT INTO A LOOK AT
HER FIGURE HOW. RAM COULD BE MY
THEY'RE NOT OTHER PROGRAM WOULD
BE MORE OF. THE THING. IS
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT PROGRAMS
HIGHER HIGH INMATES THE OF WAY
TO REHABILITATED PROGRAM AND
WILL CDC OURS RIGHT. ARE PUT IN
PLACE TO TRY TO IN THIS IN MANY
THE BREAKS THE AND SO WE THINK
VARIOUS WAY THAT THIS COULD AND
A ENSURING HIRING HIGH NEED I
AT GET IN PRO IN OUR FOR IT WE
ALSO THING THAT IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THE STATE TAKE A LOOK AT
ITS INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE IT
ACTUALLY HAS THE CAPACITY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF HIGH RISK
HIGH NEED INMATES RIGHT NOW
IT'S NOT CLEAR IF WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE SPACE AVAILABLE TO
MEET EVERYONE'S NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN IN THE PROCESS OF
ADDING ABOUT EITHER AS A-
ASSIST. ATTIC ASSESSED WHAT. BE
B. AND OF CLASSROOMS. AND
TREATMENTS BY NOW. TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS OLD NEEDS THAT GO ON
MATT AND THEN FOR. WE ALSO
THINK THAT THE STATE COULD
IMPROVE BY AND- IMPLEMENTING-
PERFORMANCE MEASURES TO SORT OF
CONDUCT REGULAR OVERSIGHT OVER
PROGRAMS A LOT OF THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS EVALUATIONS CAN
TAKE YEARS TO DO AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO. SORT OF MAINTAIN
CONSTANT OVERSIGHT OVER THE
PROGRAMS AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MEMBERS HAVE
A COPY OF THIS REPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE CAN MOVE ON TO.
DOCTOR PAN I THINK WHO LIVE
THAT WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT MEDI CAL BEING OUT TAPPED
INTO- CENTER SKINNER SO I'M
SURE HE'S GOING TO TAKE US
THERE FOLLOWING DOCTOR PANT
WILL BE SENATOR BAIL DOCTOR
PAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AS
CHAIR AND- A NOTE THAT-
STRICTLY RAISED AND- QUESTIONS
ABOUT- WHAT'S TRADING OR
INCREASED COSTS- HEALTHCARE
CAME- WAS SPECIFICALLY
REFERENCES THE FIRST ITEM. SO
IT IS SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS- MORE BROADLY IS A WHAT KIND
OF PROPOSALS AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE DIGGING INTO
MATTERS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
SINCE I CHAIRED THE MEDI CAL
SIDE OF THINGS- WHAT KIND OF
THINGS WILL BE LOOKING AT TO
TRY TO BEND THE CURVE ON
SPENDING ON THE- HEALTH. CARE
THAT I KNOW THAT SOME OF ITS
HUNDRED RECEIVERSHIP- AND
THAT'S YEAH. BUT I GUESS SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS WOULD BE ONE
IS THAT-IF THERE'S A WAY TO
YOU CAN'T HAVE THEM ON MEDI CAL
WHEN THEY'RE INCARCERATED BUT-
IT'S OUR SPEAKS TO OKAY WELL
WHAT ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT
TWENTY YOU DO NOT HAVE THE
MCCARTY STRAIGHT BUTTON SO THE
FACILITY WHERE YOU CAN GET CARE
RIGHT- POTENTIALLY OR- I GUESS
THE OTHER THING IS THAT GIVEN.
THE CURRENT DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
POPULATION I MEAN YOU KNOW WHAT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE AT LEAST
FOR RIGHT NOW AND PROBABLY THE
PEOPLE COMING IN OR NOT THAT
THE OLDER AND AS PRIDE THE
YOUNGER AND- A WHAT IS
PROJECTION. ON THE CURVE ON OF
WHERE THE HEALTHCARE COSTS ARE
GOING TO GO- GIVEN WHAT YOU
KNOW NOW SO DO WE KNOW WHAT
THAT CURVE LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS
OF. WHEN WE START THINKING
ABOUT HOW YEARS. AND THEN
FINALLY. IT WITH THE ONE GOALS
IS TO CLOSE A STATE PRISON OR-
AND- AND FIVE YEARS AND- WE'RE
ALSO TRYING TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF YOU KNOW ALSO. THE
FACILITIES WERE CONTRACTING OUT
SO FORTH- BUT- IS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THAT LIKE. YES IS
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY ALSO. NON
LINEAR CELL RIGHT SO I GUESS
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS IN THE
SAME WAY WE TALK ABOUT WELL YOU
KNOW ACTUALLY. EVEN THOUGH OUR
PRISONER. RATES GOING DOWN- YOU
KNOW THE COST IS INDUSTRY GOING
DOWN SOME BECAUSE OF
PROGRAMMING BUT SOME OF THIS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN INFRASTRUCTURES UNTIL
YOU ACTUALLY CLOSE A FACILITY.
YOU WON'T SEE A SAVINGS. FROM
THAT BECAUSE OF SPECIALLY HAS
MEETING A CERTAIN AMOUNT. DOES
THAT ALSO APPLY TO THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SIDE OF
THINGS AS WELL SO WHAT'S THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. COSTS IN
TERMS OF. HEALTH CARE FOR
PRISONERS. AND NUMBER PRISONERS
IS IT. IS IT IS IT. IS IT A
LINEAR RELATIONSHIP ARE IS IT
NOT AND IT'S ACTUALLY WE CLOSE
OF SILLY WILL. BE ON THE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO. NINE DOCTORS
AND NURSES. WHO HAVE TO GO OUT
SYSTEM THE PENNY ON. THE AND
ARE YOU TO HAVE THE ANY ON
LOCATION OF SILLY. YOU MAY BE
ABLE TO AT. PEOPLE WHO IS A
RECRUIT FOR. HIM AS MUCH OR
WHATEVER ELSE I DON'T IT. SO I
HAVE PEOPLE IN THE- WELL.
EXACTLY SO YES THERE'S I'D SO
WITH THERE A WAY TO GET. ON TO
YOU KNOW OUR OF THIS. PRESENTS
THE MEDIC WHAT THE LOOKING AT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS WHAT'S THE- ON
HEALTH CARE AND- WHAT IT OPERA.
AND IS REALLY BETWEEN PRISONERS.
OBVIOUSLY JUSTIN FOR ASIAN SOME
OTHER THINGS RELATE HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND ARE SPENDING ON
HEALTH CARE WITHIN THE PRISON
SYSTEM. SO I COULD TAKE A- STAB
AT. UNPACKING SOME OF THAT
THERE'S A THERE'S A COME A FEW
POINTS THERE SO- LET ME JUST
START WITH- ADD YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT THAT. THE INCREASING COST
HER FOR HEALTH CARE- YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT IS A
GROWING AREA OF EXPENDITURE FOR
US- AND IT IS ONE IN WHICH- WE
DO HAVE- AS AN ADMINISTRATION
LIMITED CONTROL BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL RECEIVERSHIP OVER-
PRISON MEDICAL CARE- I THINK
WHAT'S- REALLY UNDERLYING SOME
OF THESE INCREASES IS THE- THE
AGING POPULATION THAT WE HAVE-
AND- IN THIS KIND OF GETS TO
CENTER SKINNER'S QUESTION FROM.
EARLIER AS WELL- THE ELSE IN
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SO HERE
THE ANSWER NOW. SURE IN I THINK.
THE PERSON POP IS AGING IS IN
PART BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW THE
UPTAKE THAT THAT WE HAD IN
SENTENCE LANES GOING BACK
DECADES REALLY AND TO THE IN
THE EIGHTIES AND NINETIES WHEN
WE STARTED- SORT TOUGHER ON
TOUGH ON CRIME POLICIES LIKE
THREE STRIKES LAW I THINK WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW IS REALLY THE
TAIL END OF THAT- AND BECAUSE
IT TOOK US A DECADE TO GET INTO
THE SITUATION I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY SOLUTIONS TO GET OUT.
OVER NIGHT UNFORTUNATELY- SO I
THINK- THE AS AS WAS NOTED
EARLIER BY SOME OF THE
PANELISTS I THINK THE DECISIONS
AROUND PAROLE AND MAKING SURE
THAT- GIVING PEOPLE ADEQUATE
CONSIDERATION FOR PAROLE- WILL
HELP OVER TIME TO REDUCE- SOME
OF THE AGING IN THE PRISON
POPULATION AND HAVING FOLKS GO
OUT THE BACK DOOR. I'M YOUR
CALL ABOUT UTILIZING CAL SO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ACTUALLY- DONE I
THINK A VERY GOOD JOB OF
UTILIZING MEDI CAL FOR
OUTPATIENT SERVICES SO WHEN WE
SEND AN INMATE. OUT TO A
HOSPITAL FOR- INPATIENT CARE
LASTING TWENTY FOUR HOURS OR
MORE. WE CAN CLAIM MEDI CAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THAT
TREATMENT BECAUSE IN THAT CASE
THEY ARE NOT CONSIDERED AN
INMATE ANY LONGER BECAUSE
THEY'RE OFF OF THE PRISON
GROUNDS- THERE ARE LIMITATIONS
TO THAT OF COURSE- YOU KNOW I
THINK. FOR OUTPATIENT SERVICES
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO CLAIM
REIMBURSEMENT UNDER MEDICO- WE
HAVE LOOKED AT- USING MEDI CAL
FOR OUR- INMATES THAT WERE
HOLDING AND THE- REENTRY
FACILITIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHICH ARE SORT OF OUR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
FACILITIES- UNFORTUNATELY THE
DETERMINATION FROM- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- WAS THAT THE
INMATES. WERE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL BECAUSE- I THINK THAT
THE KEY CRITERIA THAT LOOK AT
THIS THE FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT-
AND BECAUSE OF THE- SECURITY-
CONCERNS AROUND THOSE
FACILITIES THAT THOSE. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE STILL UNDER THE
CUSTODY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND WE HAVE TO-
ENSURE THE COMMUNITY BUT THERE
ARE. IN UPSET FROM THE SOME
RISK IS ABOUT FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT AND SO. WE NEED TO
BALANCE THAT WITH THINK ABOUT
THE CAR SAVINGS OF. WHILE AND
THEN. WE'RE QUESTION THIS WILL
BE A THIRTY THE HEALTH KERR
ACOSTA CURVE ON. ALLUDED TO THE
THAT NO IT IS IT IS NOW LINEAR
SO AS WE CALL THE STATE PRISON
IT'S NOT GOING TO RELATE TO A
YOU KNOW PER. DECLINE IN HEALTH
CARE. NAKED GETS BY TO WHO ARE
THE WHO ARE DRIVING THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS IT'S THE AGING
FOLKS IN AND IT'S SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE SEE IN THE COMMUNITY IN
TERMS OF. A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
OUR AND IT'S A REALLY DEPRIVING
THE MAJORITY OF THE COST AND SO
UNTIL WE KIND OF GET AT THAT
ISSUE- THE IT'S UNLIKELY THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY BEND THE COST
CURVE. AND JUST REACH- ANY OF
THESE PRISONERS SOLD
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDING NURSING
HOME CARE FOR THEM WITHIN THE
PRISON. I IT DOES. OF A CAR ON
K. A IN ON THE CAL HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IN STOCKTON WE HAVE-
ESSENTIALLY SKILLED NURSING
CARE LEVEL- BEDS THERE SO- IN
ESSENCE YES I THINK THERE ARE
SOME SOME NUMBER OF BEDS THAT
THAT'S THE CASE. WE ALSO HAVE
HOSPICE BEDS THAT. CALIFORNIA
MEN'S FACILITY VACAVILLE- OF
SORRY I KNOW YOU TALKED TO BE
IN THAT. YEAH I THINK FOR THE
RECORD WE FACTOR TALKING THE
MICROPHONE BUT- SORRY. I WILL
BE OFFENDED THAT YOUR TALK TO
MICHAEL A LITTLE. BEYOND THAT
CENTER PAN IS A- THE PART AT
WITH IT HEALTH CARE SO. AND
THERE'S OFF WE HAVE ELIMINATED-
THE REQUIREMENT OF COPAYS FOR
INMATES SO IT DOES NOT
DISCOURAGE INMATES SEEKING
ACCESS TO OUR- AND I ALSO NEED
TO SAY JUST FROM AN OPERATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE THE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. IS MORE OF AN
OPERATIONAL DECISION NOW THAT
WE HAVE MADE THAT AMENDED
MANDATE AND THAT IS PRIORITY
NUMBER ONE I KNOW SAFETY
SECURITIES. IN A PARAMOUNT BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH CARE
AND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
APPOINTMENTS- THE DESTRUCTION
OF THAT- WE HAVE DRASTICALLY
MINIMIZE WERE ALMOST ELIMINATED
BECAUSE THAT IS A PRIORITY- AND
ONE WOULD THINK THAT YOU KNOW
IF SOMETHING HAPPENS ON A
PRISON YARD. EVERYTHING IS SHUT
DOWN AND CLEAN HEALTHCARE
THAT'S NOT THE CASE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE HAVE TO GET THESE IMAGE
TO THEIR HEALTHCARE SERVICES-
TO A MISTER JOHNSON'S POINT AND
IT'S- IT'S REALLY BASIC- WHAT
WE FEED IN MAKES. HOW FRIEDMAN.
THE LEVEL OF THE SEE. WE HAVE
IMPROVE AND WE ARE SERVING A
HARD HEALTHY. IT IS NOT THE
MOST POPULAR. AT THE END
POPULAR. BUT I WE DID OUR
TRYING TO MOVE AWAY FOR OUR
BEHIND GREAT. AND YOU KNOW MANY
OF SUITES WE USED PROVIDE DO
PROVIDE SWEETS PASSED OUT AT
THE WE READ. THAT IT'S THIS A
DIRECT CALL. JIM THEY EAT. AND
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE
CHALLENGE POINT IS- WE ARE
ESTABLISHED SEEN THE HEART
HEALTHY CANTEEN ITEMS WHICH IS.
INMATES ON THEIR OWN CAN GO BY.
MISS NO DIFFERENT TO ME WHEN I
GO I HAVE TO GO WITH MY WIFE SO
SHE COULD MAKE MY SNACKS. BY
WHEN IT'LL BE A DIFFERENT SET
OF SNACKS. BATES ARE ALSO THE
SAME WE TO PROVIDE. LOW SODIUM
HOW TO PROVIDE A HEART HEALTHY
OPTION FOR THEM. A WE ARE
KEEPING AN EYE ON THAT WE
WITHIN THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS ON A RECENT TRIP
TO NORWAY. THAT WAS A CONCEPT
OVER THERE THAT- ALL HEART
HEALTHY CANTEEN ITEMS ARE SOLD
TO THE INMATES AT COST WITH
EVERY PURCHASE THEM AND THEN.
ANY ON HEART HEALTHY OR ANY ON
HEALTHY ITEM THERE IS A MARK UP
ON THOSE- WE ARE. CONSIDERING
THAT THIS MORE FOR THE DIRECTOR
OF ANOTHER ADULT OPERATIONS BUT
THAT'S AN OPTION- I KNOW IT
WILL GOAL IT MY NUMBER. THE
MOST POPULAR THING BUT WE HAVE
TO TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT. AND
THEN LASTLY WE- IMPLEMENTED.
SOME YEARS AGO- IN AN EFFORT TO
REDUCE OUR STDS AND
INSTITUTIONS WE DID- WE DID
IMPLEMENT A CONDOM- PROGRAM
INSTEAD OF INSTITUTIONS RIGHT.
SELECT A JUST JUST ON A BIT AND
OF YOUR- OF HOW TO REDUCE
MISTER. IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
APARTMENT DOES DRAW DOWN SOME
MEDI CAL HOWEVER WE'VE BEEN
MONITORING THE RATE AT WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT IS I'M TRYING
DOWN MEDICAL AND IT DOESN'T
SEEM TO LINE UP IN THE WAY WE
WOULD HOPE. WITH THE LEVEL OF-
INPATIENT SERVICES THAT ARE
DELIVERED IN THE COMMUNITY WE
HAVE NOT ARRIVED AT-
IDENTIFICATION OF WHAT THE
BARRIERS ARE TO INCREASING IT
OR INDEED IF IT COULD BE
INCREASED SO RIGHT NOW. THE ON
ADMINISTRATION IS REQUESTING-
SOME FUNDING TO SUPPORT
CONTRACT MEDICAL SERVICES WHICH
INCLUDE THESE TYPE OF SERVICES.
AND SO WE'RE WITHHOLDING
RECOMMENDATION ON THAT- WELL WE
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO TRY
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY CAN DO
TO INCREASE THAT AMOUNT OR IF
THERE ARE BARRIERS THAT CAN BE
REMOVED TO TRY TO INCREASE THAT
AMOUNT. IN TERMS OF- YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT WHERE WILL THE
COSCO- GIVEN THAT WERE STILL IN
THE MIDST OF THE RECEIVERSHIP
AND ONLY ROUGHLY A DOZEN- ON
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN
DELEGATED SO ESSENTIALLY THE
PROCESS OF GETTING OUT OF THE
RECEIVERSHIP. REQUIRES THE
RECEIVER DELHI EIGHT. BILLION
SO. THAT KERN. ON CAN BY
RECEIVER. TWITCHES KERN ROD IT
OR SO OKAY AS PART IF YOU ARE.
ON A THEN ALSO. ANY OF THE-
THAT THE RECEIVERS HAS TAKE IN
CAN. ARMS WE'RE STILL SO OF. A
DID TO ESTIMATE WE THAT WILL.
BUT WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH. THE
DELEGATION OF ALL OF THOSE AND
SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT COST
COULD INCREASE HOWEVER. BOB
THERE IS. THERE IS A SIGNATURE
CHANGE IN THE SIZE OF THE
POPULATION. IT COULD OF THE M.
OF CA THAT THE STATE IS FOR.
BUT I WOULD SAY THEY'RE SORT OF.
MORE UPSET AND RISK THAN THERE
IS. A LIKELIHOOD OF REDUCTION
IN COST. ENTER OF YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT THE RADIO HEALTH CARE STE
I THINK IT IS FOR TO SAY THEY
ARE ARE NOT. REAL WITH INMATES.
FOR CA REASONS ONE BECAUSE OF
THE FIX COSTS. FOR WE INVEST IN
THE UC. HEALTH CARE FACILITY
WHICH WAS A MAJOR EXPENDITURE
OF FUNDS TO CREATE A LARGE-
HOSPITAL LIKE SETTING FOR
INMATES BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT. WITH CERTAIN
EXCEPTIONS WHITE PROP THIRTY
SIX MANY OF THE SENTENCING
CHANGES HAVE REALLY AFFECTED
SHORTER TERM INMATES- AND SO
THERE'S SORT OF A
DISPROPORTIONATELY LESS LIKELY
TO AFFECT THE- LONG TERM MORE-
THE END MEETS WERE AGING AND
CONTRIBUTING TO HEALTH CARE
COST IS PROPORTIONALLY SO IT'S
ALSO. SEE WHAT NON LINEAR
BECAUSE OF THE RELATIONSHIP
WELL. I GUESS WE SAY THE BOTTOM
OF A THROW AWAY THE KEY THEN
WE'RE PAYING FOR ALL OF IT.
YEAH OKAY. BUT THAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR ANSWERS I IT
LOOKS. TO YOU KNOW I'M SURE OF
PRESENTED MORE BUT WHICH FOLLOW
ALONG. AND SEEING WHAT WE CAN
TRY TO DO TO ADDRESS THAT I
GUESS THE ONE OTHER MAYBE FOR
IF I MAY JUST ONE BRIEF SO. WE
TALK ABOUT RECEIVERSHIP AND WE
HAVE THE YOU KNOW WITH EACH
FACILITY BUT I. PRESUME AND
LESS WE THINK RECEIVERS FOR THE
SPENDING LOTS OF EXTRA MONEY
THAT THE SPENDING ONCE THEY'VE
SILLY MOVES OUT OF RECEIVERSHIP
STILL STAYS APPROXIMATELY THE
SAME ADJUSTED FOR OF NUMBER OF.
IS IN AGENTS FORTH THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE RETURN. THREE
EIGHTY NINE. WE SHOULD BE
EXPECTING EIGHT. DROP INS
HEALTHCARE SPENDING JUST
BECAUSE OF GOES OUT A PURSE
RECEIVERSHIP RIGHT I MEAN IT'S
VERY REASON WE ENDED UP IN
RECEIVERSHIP EXCELLENT DOING
THE RIGHT THING CORRECT. THAT
IS CORRECT- IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THERE'D BE A SOMEWHAT MINOR
REDUCTION BECAUSE IN SOME CASES
THERE'S SORT OF A DUPLICATION
OF ADMINISTRATIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND WE MIGHT
HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE
SOME DECISIONS THAT. WE WOULD
LACK THAT ABILITY BUT ON THE
WHOLE THERE SHOULD YOU USE YOU
WOULD BE SURPRISED TO SEE A
LARGE REDUCTION IN THE AND
HEALTHCARE EXPENDITURES-
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAINTAIN THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING ONCE WE SUCCESSFULLY-
EXIT THE RECEIVERSHIP. THANK
YOU THANKS FOR MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTERVILLE.
REGARDING THE HEALTH OF FUNDING
I JUST SAID THE CHAIRS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTWHICH SAYS
THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH BLOCK
GRANT FEDERAL MENTAL HEALTH
BLOCK GRANT CAN BE USE FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. SO I
THINK WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT THE
NEW FEDERAL. A RULE AND HOW
THEY VIEW FUNDING PROGRAMS IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE RE
ENTRY FACILITIES TO SEE IF WE
COULD. INCLUDE THAT NEW POLICY
IN OUR APPROACH TO FUNDING-
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS- WITH
MEDICAID FUNDS AND OTHER.
FEDERAL. HEALTHCARE FUNDS SO
AND I LEAVE IT TO DOCTOR PLAN
DO- EXAMINE THAT CLOSELY IN HIS
COMMITTEE BUT BUT I THINK- IT'S
VERY IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT.
DIRECTION THAT ARE NOW TAKING
THEIR NOW SAYING. YOU COULD
TAKE THE MENTAL HEALTH BLOCK
GRANT AND USE IT FOR FEDERAL
FUNDS. OF WE HAVE A CHART FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
IN THE FINANCE DEPARTMENT. WHO
LISTING THE INMATE POPULATION-
I WOULD LIKE ALL OF US TO LOOK
AT THIS IS THE BASE CASE THAT
WE'RE STARTING WITH NOW. OKAY
IS THE BASE CASE SO WE WANT TO
SEE WHAT STRATEGIES- AT
ACTIVITIES WE CAN PROPOSE-
THROUGH THIS BUDGET PROCESS-
TO. REDUCE THE POPULATION. OF
LEVELS IN OUR STATE PRISON OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS I THINK
THE- THE STRATEGIES- IN THE
OPTIONS. OF WE NEED TO LOOK AT
WERE TALKED ABOUT LARGE A LOT
TODAY- I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTION ON HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS- I'M
INTERESTED IN WHAT THE NEW
DIRECTION OF THE GOVERNOR WOULD
BE. IN TERMS OF HOME LOS.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE THERE A LOT OF
ROOM CAN WE- SOMEHOW PUT THEM
BACK INTO HOUSING. OF WILL
PUTTING THEM BACK IN A HOUSING
REDUCE CRIME IN THE COMMUNITY
WILL REDUCE SO. THE HEALTHCARE
COSTS OF PEOPLE BY HOUSING
THOSE PEOPLE WOULD- PROVIDE A
BETTER FOR THERAPEUTIC
ENVIRONMENT FOR THEM. AND I
THINK WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT THOSE
OPTIONS THAT WE CAN CONSIDER.
TO REDUCE INCARCERATION I
LOOKED SPECIFICALLY AT THE RE
ENTRY- BEDS. AND IN THE IN THE
CHART AND I SEE WILL IS. OUR
POSSIBILITY OF INCREASING THAT
THAT'S A TO BE. KIND OF WHAT
THE GOVERNOR WAS ABOUT I CALLED
SUPPORT OF HOUSING. HOUSING WAS
SUPPORT SYSTEMS- THAT CAN HELP
PEOPLE. I THINK SEARCH SO. MR
WIDELY BOND IN THE JOHNSON HERE
I LIKE TO ASK THEM. IF YOU USE
THIS IS THE BASE CASE WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY THE STATE'S MOST
IMPORTANT NEXT STEPS ARE. OF
FOUR OF THAT WE TAKE IN REGARDS
TO. PEOPLE THAT ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED- WHAT KIND OF
STEPS DO WE TAKE. THE NOW THAT
YOU KNOW ARE PROVEN TO BE
EFFECTIVE- AND- SUCH ABUSE
TREATMENT IS A SPECIAL SPECIAL
INTEREST OF MINE I VISITED THE
DOMINANT FRIZZ. YOUR MATCHING
DIAMOND I WITH DOWN THERE AND
HAD A NICE ENJOYABLE TIME WITH
THE STAFF IN THE- INMATES AND
WE SAW HOW THEY HAD A- RE ENTRY
PROGRAM THERE THAT WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE. IT WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE IN FINDING JOBS FOR
PEOPLE ONCE THEY LEFT DONOVAN.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
WE TALKED ABOUT THE JOB
PLACEMENTS IN THE TRAINING AND
SO FORTH- I WAS VERY IMPRESSED
WITH THAT AND I ALSO VISITED
THE- CORRECTIONS FACILITY IN A
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA FOR WOMEN.
AND I FOUND THAT MAYBE THEY
DON'T HAVE SUCH A ROBUST JOB
TRAINING. PROGRAMS THAT MAYBE
WOULD BE RELEVANT I MEAN THEY
HAD SOME JOBS JOBS IN THE
PRISON MAKING FLAGS AND- NO
DENTAL APERTURES AND OTHER
THINGS BUT- HOW CAN WE IMPROVE
THOSE PROGRAMS TO MAKE THEM
RELEVANT TO PEOPLE. IN
PLACEMENT OF JOBS AFTER THEY
LEAVE PRISON SO THOSE ARE THE
QUESTIONS MAYBE PERHAPS YOU CAN
START YOUR YOUR- DIALOGUE ON MY
PRINT MY PURPOSES THIS IS THE
BASE CASE WHICH IS START HERE
AND WE SAID OKAY LET'S GET TO
STRATEGIES ALL TOGETHER IN. THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS- LET'S COME UP
WITH SOME- ANSWERS DURING THE
BUDGET PROCESS I'D SAY MY
COMMENTS OF THE- KIND OF BRIEF
THIS SIX BECAUSE- I THINK THAT
A LOT OF MYSTERIES AND I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF. A LOT OF-
MISMATCH IN TERMS OF THE
PROGRAMMATIC OFFERINGS IN THE
INSTITUTIONS. AND WHAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY NEED AND AS YOU
MENTIONED PEOPLE WHO WERE WHO
WERE RETURNING FROM PRISON I
THINK. ON THE FRONT END PEOPLE
COME IN AND WE NEED A BETTER
SENSE OF WHO THEY ARE WHAT THEY
NEED. IS SO THAT WE CAN
PRESCRIBE. A PROGRAM THAT WILL
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THEM ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS AND WHEN THEY GO
HOME. WHAT NEEDS TO REMAIN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHILE THEY'RE ON
PAROLE OR AND OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. THAT THEY GET THE
KIND OF SUPPORT. THEY NEED
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
COUNSELING THERAPY I THINK ONE
THING THAT CAN REALLY HELP ME
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT A TO
THE- THE POINT THAT YOU RAISED
ABOUT. WHAT YOU SAW WHEN YOU
WENT TO THE INSTITUTIONS. I
THINK THAT. THAT PEOPLE IN THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO GET INTO
THE PRISONS. YOU NEED TO SEE
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE BY
THE TWENTY SIX NOW I THINK.
I'LL I'LL BET MOST PEOPLE HAVE
NOT BEEN TWENTY SIX- BECAUSE
BECAUSE IT'S PEOPLE DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND WHAT LOOKS LIKE WHAT
IT FEELS LIKE. OUR BE TRUE ASK
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
WHAT THEY NEED. IF YOU PROVIDE
A SAFE SPACE THEY WILL SHARE
THAT WITH YOU. AND THEN THEN
HAVE THE DRIVER POLICY. INSTEAD
OF CREATE A POLICY AND SAY HEY
WE'RE GIVING YOU WHAT WE THINK
YOU PROBABLY NEED AND I THINK
THAT'S A BIG MISSING PIECE I
MEAN THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD BE CAN
BE GLEANED ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
SURVIVORS OF GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE. THERE IS SUCH A GREAT
NEED OF SPACE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
ASK FOR WHAT THEY NEED THAT
WOULD REALLY INFORM A LOT OF
OUR PROGRAMMATIC DECISIONS
GOING FORWARD I THINK IN THAT
THAT JUST MEANS GOING TO THE
INSTITUTION LISTING. HAVING AN
INFORMATIONAL. MEETINGS AND
HEARINGS IN THE INSTITUTIONS
SPECIAL THE WOMAN'S PRESENCE
AGAIN TELL YOU A LOT. ABOUT
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE TO DO THAT
IF WOMEN'S PRESENTING- FLOOR
REALLY IMPORTANT A LONG LIST OF
THINGS THEY- WHEN THE OFFICE.
DECADE YEAH FIVE THIRTY BY THE
WOMEN'S KERR A WE HAVE
ATTEMPTED. A CLOSED GAP ON IN
TERMS OF. AMONG OUR COLLEAGUES
THE ISSUES AROUND EQUITY- AND
CHALLENGES INCARCERATED WOMEN
HAVE EXERIENCE IN THE STATE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AND SO.
MANY OF US DO THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT THEY TALKED ABOUT YEAH
THEY ALSO ONE MORE WOMEN- FOX
STAFF YEAH YEAH IN FACT WOMEN'S
FACILITIES SEC LAKES IN ONE OF
THE RESPONSE THANK YOU AND I
AGREE ON GROUP'S KEYS COMMENTS
CERTAINLY WITH WOMEN'S- VISIT
IN DATA WOMEN'S PRISON LOOKS
VERY DIFFERENT THAN AN IMMENSE.
SENSE OF SUPPORT FOR WOMEN AN
INSTITUTION LOOKS VERY
DIFFERENT AS WELL- AND I WOULD
JUST ADD TO THAT THE COMMUNITY
CAPACITY YOU TALK ABOUT MEN ALL
SERVICES ACT CHANGE IN THAT
WILL OPEN DOORS- AND LEVERAGE
RESOURCES WELL A LOT OF THE
HOUSE AND IT WAS BILL WITH
IMAGES SAY DOLLARS DO NOT ALLOW
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON PAROLE TO
LIVE IN THAT HOUSE IN. SO I
THINK THAT WILL HELP AND MAKING
SURE THAT A FULL CONTINUUM OF
CARE WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
PRISON COUPLED WITH AFTER CARE
SERVICES AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES BUT FINALIZING THAT
WITH HOUSING PEOPLE HAVE TO
HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE ONCE
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH A PROCESS
IT CAN'T JUST BE A SIX MONTH
COMMITMENT THAT'S NOT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
FIGURE OUT. WORKING WITH LOCAL-
AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
SUCCESSFULLY HOUSE THAT'S WHY
LARGELY THE HOMELESS POPULATION
IS FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND SO
MAKING SURE THAT WE LEVERAGE
DRUG MEDI CAL DOLLARS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR OUTPATIENT
SERVICES. THAT HELP US MAXIMIZE
MORE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FOR
THOSE THAT DON'T QUALIFY FOR
THAT ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
BECAUSE DRUG THE CAL ONE RETAIL
BUT IT ALSO IN THE REGION STATE.
OF HER ENTRY. JUST AN EMPTY
PART AS WELL. INNER IN
INSTITUTIONS. AND YOU TO
DEVELOP SEE I WOULD KERN
CAREERS MEAN. BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE INCARCERATED HAVE A LOT
OF SKILLS. AND I NEVER GET THE
CHANCE DISPLAYED A TALENT. WE
DO WE DEVELOP WORKSOURCE
CENTERS IN INSTITUTION THEY
COME AND SEE AN NAY PREPARED
I'M STILL BEFORE YOU EVEN
LEAVE. IN A GOOD TRANSFERRED IT
TO WHEN THEY GET OUT. IN THIS
WILL WE DO WE HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH TRADE TECH
AND ONE STUFF. IN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS PVV FOR JOBS AND
FOR DIFFERENT SKILLS GUYS WANT
TO GO BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT GOD
TO JUST GO WORK AND WE'RE I
MEAN WAREHOUSE JOB TO GET IT.
SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE YOU HAVE A
DEGREE IN IN A BID TO SKEW WHY
YOU WANT TO SETTLE FOR
WAREHOUSE. YOU KNOW. USUALLY
TALENT TO BE DEVELOPING AND
FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHAT YOU WON'T
BECAUSE I ENJOY GOING TO WORK.
YOU KNOW OUR SOON WITH THE
YOUNG LADY OUTSIDE OUT EVERY
DAY I DRIVE A HUNDRED MILES TO
GO TO WORK. IN A ENJOY WHEN I
GET DO BECAUSE- WHEN I'D BE
ABLE TO COME TO SAY WE WANT TO
MEAN THE NAY TIMOTHY GOT A JOB
AND I GOT THE LIGHTS IT DID
BRING JOY TO ME. IN A SEVERE
BASIC THINGS GUYS ME WHEN THEY
GET OUT OF PRISON NAY NEED A
BIRTH CERTIFICATE A DRIVER
LANCERS KITTY. GOING BEFORE WE
COULD EVEN GET A JOB. SO WE
WILL WORK WITH YOU TO GET THAT
FOR THEIR BEFORE EVEN GO OUT
AND STUFF LIKE THAT AND SOME
RUN INTO DANGER BECAUSE THE
MOTHER THEY PUT THE FIRST NAME
A LAST NAME ON THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE. WE HAVE A SYSTEM
TO HELP THEM TO GET IT IT TAKES
A COUPLE. WITH THE GET THE TO.
GET THE. IN IN. SPACE IT TWO
HAD BEEN YOU KNOW A PEOPLE TO
REPAY BECAUSE WE YOU TODAY OUR
LIVES STILL WANT A PROBLEM YOU
HAVE BY IN ROW AND YOU GO TO BE
FOR THAT SO WE DEMANDED WE WORK
WITH YOU KNOW JUST BE YOU KNOW
PLACE IN AND YOU YOU LUXURY
WITH ME AND A HOUSE TO APPLY
THAT SO A LOT OF DOUBLE WITH
MISS WIDELY SHARE AND DO YOU
NEED TO GET TO STORE APPROVED
THE BAND ARE YOU KNOW. EVEN
WOULD LIKE THERE WAS SOME EARLY
BY ANY MORE TO WITH THE IF YOU
WILL FAMILY REVIEW A OUR NEAR.
YOU KNOW. BECAUSE PEOPLE DO
KNOW WHO YOU ARE OR THEY DON'T
KNOW CHANGE IT YOU MAY BECAUSE
WHEN I GO. A FREE I WOULD GO
THIRTY TWO YEARS. IN NAME WHEN
I GOT OUT PEOPLE TO. ME TO SAME
WAY. BUT I WOULD ASSUME SOME
TOTALLY DIFFERENT. IS SO PEOPLE
COULD LIKE YOU KNOW. ME AND
GATHER INSIDE. IN THE CHANGE
YOU HAVE BEFORE THEM AND THE
PERSON KNOWS THAT. YOU KNOWS OF
AT THE YOU KNOW IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT I HAD ONE OTHER
QUESTION FOR OUR ROOM.
SECRETARY. I EIGHT. WHEN YOU
GIVE SOMEBODY A. A SENS AND
THEN THEY GO TO PRISON. AND
THEN THEY HAVE BEHAVIORAL
PROBLES IN THE PRISON. AND
THIRD PRISON TERM IS THE US
BECAUSE OF INFRACTIONS IN THE
SYSTEM YOU HAVE. EXTENDED IN
TIME. OF I VIEW THAT IS KIND OF
A FAILURE OF PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. AND I VIEW IT
AS SOMETHING THAT WE PROBABLY
SHOULD RECONSIDER THE WAY WE DO
THAT. IN TERMS OF. THERE SHOULD
BE NO PUNISHMENT CRIMINALLY FOR
ANYBODY THAT HAS A MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM. IN. TO THE WHEN
WE EXTENDERS SENS OR THEIR TIME
OR SOMEHOW. PROVIDE SOME
PUNISHMENT FOR THEM IN THEIR
BEHAVIOR. OF IS THERE'S SOME
CHANGES THAT YOU ARE
CONSIDERING AND THEN I HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT GANG AFFILIATION.
OF AND LABELING PEOPLE RELATIVE
TO GANGS AND EXTENSION OF THEIR
SENTENCING. IS THAT A- WHAT ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
DONE TERMS OF EXTENDING THE
SENSES AND IS IT. TIME TO
REALLY CONSIDER SOME OF THOSE
THINGS. I THINK IF. IT'S TIME
THAT WE RECONSIDER MANY THINGS
SENATOR- IN RELATION TO THE
ADDITIONAL TIME THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO I'M ONLY THINKING
OF INMATES WHO RECEIVED- GOOD
CONDUCT CREDITS THAT APPLIED TO
THEIR CURRENT SENTENCE THAT
THERE'S ALREADY BUILT IN CREDIT
CREDITS BUT READ IT IS DEMERITS
IF THEY GET DEMERITS SO THEY
LOSE THE CONDUCT CREDITS THAT
THEY'VE EARNED BY EITHER THE
TYPE A SENTENCE THEY RECEIVED
OR- TIME OFF SENTENCES BY
PARTICIPATION IN PROGRAMMER
OTHER OTHERWISE- THE MENTAL
HEALTH POPULATION- AS STATED
EARLIER TO HAS RISEN WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. WE DO HAVE TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
MENTAL HEALTH BEHAVIOR BEFORE
WE DO BEFORE WE ADDRESS ANY
LOSS OF CREDITS WE CAN DO
BETTER AT FACT- WILL NOT ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE COMMON CORD IS
ASKING US TO BUT I THINK
INTERNALLY WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THE SOME OF THE BEHAVIORS THAT
INMATES EXHIBIT OUR MENTAL
HEALTH RELATED AND SHOULD THEY
RECEIVE TIME OFF SENTENCE FOR
THAT- IF WE CAN ATTRIBUTE TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH. I THINK YOU
KNOW BALANCING SAFETY SECURITY
AND SUPPORTING STAFF NEEDS OUR
CONCERNS AND HOW WE TRACK IN
AND DEAL WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
EITHER BY GETTING OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THEY NEED. FOR
PROVIDING. A SAFER LEVEL OF
HOUSING FOR THEM BASED ON THE
SECURITY IT'S A DIFFICULT. YOU
KNOW IT'S A DIFFICULT- POSITION
TO BE IN TO TRY AND MATCH THE
BOLD BUT I KNOW. ONE THING THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT IS YOU KNOW
DO WE WRITE DISCIPLINARY IS FOR
PEOPLE TO TAKE SOME TIME OFF
THEIR SENTENCE JUST BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DID HAS A
MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT TO IT.
I THINK GRANT A POINT ON
CORRECTIONS WE CAN START MAKING
BETTER INFORMED DECISIONS. BUT
WE DO HAVE TO DOCUMENT THE
BEHAVIOR FOR TREATMENT PURPOSES
SO WE CAN SHOW EITHER FOR PRE
PAROLE OR PROGRAM NEEDS. IT HAS
TO BE DOCUMENTED SOMEWHERE- IN
RELATION TO- FOR WE HOUSE
INMATES THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN MATES DEBTORS-
MENTALLY ILL. THE RAIN
RESTRICTED HOUSINGS OUR ADS SAY
EGGS ARE SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
WHATEVER YOU KNOW. WHATEVER
TURN PEOPLE ON TO USE THESE
DAYS BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT. A
LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH DOES DRIVE
A PERSON'S PLACEMENT IN THOSE
AREAS. AND THEN THEY LIKE TO
STAY THERE FOR VARIOUS REASONS
EITHER OUT OF FEAR. FOR THEIR
TO THEY HAVE- DECOMPENSATED TO
A POINT THAT'S ALL THE WORLD
THAT THEY KNOW AND THAT'S A
STRUGGLE THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW. WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SAY.
A PERSON'S BEHAVIOR SHOULDN'T
AUTOMATICALLY PLACE THEM IN A
SEGREGATED HOUSING MAY THEY
JUST SEEM TO BE IN ANOTHER TYPE
OF HOUSING IN A- IN A-
COMMUNITY SETTING OR AN AREA TO
WERE STAFF FOR. OR CLINICAL
STAFF CAN A JESTER NEEDS BETTER
THAN AN AD SIX SETTING. SO WE
TALKED ABOUT TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS THE TIME OFFICE SENTENCE
BASIN BEHAVIOR. THAT'S MINUS
THEM GETTING. ALSO ADDING OF
TIME OR ADDING OF TIME WOULD BE
THEY GO OUT AND GET ANOTHER
CHARGE IN THE- WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ELEMENT COUNTY TODAY.
WELL IN THAT CASE THE TICKET.
THEY LOOKED ALL FACT AND THEY
HAVE TO MAKE THEIR OWN. WHEN
THEY WERE TO CHARGE NOT. I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
IS EXTEND THEIR SENT BASED TIME
EARNED. THIS CASE WE HAVE TO-
AND PLAINTIFFS COUNSEL ON THE
ON THE COLEMAN CASE THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT THEY HAVE WITH US
AND WE ARE. WE DON'T HAVE OUR
HE'LL SO DUG IN BUT IT'S ABOUT
MATCHING. GIVEN THE RIGHT
ANSWER SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SAFETY SECURITY BUT THE SAME
TIME. ADDRESSING THE SAFETY
CONCERNS THAT AN INMATE HAS. SO
WHAT ON THE RE ENTRY PIECE
WHAT. WHAT WE HAVE NOW LONG. I
THINK WE'VE ALWAYS NANA BUT
JUST FOR A TO SAY IT RANCHERIA
BEGINS DAY ONE. FOR AN INMATE.
DAY ONE THAT THEY HAD A
RECEPTION CENTER. AND THEN THE
DAY ZERO BEFORE THEY GO OUT RE
AND WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE HAVE. FIRST IDENTIFY THE
INDIVIDUAL'S NEEDS TO MISTER
WALLACE POINT- JUST. AN INMATE
IN A VERY PROGRAM JUST AS AN
OPENING DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S
BEST PRO FOR THEM IS PROBABLY A
WASTE OF RESOURCE. SO WE HAVE
TO ASSESS WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL'S
NEEDS ARE WE HAVE TO ASSESS
WHAT THE RISK IS. AND THAT HAS
TO BE A STATIC ASSESSMENT IT I
MEAN MORE DYNAMIC RIGHT NOW
WITH STATIC. WE CAN DO IT. A
NEAR ONE BUT THAT WE MAY NOT
RECESS UNTIL YOUR FIVE A LOT OF
HAPPENED IN THE FIVE YEARS
THEY'VE MATURED THEY'VE
LEARNED. AND GROWN SO THEIR
NEEDS. ARE ALSO GOING TO
INCREASE OF THE WE NEED TO BE
MORE DYNAMIC ON WHAT WE HOUSE
THEM- TO INCLUDE LOWER LEVEL
HOUSING. INDIVIDUAL DON'T
ALWAYS NEED TO BE A LEVEL FOUR
FACILITIES WHICH ARE HIGHEST
LEVEL THEY DON'T- AND I THINK
THE YOUTHFUL OFFENDER PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN THE
BUDGET IS ADDRESSING THAT
ISSUE. RECOGNIZING THAT INMATES
WHO HAVE BACKED UP MANY POINTS
THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF
INCARCERATION. THAT MAY NOT BE
THE BEST PLACE FOR THEM IN YOUR
FIVERR YOUR TEN. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE LEARNED THAT WAS NOT A
PROPER WAY THINKING. WE HAVE
OVER WRITTEN DOWN INMATES IF
THEY HAVE BEEN DESPAIR FREEZE
WE CAN GET THEM THE NEEDS THAT
THEY YOUR PAROLE- DEPARTMENTS
FEEL THAT THERE IS A LACK OF.
THE FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE IN YES.
HOW CAN WE COORDINATE THAT.
ISSUE WITH THE GOVERNORS. WELL
I WORK THAT HE'S TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH ON THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESS. POPULATION IT'S RIGHT
IN LINE WITH THE HOUSING PIECE
I THINK RE ENTRY SERVICES
RAINTREE HOUSING NOT TO FOR THE
SAKE OF HOUSING BUT WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. IS CRITICAL AND
THAT'S WERE. YOU KNOW PARTNERS
OF OURS LIKE LIKE DOGS AND
OTHERS THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE
GOING TO BE CRITICAL BUT I
KNOW. THAT THEIR FACED AND
OTHERS ARE FACED WITH THE- THE
CONCERN OF A FACILITY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OR ZONING OR
PARTICULAR COUNTING OR AREA.
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING WE HAVE
HAD SITES THAT. PARTNERS THAT
WE'VE HAD OUR TRIED TRY TO GET
ZONE FOR FACILITIES AND JUST
BECAUSE OF POLITICS ARE
CONCERNED. WE CAN GET ZONED.
THAT HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED OUR
PAROLE DIVISION- THEY ARE IN
LINE WITH THE REHABILITATIVE
CHANGES THAT WE'VE HAD IN OUR
PRISONS. THEY HAVE THE SEVEN
LINE THAT. ALSO TO PROVIDE THIS.
WE'RE. THE TWO SHOULD HAVE GONE.
HOW FORM. I OVERSEE THE PAROLE
SIDE BUT I HAVE A GOOD. WITH
THE PROBATION PARTNERS IN THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. AND THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE ALL THE
INFORMATION. THAT AND SERVICES
THAT THE INMATE HAS RECEIVED
THAT THEY GET THAT SAME
INFORMATION FOR THE PROBATION.
OFFICERS TO COUNTY SO THEY CAN
BE. UTILIZING THE SAME
INFORMATION TO PLUGIN. RELEASES
INTO SERVICES THE SAME WAY
PAROLE PLUGS AND RELEASES
ANDERSON THANK TO. BE AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF RE
ENTRY BEDS OR- OTHERWISE
HOUSING. UNITS THAT INMATES
COULD BE PLACED IN IN DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PROPRIETY IS DIFFERENT
TYPES. OF IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE I SEE THE
NUMBERS THAT YOU SHOW YOUR THE
OVER FIVE YEARS. SALAS THE SAME
IT DOESN'T CHANGE. AND ARE
WONDERING IF SOME KIND OF
INITIATIVE COULD TAKE PLACE TO
SHOW US. MAYBE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH. THERE WOULD INCREASED
THAT PROCESS BASED ON WHAT I
HEARD HERE OF I HAD A QUESTION
FOR DOUG TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION NO YOU MAY DEFINITELY
DIRTY YOU LIKE THAT IDEA YOU
WANT TO WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS. YES COMMITTEE OR TASK
FORCE THIS WORK ON THE SCRIPT
MMHM SO I TAKE YOUR CHECK WE
NEED TO GET THE- MORE
SPECIFICS. COORDINATOR WITHOUT
I'D LOVE TO SEE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED THAT- YUP A FROM A
JUST QUICKLY THAT- TO SOME
DETAIL ON THAT WERE ACTUALLY
PROPOSING AN EXPANSION OF A
HUNDRED BEDS- FOR A NEW ONE
HUNDRED BED REENTRY FACILITY IN
ALAMEDA- AS PART OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET- WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO-
TO FIND NEW REENTRY FACILITIES-
AND A LOT OF LATE. HE'S TALKING
ABOUT HE FOUND ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED SITES THAT WE- THAT I.
LAST YEAR WAS A HUNDRED NOTES
OVER HUNDRED SO HE'S GOT HE'S
WORKING ON FINDING. HE SOME
PROPERTIES THE NEW FACILITIES
YEAH AND I DON'T THINK LEASE
WHEN HE DID THAT WE NEED TO BE
CREATIVE IN TERMS OF HOW WE-
APPROACH THIS ISSUE WE'VE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH
MISTER BOND ABOUT- HOW WE CAN-
FACILITATE THE EXPANSION OF
REENTRY FACILITIES AND GET
AROUND SOME THE CONTRACTING
ISSUES THAT HAVE. I THINK
PRESENTS SOME CHALLENGES BUT-
IT'S NOT SIMPLY AN ISSUE THAT
WE CAN JUST KIND OF THROW MONEY
AT THERE ARE COMPLEXITIES
AROUND CITING AND SO FORTH SO-
BUT I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
CONSTANTLY EXPLORING
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND THAT
AREA THE GOVERNOR CONSIDERS
THAT A COMMON CORNER STONE OF
THE- OF OUR EFFORTS AROUND
REENTRY. BUT A DOG I HAVE ONE
LAST QUESTION WE COULD MA'AM
SURE DON'T YOU MENTIONED THAT
YOU WERE. IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM OKAY AND I'M- I OFFERED
A BILL TO AB. WHICH EXTEND THE
AGE HOWEVER. YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM WHEN THE AGE OUT ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR. AB TWELVE RIGHT
OF CAN YOU TALK ABOUT FOSTER
USE A DEBIT **** ADULTS THAT
AGE OUT AND HOW THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR A. B. TWELVE
SERVICES THAT'S THE EXTENT AGE
FROM EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE
AND- I MIGHT ADD I HAVE A BILL
THAT EXTENDS IT TO TWENTY FIVE
OF INTRODUCED SO I WOULD HIGHLY
RECOMMEND IN THAT I KNOW I HAVE
A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD AND I WOULD
WONDER ON OUR OWN IT EIGHTEEN
WELL CAN YOU AND I GUESS ON.
YOU KNOW AS A FIVE CHILD NOT
HAVING THE RESOURCES WORK ON
BUILDING TRANSITION AGES
HOUSING AND WE WORK WITH OTHER
AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE SERVICE
AND I CAN TELL YOU BEING IN
THAT SAYS YOU DO EXPERIENCE
TRAUMA UNIT. YOU GO. FOR HOUSE
TO HOUSE THE NOT ONE FAMILY
GIVEN TO. OVER DOESN'T YOU KNOW
SO YOU'RE IN MULTIPLE FAMILIES-
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING AND TO
SAY THAT SOMEBODY IS READY AT
EIGHTEEN. THREE INDEPENDENT AND
TO LIVE ON THEIR OWN IS JUST
NOT CORRECT AND WE KNOW THIS-
IN JUVENILE HALL. THEY TURNED-
UNDER THE JURORS RIGHT. THEY
TURN EIGHTEEN. AND THEY HAVE A
MOTOROLA BY THIS IS THE CASE
THAT A BROTHER. WHO WAS INJURED
WHEN ALL HE HE WAS A FOSTER
KID. AND HE WAS ALLOWED TO HAVE
THE SERVICES HE WENT TO
COLLEGE. THE OTHER BROTHER THE
ITS CURRENCY CHENEY BECAME LIKE
ON THE STREETS AND WHAT'S SO
TRAGIC ABOUT THAT IS IN MANY
INSTANCES THE SAME POPULATION
IT JUST DEPENDS ON WHO SHOWED
UP FOR. THE SHERIFF OR SOCIAL
WORKER THAT'S CORRECT IN YOUR
LIFE BUT IT'S THEY'RE THE SAME.
YEAH I IT'S DO WITH THAT IS
THAT A MAJOR. IT IS A PER. IN
IT NEEDS BE A- I THINK PEOPLE
ARE IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD
AGREE IS THAT WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING HOME ESPECIALLY FROM
INCARCERATION IT'S HARD ENOUGH
FOR INDIVIDUALS TRANSITION AND
OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
WITHOUT THE OTHER ADDITIONAL
ISSUES OF COMING OUT OF A
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM- SO TO TAKE
THAT RESOURCE AWAY FROM THEM IS
ONLY GOING TO PUT THAT IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY WILL
LIKELY END UP IN THE ADULT
SYSTEM MORE HAVE A HIGHER RISK.
TO END UP IN THE ADULT SYSTEM
AND THEN COME TO US TWENTY
YEARS SAID LATER FOR HELP. SO I
THINK THAT DOES NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED I THINK IS A SOMEBODY
THAT'S EXPERIENCE THAT I CAN
SAY THAT. AND SOMEBODY IT'S NOW
APPARENT YOU KNOW MY DAUGHTER I
ADOPTED MY DAUGHTER AT FIVE
YEARS OLD SHE'S FIFTEEN. AND
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE TO
GET THOSE RESOURCES BUT I KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE THE I LIVED ON
MY OWN I WAS FIFTEEN. IN A
YEARS OLD. I KNOW THE CHECK.
WHICH IS A BUT IT WAS A-
FIFTEEN YEAR. LIVING ON MY OWN
THAN STRUCK. WORKING TWO JOBS
AND TRYING TO GO TO SCHOOL. AND
TRYING TO GET BY AND NOT REALLY
ACCESS IN THOSE KIND OF
RESOURCES AS WELL. AND REALLY
AVAILABLE IN THE STATE THAT I
LIVED IN- OR- MADE AWARE OF TO
MEANS AT THAT TIME SO. YES I. I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT DOES
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AT THINK
INDIVIDUALS AND DJJ IN AND
OTHER JUVENILE INSTITUTIONS I
WOULD IMAGINE. THE CORRECTIONS
AND PROBATION THOSE ARE-
BARRIERS FOR THEM AS WELL TO
BECAUSE THEY'RE HELPING TO
COORDINATE GETTING THEM OUTOF
THE SYSTEMS OF RESOURCES. AND
SO ME I COULDN'T. SAY ENOUGH
ABOUT THAT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS SO. FINDS OUT IF
ANY OF THE PEOPLE UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION ARE ELIGIBLE.
ESPECIALLY THE YOUNGER ONES.
FOR FOSTER CARE SERVICES.
BECAUSE I DON'T THEN I VISIT
THE PRISONS AND I ASKED THE
QUESTION OF THE WARDENS HOW
MANY OF THE IMAGES THINKER.
FORMER FOSTER YOU. I HEAR ALL
KINDS OF NUMBERS LIKE 60% 50%
OF IS A HUGE NUMBER AT LEAST I
MEAN I HAVE NO IDEA I THINK WE
HAVE THE SOLID. YEAH AND IF
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS WHICH THE FEDERAL
CHILD WELFARE ACT. PUTS MONEY
INTO THESE PROGRAMS. THE IF WE-
LET ME CHANGE THIS LAW THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THEY WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE. FOR ALL THE
SERVICES THAT OTHER FOSTER YOU
FORGET. AND IT SEEMS LIKE A
REAL NO BRAINER FOR US TO DO
THAT AND TO HELP THEM- ACHIEVE
SUCCESS IN THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE CHILDWELFARE
AXLE ABOUT IS TO TRY TO FIND A
WAY OF CHI ACHIEVING- SUCCESS
SO I DON'T SURE I HAD AHEAD I
ONLY HAVE ONE MORE THING I WANT
TO DO. COULD YOU FIND OUT HOW
MUCH THE AVERAGE PRISONER COSTS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
DISH IN THIS BUDGET. WHAT IS
THE NUMBER FOR THAT AT THAT
SOMEBODY KNOWS. I HAD L. L.
HAVE YOU DOWN TO THE NEAREST
DOLLAR BUT I TELL YOU THAT IT'S
ABOUT. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
AVERAGE BECAUSE- WHAT'S THE
COST AND AN EMPHASIS ON AVERAGE
BECAUSE AS WE WERE TOLD EARLIER
YOU KNOW EVERY BAD ISN'T
DESIGNED YEAH THAT THERE THERE
ARE NO AVERAGE INMATES EVERY
INMATE IS UNIQUE SO. AVERAGE I
APPRECIATE THAT OF THE OVERALL
AVERAGE IS ABOUT NINETY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PROJECTED FOR
THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- HOW MUCH OF A FOR
WOMEN INMATES. SO THAT'S AN
OVERALL AVERAGE INCLUDES WOMEN-
WE I DON'T HAVE ANY DATA
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE ON THE
BREAK OUT BETWEEN THE MEN AND
WOMEN'S THAT'S JUST THAT'S A
CUMULATIVE AVERAGE ON THE OTHER
THE OTHER MAN SURE THE OTHER
THING THE WOMAN. SAID OUR
LITTLE SAFE MEETING WE HAD A
LITTLE SAFE MEETING THERE WITH
THE THERE'S OVER A THOUSAND ON
THAT ONE TATTOO REMOVAL. AS A
BELIEVE THAT THE GANG MARK ON
THEIR- BODY WILL. ENCOURAGE
LAST CHANCE FOR PAROLE WELL AND
THEN THE CHALLENGE FOR THE
WOMEN BECAUSE IF IT'S IF THE
TATTOO WAS GANG RELATED IT CAN
BE REMOVED THE CHALLENGE FOR
MOST WOMEN IS THE TATTOOS ARE
THE NAMES OF MEN IN THEIR LIVES
AND THERE'S NOT ALWAYS AN
ASSOCIATION OF THE THAT HIS
NAME ON YOUR FOREHEAD AS I
HAVE. BORNE WITNESS TO IS A
DIRECT GANG AFFILIATION AND SO
THE WOMEN IT'S THE NATURE OF
THE TATTOOS- THAT WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE WE EXPAND THE LAW TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE INCLUDED THERE
IS FUNDING WE HAVE A TATTOO
REMOVAL PROGRAM YES YOU TO DO
SOMETHING TO MAKE IT BIGGER AYE
GARCIA WE DO HAVE FUNDING SO AS
WELL OF THE RE ENTRY NUMBER THE
NONPROFIT TO DO IT AS WELL- SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR BAIL-
YES WE'VE GOT- OUR LAST MEMBER
WHO ASK QUESTIONS AND THEN WE
WILL OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AS I QUEUE UP SOME TO
COP A YEAR OKAY IF I CAN JUST
SEE BY SHE'S A SIGN A SHOW OF
HANDS HOW MANY PEOPLE TEND
PARTICIPATING PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY. SEND A COPY
OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS I
ACT ACTUALLY. KIND OF FALL INTO
TWO. TWO AREAS- AT FIRST I WANT
TO SAY THAT- THAT THIS IS A
BUDGET. A HEARING SO THAT IT IT
I APPRECIATE THAT THE BUDGET
ASPECTS OF THE THINGS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE IMPACTS THAT
IT HAS ON OUR BUDGET BUT- BUT I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HUMANISTIC
APPROACH- AT THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AND- SECRETARY.
SECRETARY DS YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE MISSION IN THE VISION.
STATEMENTS AND I LOOKED HIM UP
WHILE YOU WERE TALKING SO THAT
I COULD GET A SENSE OF WHERE
YOU WERE COMING FROM AND- AND I
THINK THEY'RE ON I JUST WANT A-
BET PERSONALLY I THINK THEY'RE
THEY'RE TERRIFIC THERE ARE OWED
MAP. FOR WHERE I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT SEES ITSELF GOING
AND- AND NAKED THAT GIVES ME A
LOT OF. A LOT OF HOPE AND THEN
I ALSO WANTED THINK- MISTER
WIDELY MISTER BOND AND MISTER
JOHNSON FOR BEING HERE TODAY
BECAUSE YOU PUT THE FACE AND
THE PROGRAM- FRONT AND CENTER
AND ULTIMATELY. PART OF OUR BUT
DID DISCUSSION IS HOW CAN WE DO
A BETTER JOB. OF REHABILITATING.
EIGHT TO HOW AND WHY ARE THE
STEPS WE TO DO A ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO THAT HAVE. MISTER WHAT
I BELIEVE YOU WERE THE ONE WHO
SAID THAT THERE WAS A NEED FOR
SUPPORT AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- ON THAT SO I
JUST WANT TO BE. CLEAR I'M
ASSUMING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
YOU NEED- STATE SUPPORT FOR
THAT BECAUSE- I RUN A NONPROFIT
DOING VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND- YOU GO AROUND
WITH THEIRHAT IN HAND IN THE
COMMUNITY AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT SOMETIMES SO. IF YOU
COULD TALK TO A LITTLE BIT YEAH
DEFINITELY- STATE SUPPORT IS
GREATLY BADLY NEEDED OF LOCAL-
SUPPORT- COUNTY CITY BASE.
IMPORT OF FOR SURE- AND PART OF
THAT IS ABOUT. I WAS THE
FINANCIALS OF ISN'T BUT ALSO
JUST IN ACCESS TO THE
INSTITUTIONS INTO THE PEOPLE WE
WORKING WITH- A AND I THINK I
WILL SAY YOU KNOW THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THINGS GOT A LOT
BETTER- AND THOSE ARE GOOD
IDEAS IS. COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO PARTNER WITH THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE HE
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE THAT FOLKS
BRING WHEN THEY WHEN THEY COME
TO THE INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER
MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING IN AS A PART OF A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
ARE COMING AS VOLUNTEERS.
THEY'RE DOING IT ON EVENINGS
WEEKENDS- AND NONE OF US CAN
SUPPORT OURSELVES OUR FAMILIES
AS WELL AS VOLUNTEERS SO WE
NEED A MUCH MUCH BROADER BASE
OF FUNDING TO SUPPORT THOSE%
EFFORTS. AND I GUESS AS A
FOOTNOTE TO THAT- ALL SERVICES
ARE NOT EQUAL SO THERE MAY BE
REALLY GOOD SERVICES AND IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT
RURAL AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT.
AND IT'S BIG AND MANY OF THE
INMATES AT A RETURNING TO
THEIR- COUNTIES ARE LIVING AN
ISOLATED COMMUNITY SO THAT THIS
SUPPORT AND THE- THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A PROGRAM MAY BE LIMITED AND
SO THEM. I JUST THINK WE NEED
TO THINK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST LOS ANGELES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT HAS A REAL GOOD
SUPPORT SERVICE PROGRAM BUT
THAT THAT THE ON. SOME OF THE
OTHER COUNTIES HAVE HAVE THAT
AS WELL I'M AND I KNOW THAT'S
NOT AN ISSUE THAT. I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO SOLVE THAT ISSUE
BUT I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I THINK THE YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY. ARE OUR- AS
WHAT I HAVE SEEN. WHICH IS THAT
IT IT YOU KNOW TO HAND- IN
INDIVIDUAL TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND A ONE WAY TICKET. JUST
DOESN'T GET THEM STARTED ON AND
ON THE LIFE THAT ON THAT'S
GOING TO BE. REALLY SUPPORTED
AND THE KIDS IN THE BEST CHANCE
FOR SUCCESS SO WHAT WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE SERVICES ARE THAT.
THAT YOU NEED TO WRAP AROUND
HOW DO WE SUPPORT THAT
FINANCIALLY. UP BECAUSE IN THE
END BUT WE WANT TO DO IS REDUCE
OUR OWN COSTS AS WELL AS WELL
AS INTEGRATE. INDIVIDUALS BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITY- SO THE
OTHER THING SO THAT SO THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND- I'M SURE
THAT- THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
WE CAN EXPAND THOSE SERVICES.
IN REGARDS TO THE TESTIMONY
ABOUT. REDUCING THE CONTRACTS.
ED THE CONTRACTED BEDS AND THE
THIS AND PARTICULAR WHAT I'M
WHAT I'M REFERRING TO IS THE
NUMBER OF BEDS THAT WERE IN A
FIVE I HAVE IT ON A PIECE A
NAPKIN SO HIT IT'S NOT AS
THOROUGH AS I'D LIKE IT TO BE.
IN MARCH WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF BEDS THAT WERE
PAYING FOR IN IN THE PRIVATE TO
THE PRIVATE CONTRACTOR IN APRIL
THAT THAT'S ANOTHER RATCHET
DOWN AND MY QUESTION- BECAUSE I
WAS AROUND. UNFORTUNATELY WHEN
WE WERE CONTRACTING OUT OF
STATE AND THOSE CONTRACTS WERE
FAIRLY ONEROUS BECAUSE IT
REQUIRED US TO SEND A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF INMATES OUT OF STATE
INTO A- CONTRACTED FACILITY AND
WE NEVER MET OUR TARGETS. SO AS
A CONSEQUENCE WE WERE PAYING
FOR BEDS THAT WE NEVER FIELD.
AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE AS
WE LOOK AT THIS. OPPORTUNITY TO
GET RID OF THOSE BEDS THAT
WE'RE STILL NOT PAYING FROM
EVEN IF FOR TOUCH UTILIZING
THEM- CERTAINLY- CENTER THE WAY
THE CONTRACTS ARE STRUCTURED WE
ONLY PAY FOR THE BAD THAT WE
USE. SO WE WOULD NOT BE AND
THAT SORT OF SITUATION IN THIS
CASE OKAY SO WHAT AS WE
ELIMINATE THOSE BEDS WERE
MOVING THEM BACK INTO OUR OWN
FACILITIES AND NOTES AND THAT
KIND THOSE CONTRACTS TERMINATE
AND WE DON'T WE'RE NOT PAYING
ON A MANY ANY LONGER ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT AND THERE'S NO PENALTY
ON ON THOSE HOUSES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. I AM
A- PRESIDING. TIME TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS ON THE
DICE. RIGHT THEN WE WILL TURN
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THE MIKE
RIGHT THERE THE MIKE IN THE
AISLE. GOOD AFTERNOON
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO ALL OF
YOU TO THE I'M AMANDA LIFE FOR
IT I AM AN AREA MANAGER WITH
CHIU EVERY COUNTRY SERVICES
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
READ MANY PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I'VE BEEN WITH JURY
ON TREE FOR OF LOVE IN YEARS
NOW AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING- HERE IN
THIS FABULOUS TO. I'M UTILIZING
THIS OPPORTUNITY SPEAK TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR OBJECTIVE TODAY.
TO BE SOLUTION FOCUSED WITH OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. TO RE
ENTRY SERVICES HAS COLLABORATED
WHERE OF CDC ARE AND MANY
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND WE'RE
PROUD TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. WE CAN AGREE THAT
THOSE MANY AGENCIES THAT WANT
TO HELP JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS WHETHER IT BE FOR
PROFIT NON FOR PROFITVOLUNTEERS. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATION
CAN USE ALL OF THE HELP THAT
THEY CAN GET- WE'RE ALL HERE
FOR THE SAME REASON TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. ROOF COMMUNITY
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ULTIMATELY
TURNS LIVE. WHAT I'D LIKE TO
BRING FOCUS TO TODAY THAT HAS
BEEN TOUCHED ON A LITTLE BACK.
BUT IS REALLY GOING BACK TO THE
RESEARCH SO WITH SOME
INDIVIDUALS TODAY HAVE ASKED
WELL HOW DO WE BE A FACTOR BUT
HOW DO WE ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR OUR TAX PELA. MANY MANY
YEARS AGO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF CORRECTIONS AND
THE CRIME AND JUSTICE
INSTITUTE. TOOK ALL OF THE
RESEARCH AROUND WHAT WORKS IN
REDUCING RECIDIVISM WHAT CAN WE
DO TO ACTUALLY IMPACT ADULT
CRIMINAL THINKER. AND THEY TOOK
THAT RESEARCH META ANALYSIS AND
TURNED IT INTO A FRAMEWORK THAT
PROVIDERS LECTURE REENTRY AND
OTHERS CAN PUT INTO PRACTICE.
THIS FRAMEWORK IS KNOWN AS THE
EIGHT PRINCIPLES OF EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION AND I REALLY WANT
TO BRING THAT BACK TO THE TABLE
BECAUSE UTILIZING THOSE
INTERVENTION FOR THE POPULATION
WERE DISCUSSING. THE
RESPONSIBLE AND ETHICAL THING
TO DO I'VE BEEN VERY PROUD TO
BE ABLE TO SAYS. THAT AT G. A
REENTRY WE ARE OPERATIONALIZE
AND THERE'S PRINCIPLES EVERY
pEARLIER A HOW OF PRO. AND
EXPERTS IN OUR FIELD THE- THREE
WAYS TO MEASURE PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS THE FIRST ONE
BILLION RECIDIVISM REDUCTION
WHICH HAS BEEN MENTIONED TODAY
OF COURSE IT HAS ITS PROS AND
IT'S CONS WE OFTEN HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE MEASURING APPLES TO
APPLES HERE. BUT AGAIN IF THAT
CONTINUES TO BE THE GOLD
STANDARD SO REDUCTIONS IN
RECIDIVISM NUMBER TWO WHICH
HASN'T REALLY BEEN MENTIONED
TODAY IS INTERMEDIATE OUTCOMES
SO THINGS SUCH AS REDUCTIONS IN
CRIMINAL THINKING REDUCTIONS
INVALIDATED RESTS CORE IT
DIDN'T AND EMPLOYMENT GAIN SOME
SOBRIETY ACTUAL OUTCOME MATCHA
IS SO NOT DATA POINTS LIKE HOW
MANY PEOPLE COMPLETED A PROGRAM
BUT TRUE BEHAVIOR TENANTS. AND
THEN THE THIRD ONE ONE OF MY
FAVORITE IS ACTUALLY APPARENT
THE EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES SO
GOING BACK TO THE FRAMEWORK
THERE'S EIGHT PRINCIPLES ARE WE
MEASURING UP PROGRAMS AT HERONS
TO THE RESET ARE WE ACTUALLY
YOU UTILIZING VALIDATED
ASSESSMENTS THAT MEASURE
WHETHER OR NOT A PROGRAM IS.
GOING TO THE FIDELITY OF WHAT
WORKS TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM AT
GEO REENTRY WE HAVE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE
HAVE OUTCOME MEASURES THAT SHOW
THAT WERE IMPACTING BEHAVIOR
TENANTS THAT WERE IMPACTING THE
LIVES THAT WE SIT HERE AND TALK
TO ALL. OF YOU ABOUT TO DEBT WE
WOULD LOVE TO INVITE ALL OF YOU
AT ANY TIME AND YOU THE PROBE
THAT WE- ACROSS STATE. ARE WE
MENTIONED WOMEN'S CUSTODY
ISSUES TODAY WE HAVE A
FANTASTIC PROGRAM AND MCFARLAND
WE ALSO HAVE PROGRAMS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND MANY COUNTY ARE
THE REPORTING SENATE'S AS WELL.
SO WE CAN PROVIDE THE OUTCOME
MEASURES TO BACK UP THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE MORE
COMPASSES SO AND WITH EVERYONE
AND REALLY BE INVOLVED IN THIS
COMMITTEE. TO TALK ABOUT THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN BRING TO
THE TABLE AND THE FUTURE OF HOW
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON COULD
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE SPACE
TO ALLOWING US TO OFFER SOME
FEEDBACK IN OUR THOUGHTS MY
NAME IS FATIMA COM I'M WITH THE
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET CORRECT- I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON A FEW THINGS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE HEARING.
ANOTHER THINGS WAS THERE'S FEAR
OF LETTING PEOPLE OUT EARLY.
PROVIDING OVERCROWDING WHAT
WOULD THE BEST QUICKEST WAYS TO
MITIGATE THAT IS TO RELEASE
PEOPLE FROM INCARCERATION-
THERE HAS NOT BEEN THERE'S A
LOT OF STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT.
PEOPLE COMING HOME TO SEND
COMMUNITIES- IT DOES NOT
CORRELATE TO HIGHER CRIME RATES
OF THE FACT THAT THERE'S THIS
FEAR THAT IT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERN THE WAS VALID. IS NOT
SHOWING THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
INCREASED SPIKE OF CRIMES OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. WE HAVE
BEEN SENTENCING PEOPLE TO
REALLY LONG SENTENCES
UNNECESSARILY AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE.
CONTINUALLY WORKED ON AND
ADDRESSED- BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ONE THING THAT REALLY DOES
HELP PEOPLE COMING HOME
RETURNING HOME IS INVESTING IN
COMMUNITY CARE PROGRAM SO
COMMUNITY DRIVEN COMMUNITY LED.
AN COMMITTEE PROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE RETURNING HOME- ANOTHER
WAY TO MITIGATE THIS ISSUE OF
RECIDIVISM IS TO ALLOW FOR
START OF JUSTICE PROGRAMMING
BOTH ON THE FRONT AND IS AS A
DIVERSION. AND ALSO FOR PEOPLE
COMING HOME AND SHOULD NOT BE
DONE JUST FOR YOUNG PEOPLE ALSO
FOR ADULTS. I'M CURRENTLY IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY IN SOME SCHOOL
COUNTY WE HAVE. RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR
MINORS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
ARE. POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE
CHARGED WITH SOMETHING. OF WHEN
THEY PARTICIPANTS DIVERSION
PROGRAM THEY ARE THEN TRACKED.
OF THREE YEARS AFTER. AFTER
COMPLETING THIS RESTORED OF
PROGRAM. WHEN THEY'RE TRIED WE
CAN SEE THAT IN SOME CISCO
COUNTY THE RECIDIVISM RATE FOR
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE CIRCLES ARE
LESS THAN TEN PERCENT. SO LET'S
BEEN PERCENT OF PEOPLE OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE GONE THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM HAVE HAD ANY
CONTACT WITH PLEASE WITHIN
THREE YEARS OF FINISHING THE
PROGRAM AT IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
THAT NUMBER IS LESS THAN 20% SO
WE CAN SEE THAT THE OUR NUMBERS
WE HAVE EVIDENCE. IS THAT I CAN.
THAT CAN CURB AND CAN PEOPLE
OUT OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AND ON TOP OF THAT
RESTORED OF JUSTICE DOES
SOMETHING THAT OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM LACKS. IT DOES NOT A
RESERVE JUST AS HOLD THE SPACE
FOR VICTIM OFFENDER DIALOGUES
AND ALSO FOR HEALING THE FOR
ABLE TO WORK WITH PEOPLE.
DURING THE TIME OF AN OFFENSE
AND GET THEM AND THE AND THE
VICTIM TOGETHER TO.TO TALK
THINGS OUT TO COME TO.
SOLUTIONS AND TO ALSO LOOK AT
OKAY WELL WHAT BECAUSE THE
SITUATION TO HAPPEN AND WHY WE
CAN BE SAVING A LOT OF MONEY
AND HOPEFULLY BE DRIVING DOWN
THE POPULATION OF INCARCERATION
WERE DIVERTED PEOPLE AWAY. AND
LASTLY I THINK AND MANY OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNICATOR E.
THAT TURNING OVER RE ENTRY
PROGRAMS AND TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING TO PRIVATE COMPANIES
SUCH AS GEO GROUP IN OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS NEVER BEEN A
GOOD THING IT'S ALWAYS BEEN- IF
SOMEONE IS COMING HOME FROM
CONSERVATION THE LAST THING
THEY NEED IS TO BE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT MIMICS
PUNITIVE. MEASURES PRACTICES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND THAT'S
THE PROBLEM THAT WE ARE SEEING
CONTINUOUSLY AND BEST PRACTICES
WE THING IS TO PULL AWAY FROM
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH FRASER I'M ALSO WITH
THE AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE AND A MEMBER
ORGANIZATION OF CURB
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET- IT'S A REAL
PLEASURE TO BE IN A ROOM FOR A
SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT
CLOSING PRESENCE IN CALIFORNIA
AND I WANT TO START MY REMARKS
BY URGING FOLKS TO HAVE A
SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT NOT
JUST CLOSING ONE PRISON BUT
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO CLOSE THREE FOUR FIVE
PRISONS IN THE COMING YEARS.
AND SENATOR SKINNER YOU ASKED
FOR REDUCTION STRATEGIES THAT
COULD LEAD TO THESE KINDS OF
CLOSURES AND I THINK THE THING
THAT I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON TODAY
IS AROUND SENTENCING- WE HEARD
EARLIER FROM MISTER GRAVES THAT
THE RESEARCH DOES NOT SUPPORT
THAT LONGER SENTENCES MEANS
BETTER PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE'VE
HEARD- EXAMPLES TODAY OF WAYS
THAT WE CAN DO THAT REPEALING
THREE STRIKES HI MISTER WILEY
MENTIONS THAT THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE SEARCHLIGHT
SENTENCES WE ALSO HAVE OVER
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE SENTENCES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. ISRAEL STRONGLY
URGING. BUT JUST DIRTY
CONSIDERATE. LA WITHOUT PAROLE
SENTENCES TO REPEAL TREES. STE
WE HAD A KIND. TO T. HERE OR
ELDER PAROLE AND- I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT ABOUT 24% OF THE
CURRENT POPULATION. THAT'S
INCARCERATED IN CDC OURS OVER
THE AGE OF FIFTY CURRENTLY
THAT'S WAY HIGHER AS A
PROPORTION THAN IT'S EVER BEEN
IN AS WE DISCUSSED TODAY THAT'S
BECAUSE OF THE LEGACY OF
EXTREME SENTENCING. CURB IS
RECOMMENDING IT THAT THAT THE
THRESHOLD FOR OLDER PAROLE
ELIGIBILITY BE REDUCED TO FIFTY
YEARS OF AGE AND PEOPLE THAT
HAVE SERVED FIFTEEN YEARS OF
THEIR SENTENCES. WE'D BE HAPPY
TO SHARE A MEMO WITH YOU
EXPLAINING THE RESEARCH BEHIND
THAT IN THE REASONINGS FOR OUR
OUR RECOMMENDATION OF THAT. THE
OTHER PIECE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY IS THAT IN RECENT
YEARS THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
LEGISLATION AND HISTORIC
LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN PASSED.
WITH REDUCED- AND ELIMINATED
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS BUT NONE
OF THESE BILLS HAVE BEEN
RETROACTIVE- NOW THERE'S A LOT
OF REASONS FOR THAT ONE OF
WHICH IS THAT IT WOULD COST A
LOT OF MONEY TO MAKE IT THOSE
BILLS RETROACTIVE INTO APPLY
THOSE SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS
REPEALS TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING TIME FOR
THEM. WHAT I WAS HEARING TODAY
IS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
SPENDING THIRTEEN AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS ON CORRECTIONS
IN IN OUR STATE AND WE'VE GOT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS. OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS
HONOR ON OURS STATE PRISONS I
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THAT AND I
THINK IN THE LONG RUN IN THE
LONG TERM AT THE HIGH. LEVEL
ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES. A LONG
TERM. ABLE REDUCTIONS IN PRISON
POPULATIONS I WOULD HOPE THAT
WE CAN HAVE A SERIOUS
CONVERSATION ABOUT APPLYING
THESE BILLS RETROACTIVELY TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
SERVING TIME. I TO ME COMMUNITY
CARE ENHANCES PUBLIC SAFETY AND
I THINK TO SOME OF THESE STEPS
WE CAN INVEST STRONGLY AND
COMMUNITY CARE AS A WAY TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY- THE LAST
THING THAT I JUST LIKE TO SAY
IS THAT I HAD. CURB HAS SEVENTY
MEMBER ORGANISATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ONLY
ONE OF US WAS ABLE TO MAKE IT
HERE TODAY. AND SO I HOPE THAT
THERE WILL BE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SUBMISSIONS OF FEEDBACK ONLINE
OR THROUGH OTHER MECHANISMS FOR
GROUPS THAT AREN'T ABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY. THAT HAVE STRONG
RESEARCH BASED- SUGGESTIONS OF
WAYS THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS A
POSSIBILITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ANY
REMAINING PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
AND- FOR YOUR INSIGHT YOUR
SUGGESTIONS YOUR OBSERVATIONS-
AND CLEARLY AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER- MY SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
BE GETTING INTO A LOT OF THESE
IN MORE DETAIL AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING MANY OF YOU
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN. AND
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR ALSO PARTICIPATING AND
STAFF FOR THE PREPARATION.
FRANCIS OVER EVERYONE ELSE IN
WITH THAT ANALYSTS SPECIFIC
GENRE SURGERY RIGHT IN WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW BE. A JURY.
RIGHT.